GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THE FIRST HEARING OF THE JOINT
RULES SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE.
SINCE OCTOBER BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE HAVE TAKEN
INITIAL STEPS TO ADDRESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A HOTLINE FOR
VICTIMS TO CONNECT TO COUNSELING
AND RESOURCES. BOTH HOUSES HAVE
AGREED TO RELEASE INTERNAL
RECORDS OF SUBSTANTIATED
COMPLAINTS.
AND PERHAPS MOST NOTABLY WITH
COME TOGETHER WITH BIPARTISAN
BICAMERAL APPROACH
TO CRAFT NEW POLICIES ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY.
AT THIS POINT I'D LIKE TO TURN
IN MY VAULT MY COLLEAGUE AND
VICE CHAIR SENATOR MITCHELL FOR
ANY OPENING REMARKS YOU'D LIKE
TO MAKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY IN
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AS YOU ALL WILL HERE THROUGHOUT
THE COURSE OF TODAY'S HEARING
THAT WILL HAVE A NUMBER OF FACT
FINDING HEARING TO THAT'S THE
INTO THE HEARING PROCESS.
WE LOOK FOR TO HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT TO
OUR RESPECTIVE HOUSES IN THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE ON A PLAN
OF ACTION FOR GOING FORWARD.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE PUBLIC
HEARINGS ARE ONLY ONE METHOD
THAT THIS COMMITTEE WILL UTILIZE
INFORMING OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
WILL HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH EXPERTS IN
HUMAN RESOURCE PRACTITIONERS.
WHILE THE FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
MUST LOOK BEYOND TO THE ISSUE OF
GENDER EQUITY AND CREATING A
OVERALL CULTURE OF INCLUSION.
HINTS THE TOPIC OF TODAY'S
HEARING.
WE NEED TO WORK COLLECTIVELY TO
CREATE A CULTURE IN WHICH WOMEN
ARE VALUED WOMEN ARE PERCEIVED
AS EQUALS AND THAT EMPLOYEES
HAVE MUTUAL RESPECT FOR EACH
OTHER.
AS MY CHAIR ONE INCIDENT MADE
STRIDES THUS FAR BUT WE'RE CLEAR
THAT NOW'S THE TIME TO REALLY
PUSH THE ENVELOPE FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WORKPLACE CULTURE. AND THE
ROLE WOMEN CAN AND MUST PLAY IN
THE WORKPLACE HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL AS WELL AS ACROSS OUR
STATE AND COUNTRY.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS CHANCE
TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND THIS
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY COME TOGETHER IN A
BICAMERAL FASHION.
AS. MY OUT HERE AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED ON NUMEROUS OCCASIONS
ALREADY WE KNOW THAT THIS IS.
A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE.
TO REALLY SET A PRECEDENT AND
FORGE A PATTERN HOPEFULLY
APPARENT IN PRACTICE WITH THE
TWO HOUSES CAN COME TOGETHER.
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION AND
DEVELOP POLICY THAT GOVERNS THIS
UNIT GOVERNS THIS UNIQUE PLACE
CALLED THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE
BEEN SO MUCH TIME IN OUR
RESPECTIVE HOUSES.
GOING TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
THIS IS A DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITY
THAT I HOPE ALL OF US ALL OF YOU
ARE AS EAGER AS THE CHAIRWOMAN
AND I. TO UNDERTAKE AND FORGE A
NEW PATH TOWARD SELF GOVERNANCE.
WE ALSO GREATLY APPRECIATE OUR
PANELISTS TODAY WHO WILL HELP US
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW TO CHANGE
AND INFORM OUR CULTURE AND
ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS
ALL THOSE WHO ENTER THE BUILDING
ARE RESPECTED. AND FEEL SAFE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR WOULD ANY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE COMMISSION
OF THE COMMITTEE I LIKE TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS ISRAEL'S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AS WE COME TOGETHER IT IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT WE NOT ONLY EXPLORE
THE BEST PRACTICES FOR CHANGING
pBUT ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WOULD AN
ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL AROUSAL
ARREST BEEN CAREERS. EVERYONE
DESERVES TO BE PROTECTED. AND
GET ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS.
THE WELL BEING OF A BUSINESS
RELIES ON THE MORALE OF ITS
EMPLOYEES.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THE EXAMPLE
SET BY THOSE IN POSITIONS OF
POWER WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION.
WE MUST EXPECT OUR LEADERS AND
PEOPLE OF POWER TO SET THE
EXAMPLE IN THE STADLER'S A
POSITIVE CULTURE.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT IT HASN'T
BEEN THE CASE
FOR ALL THESE YEARS.
S. CHANGING CULTURE WILL NOT
COME OVERNIGHT.
IT WILL COME AS A RESULT OF OUR
DAY TO DAY CONVERSATIONS. OUR
HARD WORK INTENDED TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM. AND OUR COMMITMENT
TO CHANGE.
I ALONG WITH ALL OF YOU I HOPE
TO LEARN.
HOW WE COULD TAKE PRACTICAL
STEPS
TO ENSURE THAT NO ONE IS IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE FEAR OF
RETALIATION PREVENTS THEM FROM
SEEKING JUSTICE?
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDED THIS FORUM
TO MAKE OUR RESPECTIVE HOUSES
BETTER. FOR EVERYONE THAT
PARTICIPATES IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
I ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
I AM FULLY PERMITTED TO THIS
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT WE NOT
ONLY CREATE ROBUST POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT THAT WE CREATE A CULTURE OF
RESPECT.
DIGNITY AND PREVENTION.
I DO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR.
WELL CHAIR VICE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THE MEMBERS AND
LEADERSHIP ON BOTH SIDES FOR
THEIR WORK.
FOR OUR WORK AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY. A SENATOR
MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S AN
HONOR TO SERVE WITH YOU.
ON THIS
CRITICAL SUBJECT MATTER.
I HAVE.
I'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
AND SO HAS SENATOR BATES
WE WERE BOTH COUNTY SUPERVISORS
IN TWENTY TWELVE WHEN WE HAD.
ONE OF OUR KEY MANAGERS.
.
WHO ALLOT OF OUR FEMALE
EMPLOYEES?
REQUESTED SOME ASSISTANCE IN.
AND SO.
AS A GROUP OF FIVE WE CAN MAKE
CHANGES RATHER QUICKLY AND WE
DID.
BUT THE PROCESS HERE SEEMS TO
BE MOVING A LITTLE.
SLOWER AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT.
DIFFERENT SETTING.
BUT.
.
WE FORTY HAD TO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
RESIGNED AND WE'VE GOT.
SENATOR ON LEAVE OF ABSENCE.
AND SO JUST LIKE ORANGE COUNTY
HAD A BIG BLACK EYE IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IT'S LIKE THE
CAPITAL HAS A BIG BLACK GUY.
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW IN IT IT I'D
LIKE TO. KEEP THINGS MOVE MAYBE
A LITTLE. QUICKER SITE
APOLOGIZING APPRECIATE ALL THAT
YOU PUT TOGETHER.
I WROTE A LETTER TO THE CHAIR
JUDICIARY ON EIGHT QUESTIONS I'D
LOVE TO SEE. ADDRESSED. I
APPRECIATE THAT.
A PROCESS BUT I STILL FEEL LIKE
WE'RE JUST DOING THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL MAYBE I
WANNA GO. A LITTLE LOWER I DON'T
SEE THAT.
SECRETARY THE SENATE AS A
PANELIST I DON'T SEE THE
DIRECTOR OF RECHARGE THE
PANELISTS AND SO MAYBE I GUESS I
WOULD CONCLUDE BY SAYING.
THAT.
YOU'RE DECLARING THAT WE WILL
DEVELOP REAL SOLUTIONS I
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND I JUST WANNA KNOW HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ACCOMPLISH THAT HOW CAN
WE HELP YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISS WALDRON. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I'LL JUST SAY COUPLE BRIEF
WORDS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
CULTURE.
IT'S REALLY. NOT SOMETHING THAT
SAYS.
SPROUTS UP OVERNIGHT.
CULTURE IS SOMETHING THAT
DEVELOPS OVER TIME THE SEEDS ARE
SOWN YOU KNOW IN.
THE OUTSIDE LIVE OUR LIVES OUR
HISTORY OUR YOU KNOW OF TWO
GENERATIONS. AND.
IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT TOPIC.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU KNOW AS MS
REYES ALLUDED TO.
THERE'S THAT POWER STRUCTURE
WHEN YOU GET FROM A CULTURE
THAT'S KIND OF BUBBLING UP AND
THEN YOU.
HAVE A POWER STRUCTURE WHERE
THERE ARE SOME WHO ARE POWER
LESS AND SOME WHO ARE.
YOU KNOW FEELING.
THAT NO ONE'S LISTENING THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY.
WHERE TO TURN?
THAT CAN REALLY CULTIVATE.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT NOW WE HAVE SEEN SPROUTED
SO.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
HEARING AND A LOT WILL COME OUT
OF IT THAT WE'LL HAVE TO DIGEST
OBVIOUSLY. AND.
.
YOU KNOW WE ALL SHARE THE SAME
COMMON GOAL OF.
YEAH FINDING IT END TO THIS.
YOU KNOW PROTECTING OUR VICTIMS
IN MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW WE
CAN CHANGE THIS CULTURE WHICH IS
A BIG. PARADIGM SHIFT.
THANK YOU.
WOULD ANY OTHER. MIDDLE BY
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE ON THIS
COMMITTEE THIS IS OUR MOMENT IN
TIME THIS IS WHERE WE HAVE A
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO. TO DO THE
DEEP DIVE AFTER WE DO THE
OVERVIEW BUT IT'S OUR MOMENT
TIME TO CHANGE THE CULTURE THAT
WE LIVE IN WE LIVE IN A CULTURE
OF RAPE. IF WE ANYONE WAS
WATCHING CNN TODAY AND THEY SAW
WARY NOW SIR AND THE USA
GYMNASTICS AND WHAT THAT MAN DID
TO A HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO YOUNG
WOMEN. IS UNCONSCIONABLE AND
IT'S NOT JUST HE IT IS THOSE WHO
ENABLED AND THIS IS OUR MOMENT
THIS IS WHERE WE AS WOMEN CAN
HAVE EACH OTHER'S BACKS THIS IS
WHERE MEN CAN SAY. DUDE THAT'S
NOT COOL DON'T DO THAT WE ARE
ALL RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS AND
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE IT AND FIX IT. AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE KIM SO HAPPY
TO BE HERE.
SO JUST TO HIM REPLY A LITTLE TO
THE SENATORS.
QUESTION AND IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND IT'S A QUESTION I
THINK WE'VE ALL BEEN ASKING
OURSELVES ARM.
HOW QUICKLY DO WE MOVE I THINK
ALL OF US PROBABLY WALKED IN THE
DOOR WITH SOME IDEA OF WHAT OF
OF?
POLICIES THAT WE COULD IMPLEMENT
THAT WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
BUT I THINK WE OWE IT TO THE
PUBLIC TO THE PEOPLE IN THIS
BUILDING ARE REALLY INTO THE
WHOLE STATE TO TAKE A DEEP DIVE
INTO THESE ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY'RE COMPLICATED. NOW SEXUAL
HARASSMENT DIDN'T JUST DEVELOP
OVERNIGHT.
WE'VE HAD DECADES
OF WORKPLACE IMBALANCES AND OF A
CULTURE THAT'S CREATED THE
SITUATION AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SOLVE IT IN ONE HERE
ARE NOT GOING TO SOLVE IT
OVERNIGHT.
WE HAVE OUR WE LEARNED IN THE
LAST HEARING THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HELD THAT OUR HUMAN RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT HAS.
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT ARE
VERY SIMILAR TO THOSE FOUND
ACROSS CORPORATE AMERICA AND
MANY OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
YET WE STILL HAVE A PROBLEM.
SO WE NEED TO REALLY TAKE THE
TIME TO LOOK AT ALL OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE INVOLVED BECAUSE
THEY'RE NEW WANTS THEIR NEW
OSCAR. NUANCE BECAUSE OF OUR
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE THEIR NEW
WANTS BECAUSE OF.
THE WHERE OUR OFFICES ARE THERE
NUANCED FOR VERY MANY REASONS
THAT MAKE THEM A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT FROM A LOT OF OTHER
PLACES. AND YET WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM AGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE HAD SIMILAR
PROBLEMS AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES THROUGH
POLICY CHANGES AND WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM EXPERTS WHO HAVE BEEN
STUDYING THIS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
TO LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES BOTH
FOR PREVENTION AND TRAINING
IMPORTANT FOR POLICIES AND FOR
WAYS OF HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. WE HAVE ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT INVOLVING
TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE WE ARE
ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT SOMETIMES
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR YOU DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE.
EVEN SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT AS I
SPEAK TO EXPERTS HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND WE NEED TO IT
EXAMINE ALL OF THOSE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A VERY
DEEP DIVE SO BE READY BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA REALLY GET INTO
THESE ISSUES AND TODAY IS GOING
TO BE MORE OF A TWENTY THOUSAND.
FOOT VIEW ABOUT CULTURE CHANGE
AND HOW THAT'S DONE BUT AS WE
PROGRESS FORWARD WE'RE GONNA
START REALLY DRILLING DOWN INTO
ALL OF THOSE AREAS. INTO
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES INTO PRIVACY
ISSUES INTO RETALIATION INTO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND GO INTO THOSE
IN DETAIL SO THAT BY THE END OF
THIS.
WE CAN TAKE.
INGREDIENTS FROM OTHER AGENCIES
FROM ALL OF THE EXPERTS
AND TUNE THEM TO OUR PARTICULAR
SITUATION ON OUR TYPE OF
GOVERNANCE HERE IN THIS BUILDING
WITH OUR CULTURE. WITH
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE GETTING
THROUGH OUR CULTURE SURVEY FROM
OUR EMPLOYEES FROM INFORMATION
WE GET FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
INPUT AND CREATES SOMETHING THAT
I THINK WILL BE THE MODEL FOR
THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY HERE
DESERVES US TAKING THE TIME TO
DO THAT CORRECTLY AND
UNAPOLOGETICALLY IN TO RELIEVE
THAT ALL OF THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE
WE MAY NOT BE HERE NO ONE MAY BE
DOING THIS FOR TEN MORE YEARS MY
HOPE IS. THAT WHAT WE DO HERE IS
SO POWERFUL THAT NO ONE EVER HAS
TO DO THIS AGAIN.
SO I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION ARM
BUT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
DISAPPOINTED I THINK IN THE
INFORMATION THAT COMES OUT AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT I HAVE MY
LISTENING EARS OPEN BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF EXPERTS
COMING IN. AND I'M REALLY
ANXIOUS TO HEAR THEM. AND WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
CALL OUR FIRST PANEL.
THAT WAS THE PLAN OF ACTION. ARM
WELL I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE YOU
KNOW WE WE HAVE AGENDAS RIGHT
NOW THAT THAT REALLY GET INTO
THOSE ISSUES IN DEPTH AND THEIR
EVOLVING AND CHANGING. BASED ON
TESTIMONY THAT WE'RE HEARING AND
PEOPLE THAT ARE BROUGHT TO US
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO BE
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH BUT THOSE ARE
THE MAIN ISSUES. TRANSPARENCY
ISSUES NOT JUST HOW WE MAKE
THINGS TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC
WHO HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW BUT
MAKING SURE THAT OUR PROCESS IS
UNDERSTANDABLE TO EVERYBODY WHO
COMES IN CONTACT WITH THE
BUILDING. BECAUSE EVERYBODY HAS
A RIGHT TO THAT PROCESS WHETHER
YOU'RE A LOBBYIST OR MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC OR AN INTERN OR AN
EMPLOYEE OR AND OR REMEMBER.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S THAT'S NOT
SUBJECTIVE THAT'S MORE OBJECTIVE
BASED ON OBJECTIVE STANDARDS.
I'M AND OF.
THAT WE HAVE MUCH MORE
PROTECTIVE.
POLICIES THAT PREVENT
RETALIATION AGAINST PEOPLE WHO
BRING CLAIMS FOR AND AGAINST
WITNESSES AS WELL.
AND ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE BEST PREVENTION AND TRAINING
THAT WE CAN POSSIBLY HAVE SO
THOSE ARE THE GENERAL AREAS
NOTABLY EXPLORING. HOW WITHOUT
LET ME BRING THE PANEL FOREIGN?
PANEL IF YOU'D LIKE TO COME UP
.
AND RATHER THAN READ YOUR BIOS
I'M GOING TO ALLOW YOU. THE
SPACE TO INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AS
YOU SEE FIT.
MEMBERS I WOULD. ASK THAT WE NOT
ASK QUESTIONS OF EACH PANELIST
UNTIL THE END BECAUSE WHO'S
GOING TO BE SOME OVERLAP IN
CONTENT AND SOMEBODY ELSE MIGHT
ANSWER A QUESTION OR GIVE YOU
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT YOU
DIDN'T.
SO LET'S HOLD QUESTIONS UNTIL
THE END OF ALL THE PRESS.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND AND BEGAN.
MY NAME IS JANET DOWN HARD I'M
THE NEW AND PROFESSOR OF PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRICE SCHOOL.
.
IF I CAN OF SPEAKING FIRST I
GUESS A CALF.
I TEACH ORGANIZATIONAL BEHAVIOR
LEADERSHIP AND ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE CHANGE.
I'VE WRITTEN.
FIVE BOOKS A ROOM GONE PUBLIC
SERVICE VALUES
ON LEADERSHIP.
AND ALL OF WHICH TO A GREATER
OR LESSER DEGREE OF DEALT WITH
THE CONCEPT OF ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE.
A I AM NOT AN EXPERT ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT POLICY BUT I DO BRING
EXPERTISE ON ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE. AND HOW TO MANAGE I'M
CULTURAL CHANGE.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN OF BY AND.
DIRECTING YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
TO THE.
SLIDE BECAUSE I'M A TEACHER I DO
POWER POINT.
.
MY ROLE HERE TODAY IS IS TO SORT
OF CREATE.
GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW OF WHAT
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE IS FROM
AN ACADEMIC PERSPECTIVE WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT.
HOW ITS ESTABLISHED AND HOW IT
CAN BE CHANGED?
IN ITS SIMPLICITY A LOT OF VERY
UNCOMPLICATED ACADEMIC
DEFINITIONS OF ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE BUT I THINK THE SIMPLEST
ONE IS. ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE
IS THE WAY THINGS ARE REALLY
DONE AROUND HERE.
IT'S NOT THE STATED POLICIES ITS
NOT THE STATED VALUES IF THE WAY
THINGS REALLY WORK.
BEHIND THE SCENES.
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE IS IN
FACT BEEN.
OFTEN LIKENED TO AN ICEBERG.
UP AT THE TOP OF THE ICEBERG
THAT WHICH IS VISIBLE ABOVE THE
WATER. ARE THE STRUCTURES THE
PROCEDURES THE POLICIES THE
STATED PHILOSOPHY AND STRATEGY.
BUT YOU'LL NOTE THAT THE BULK OF
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE IS
BENEATH THE SURFACE.
IT WHERE THOSE UNSPOKEN
ASSUMPTIONS ARE WHERE THOSE
BEHAVIORAL NORMS ARE THAT ARE
INFORMALLY COMMUNICATED BUT VERY
STRICTLY ENFORCED.
SO WHY IS ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE
IMPORTANT I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE COMMENTS I HEARD ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT CULTURE IS THIS IS
NOT.
THAT THIS CANNOT BE SOLVED BY
ESTABLISHING A POLICY ALONE.
ALL CHANGE OCCURS WITHIN A
CULTURAL CONTEXT.
AND I'D.
YOU CAN CHANGE ALL OF THE FORMAL
PROCEDURES YOU CAN CHANGE.
OUT THE STRUCTURE THAT WON'T
CHANGE ANYTHING INTO YOU AND
CHANGE THE UNDER UNDERLYING
CULTURE AS WELL.
CULTURE GUIDES AND CONTROLS
BEHAVIOR POLICIES ARE IMPORTANT
RULES ARE IMPORTANT BUT CULTURE
IS IS THE PRIMARY DETERMINED OF
HUMAN BEHAVIOR AND
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND AS YOU KNOW IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR THERE ARE HIGHER
STANDARDS AND MULTIPLE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS MAKING THIS
pMORE COMPLICATED AND MORE
DIFFICULT I THINK CULTURAL
CHANGE IN PUBLIC IMMIGRANT
ORGANIZATIONS CAN BE MORE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF THE
QUESTION OF TRANSPARENCY.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE ARE SO
MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
PETER DRUCKER WHO IS A FAMOUS
MANAGEMENT THEORISTS SAID
CULTURE EAT STRATEGY FOR
BREAKFAST.
AND BY THAT HE MEANT THAT IF
THERE IS A CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
NORMS OF THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE AND THE RULES OF THE
ORGANIZATION. CULTURE WILL WIN.
MY COROLLARY TO THAT IS THAT
CULTURE EATS POLICY FOR LUNCH.
I AM IT'S THERE'S NO CONTEST IT
UNLESS YOU CAN GET IN AND BEGIN
TO. TO MOVE THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE IN A DIRECTION
CONSISTENT WITH THE KINDS OF
POLICIES AND NORMS THAT YOU WANT
TO IMPLEMENT YOU YOU WILL NOT
SUCCEED IN TERMS OF
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT.
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURES WHICH
ARE BASED ON RESPECT INCLUSION.
TRUST AND SAFETY ARE THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE AND EFFECTIVE
ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS DOESN'T THIS IS JUST WORK
HERE OF COURSE TODAY'S TALK
ABOUT SEXUAL I'M HARASSMENT BUT
THESE ARE THE QUALITIES OF
ORGANIZATIONS.
I'M ACROSS THE BOARD PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE THAT LEAD TO MORE
RESILIENT MORE PRODUCTIVE
ORGANIZATIONS.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
TAKE CALCULATED RISKS
IF YOU WANT PEOPLE TO COOPERATE
WITH EACH OTHER THEY HAVE TO
TRUST EACH OTHER AND THEY HAVE
TO FEEL SAFE AND THAT'S.
EVERYONE IN THE ORGANIZATION NOT
NOT JUST WOMEN.
SO HOW IS CULTURE ESTABLISHED
AND THE SHORT ANSWER IS IT'S
ESTABLISHED VERY VERY SLOWLY.
PROBABLY THE FOUNDERS OF
INSTITUTIONS HAVE MORE OF A ROLE
IN AND ESTABLISHING
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE THAN
ANYONE ELSE.
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO THAT
TO REMEMBER THAT CULTURE IS
COLLECTIVE.
IT IS ENOUGH FOR ONE OR TEN
PEOPLE TO SAY WE ARE GOING TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE AND IT IS
GOING TO BECOME THIS.
CULTURE IS FRAMED COLLECTIVELY
BY M. EVERY MEMBER OF THAT
ORGANIZATION.
AND SO EVERYONE NEEDS TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY NOT JUST THE PEOPLE
AT THE TOP.
CULTURE IS ALSO BASED ON
LEARNING AS NEW PEOPLE COME INTO
THE ORGANIZATION CULTURE SHIFTS
AS NEW IDEAS COME IN.
I'M IN ALSO CHANGES IN RESPONSE
TO EXTERNAL FORCES BELIEFS
VALUES ASSUMPTIONS BROUGHT IN
FROM THE OUTSIDE AND CERTAINLY
THE NEWS THAT WE'RE HEARING. DAY
AFTER DAY.
IN IN HOLLYWOOD IN SPORTS IN I
BUSINESS I'M IS HAVING AN EFFECT
ON HOW WE VIEW OUR BEHAVIOR IN
PUBLIC ORGANIZATIONS AND SO WE
BRING THAT IN WITH US.
PEOPLE LEARN CULTURE NOT BY
BEING HANDED A HANDBOOK.
I'M PEOPLE LEARN CULTURE BY
GOING OUT TO LUNCH WITH PEOPLE.
AND CULTURE IS COMMUNICATED
THROUGH STORIES AND WHAT I'M
SURE WHEN YOU CAME TO WORK HERE
PEOPLE HAD STORIES ABOUT THINGS
THAT PEOPLE HAD DONE IN WAYS
THINGS THAT HAPPENED.
SYMBOLS LANGUAGE JARGON.
STATEMENTS OF PRINCIPLE ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. INFLUENCE HOW WE
LEARN CULTURE IN AN
ORGANIZATION.
AND CULTURES DIFFERS MARKEDLY
FROM ORGANIZATION TO
ORGANIZATION
SO AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE HAS A CULTURE THAT
IS UNIQUE. I'M BASED ON HIS
HISTORY BASED ON THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN YEAR BASED ON THE
STORIES THAT HAVE BEEN TOLD.
SO THE GOOD NEWS IS THE CULTURE
CAN BE CHANGED.
I'M.
THE BEST PRACTICES IN.
ORGANIZATIONS.
IS THAT YOU HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE DESIRED BEHAVIORAL
NORMS ARE ON A REGULAR BASIS.
CULTURE CHANGES WHEN LEADERSHIP
PAYS ATTENTION ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
I AM SECOND.
HOW SO?
HOW AN ORGANIZATION REACTS
THE CRITICAL INCIDENTS?
AND AND EVENTS IS GOING TO BE
WATCHED VERY VERY CAREFULLY
THOSE WILL BECOME THE NEW
STORIES THAT PEOPLE TELL.
MODELING THE BEHAVIOR.
REWARDING HIGHLIGHTING DESIRED
BEHAVIOR.
SAY THAT.
SOME PART OF THE ORGANIZATION
HOLDS A FORUM.
WHERE I'M MEN AND WOMEN TALK
ABOUT?
WHAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE WHAT
THEY WOULD NEED TO FEEL SAFE?
WHAT THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THEIR OWN BEHAVIOR NOT
BEING OFFENSIVE TO OTHER PEOPLE
AND TO SHARE SUCCESSES AND TELL
STORIES?
OTHER ACTIONS ARE ALSO IMPORTANT
BUT THEY WILL NOT GET A CULTURAL
CHANGE
THEY A INFLUENCE IT BUT THEY
WILL NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO CHANGE
OR SHIFT THE CULTURE.
FORMAL STATEMENT OF POLICY.
TRAINING ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE AND CHANGING THE THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THOSE
THINGS ARE ALL IMPORTANT.
BUT THEY ARE ALONE NOT ENOUGH
AND AND I JUST MIGHT WANNA AND
KNOW THERE THAT THE TRAINING
THEY'RE. NOT JUST TRAINING FOR
AND.
HOW TO NOT HARASS
BUT TRAINING ABOUT HOW TO BE A
GOOD BYSTANDER HOW HOW TO BE?
RESPECTFUL OF ALL PEOPLE.
THERE IS ALWAYS RESISTANCE.
YOU CULTURAL CHANGE THERE WILL
BE RESISTANCE TO THIS CULTURAL
CHANGE
AND THE REASON FOR THAT. IS THAT
PEOPLE OPERATE AND AND FIND
THEIR SUCCESSES IN AN EXISTING
CULTURE AND WHEN YOU CHANGE THAT
CULTURE IT INTRODUCES
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT HOW THEY WILL
SUCCEED IN THE NEW CULTURE.
IT ALSO INTRODUCES.
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT HOW DOES HOW
HOW TO ACT.
.
THEY. WE CAN SAY DON'T DO THIS
AND DON'T DO THAT BUT IF YOU'RE
NOT TELLING PEOPLE IN A POSITIVE
WAY WHAT WHAT KINDS OF BEHAVIOR
YOU'RE TRYING TO INCULCATE.
AND PAST EXPERIENCES PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE GREAT EXPERIENCES
WITH ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE AS
OVITZ HANDLED INCLUSIVELY AND
RESPECTFULLY I'M YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE BETTER LUCK.
I'M.
SOME SOME SORT OF BOND FOOD FOR
THOUGHT. POSITIVE CULTURAL NORMS
ARE BY FAR THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
THAT IS.
HELPING PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE DESIRED BEHAVIOR IS.
IS FAR MORE EFFECTIVE THAN
SIMPLY EXPLAINING THE BEHAVIOR
TO AVOID.
IN OTHER WORDS PROHIBITING A
BEHAVIOR DOES NOT.
TELL PEOPLE HOW TO IN TURN
BEHAVE.
AND IT IS ALSO GOING TO CAUSE
MORE RESISTANCE POSITIVE
CULTURAL NORMS ARE FAR FAR MORE
POWERFUL.
AND CONSISTENT AND PERSISTENT
REINFORCEMENT OF VALUES IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND WHETHER YOU DO
THIRTY THOUSAND FEET OR DOWN IN
THE IN THE DEBTS. THE IMPORTANT
THING IS TO KEEP DOING IT AND IS
IS NOT A ONE TIME EVENT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
REINFORCED OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND  AND IT IS BEING
STARTED NOW. AND THAT'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT
YOU HAVE TO BEGIN.
AND I WOULD COMMAND AS A
CITIZEN I WOULD COMMEND THIS
COMMITTEE FOR BEGINNING.
.
CULTURE IS COLLECTIVE THE MORE
INCLUSION THE BETTER.
YOU DON'T WANT THIS TO BE A
WOMEN'S ISSUE YOU DON'T WANT
THIS TO BE AMENDS ISSUE THIS IS
AN EVERYONE ISSUE. AND THIS IS
ABOUT MAKING YOUR ORGANIZATION
MORE PRODUCTIVE A AND A BETTER
WORKPLACE FOR EVERYONE IN IT.
ANOTHER WAY TO SAY THIS IF YOU
LOOK DOWN AT THE BOTTOM IF YOU
FOCUS ON RULES AND CONTROL IN
ENFORCEMENT.
YOU DO TRYING TO AVOID THIS
BEHAVIOR AND AND PUNISHING THOSE
WHO ENGAGE IN IT. YOU MAY GET
COMPLIANCE BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA
GET COMMITMENT AND YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET CULTURE CHANGE.
ORGANIZATIONS AND STRUCTURAL
CHANGES ARE IMPORTANT IF THEY
ARE DONE IN AN ENVIRONMENT OF
EDUCATION A COMMUNICATION.
ENGAGEMENT AND FACILITATION
THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN GET THE
COMMITMENT TO THE CULTURAL
CHANGE.
SO I WOULD LEAVE THE AND
COMMITTEE WITH TWO QUESTIONS
ONE IS.
WHAT ARE THE CONSTRUCTIVE
CULTURAL NORMS YOU WANNA FOSTER?
NOT WHAT OF THE BEHAVIORS ARE
TRYING TO AVOID WHAT IS IT THAT
YOU WANT THIS WORKPLACE TO LOOK
LIKE.
I AND SECOND TO THINK CAREFULLY
ABOUT WHAT THE GREATEST SOURCE
OF CULTURE RESISTANCE TO CHANGE
IS.
IN IN THIS INSTANCE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT PALACE LETTUCE WANT TO I'M
LET THE PUBLIC IN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
POSTING THESE POWER POINTS ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S WEB PAGE WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND
TALK TO US.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME'S KATHLEEN SAUDI AND
I'M THE SYSTEM Y. TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND BEFORE THAT I WAS THE TITLE
NINE OFFICER UCLA.
I SO APPRECIATED LISTENING TO
MY CO PANELISTS BECAUSE SO MUCH
OF WHAT SHE SAID.
RESONATED I WAS GOING TO OPEN
MY COMMENTS WITH.
I THINK WHAT YOU REFER TO AS
OTHER ACTIONS UP WHICH WHICH. WE
AGREE OR NOT ENOUGH.
TO MOVE CULTURAL CHANGE BUT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT.
PRECURSORS TO THAT KIND OF
CULTURAL CHANGE
AND I WANTED TO TALK IT THROUGH
WITH YOU ON SOME OF THOSE STEPS
THAT YOU SEE HAS TAKEN. ON AS AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION THAT
SUBJECT I THAT RECEIVES FEDERAL
FUNDS WE ARE OBLIGATED UNDER
TITLE NINE.
TO STOP SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
SEXUAL ASSAULTS HAVE TO PREVENT
IT FROM HAPPENING AND HAPPENING
AGAIN AND THEN TO FIX IT.
DOTSON OBLIGATION THAT YOU SEE
HAS TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY AND.
RECKONED WITH OVER THESE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS LIKE MANY COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES HAVE.
STARTING IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WE
PUT TOGETHER A.
SYSTEM WIDE TASK FORCE OF
STUDENTS AND FACULTY AND STAFF
AND WE STARTED SOLICITING INPUT
FROM OUR COMMUNITY AS TO HOW WE
COULD BETTER. PREVENTION RESPOND
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT QUITTING
SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND WHAT WE HEARD.
FROM OUR PARTICULARLY OUR
SURVIVOR COMMUNITY THOSE WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SEXUAL VIOLENCE. IS
THAT.
WE NEEDED TO HAVE A VERY STRONG
POLICY AS A STARTER AND WE
NEEDED A SINGLE. TRANSPARENT
PROCESS FOR REPORTING AND
INVESTIGATING REPORTS NOW AGAIN
THIS IS NOT IN ITSELF GOING TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE BUT IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT.
FIRST STEP
THE INSTITUTION NEEDS TO CLEARLY
CONVEYANCE EXPECTATIONS AND
ESTABLISH A FAIR AND TRANSPARENT
PROCESS ON CONVEYING THAT WE
WILL HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE IF
THEY VIOLATE THOSE EXPECTATIONS.
WE ALSO IN SHORT AND I AND I
HEARD THE CHAIR REFERENCE THAT
IS.
THAT ARE COMPLAINANTS GET
INFORMED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEIR COMPLAINTS ABOUT WHAT IS
FOUND AND WHAT WAS DONE ABOUT IT
THAT SORT OF ACCOUNTABILITY. IS
VERY IMPORTANT OUR POLICY ALSO
HAS EXPLICIT PROTECTIONS OPERATE
HALLIE ATION FOR THOSE WHO
REPORT SEXUAL HARASSMENTAND
ALSO FOR THOSE WHO HELP.
INVESTIGATE OR REMEDY IT EITHER
AS WITNESS SAYS OR SOMEONE WHO
HELPS IMPLEMENT TO REMEDY WERE
VERY COGNIZANT OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT RETALIATION PARTICULARLY
IN CULTURES WHERE THERE ARE
POWER DIFFERENTIALS SUCH AS. AT
A UNIVERSITY.
WERE CERTAINLY HERE AS WELL.
I'M IT WAS ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
OUT BY LAW EVERY YOU SEE
LOCATION HAS HAVE A TITLE MIND
OFFICER.
ON THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
PERSON ON THE CAMPUS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE SORT OF
CENTRALIZED PLACE THAT TAKES ALL
REPORTS AND DIRECTS THE RESPONSE
AND.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT HAVE THAT
PERSON THERE INDEPENDENT ON
THEIR CENTRALIZED WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK SORT OF PUBLICIZING
I'M IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE OUR
COMMUNITY KNOWS WHERE TO GO TO
REPORT. AND THEN HAVING THAT
SORT OF CENTRALIZED REPORTING
DATABASE ENABLES THE TITLE MIND
OFFICER TO IDENTIFY PATTERNS.
IDENTIFY REPEAT OFFENDERS.
TRYIN ASSESS WHETHER MORE SORT
OF SYSTEMIC ACTIONS ARE REQUIRED
SO THAT TITLE NINE OFFICERS BEEN
REALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
RESPONSE.
.
AS IMPORTANT AS THOSE SORT OF
RESPONSIVE EFFORTS HAVE BEEN IN
AND THOSE REPORTING PROCESS
THESE.
IT'S BEEN PERHAPS
JUST AS IMPORTANT OR MORE
IMPORTANT TO SET UP
CONFIDENTIAL.
RESOURCES ON PLACES WHERE
SOMEONE WHO'S EXPERIENCING SEX
HARASSMENT SEXUAL VIOLENCE CAN
GO ON WITH OUT.
PUTTING THEIR EMPLOYER ON NOTICE
AND TRIGGERING A WHOLE PROCESS
THAT THEY MIGHT NOT BE READY TO
ENGAGE IN YET.
SO AT THE CAMPUS IS WE HAVE A
CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE.
WHO SERVES
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES TO
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE
OR SEXUAL HARASSMENT BUT WE ALSO
HAVE AN ARM BUDS OR EMPLOYEE
COUNSELING CENTER AND HAVING THE
ABILITY TO LEARN ABOUT WHAT THE
COMPLETE PROCESS MIGHT LOOK
LIKE?
IN A CONFIDENTIAL SETTING IS
VERY EMPOWERING FOR SOMEONE WHO.
MAYBE EXPERIENCING SEX
HARASSMENT GIVES THEM BACK SORT
OF A SENSE OF CONTROL.
IN A SPACE WHERE THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT FEELING THAT THEY'RE
FEELING THE SITUATION'S VERY OUT
OF CONTROL.
SO HAVING THOSE CONFIDENTIAL
RESOURCES ON HAS BEEN REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU SEE.
.
AND THOSE ARE REALLY ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW WE RESPOND AFTER
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SEXUAL
VIOLENCE HAS OCCURRED OF COURSE.
IDEALLY WE WOULD BE PREVENTING
AT AND AND AND NOT HAVING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SEXUAL.
ASSAULT.
OCCUR AND OUR LOCATIONS ON SO
WE FOCUSED A LOT ON.
PREVENTION AND AWARENESS AND.
I DO THINK IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE I
THINK.
FOR A LOT OF THE REASONS.
THAT MY CO PANELISTS IDENTIFIED
ITS.
PROBABLY THE MOST CHALLENGING
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE AS WELL.
.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY TO TRY AND HEAR FROM
THEM WHAT MESSAGES WOULD
RESONATE WITH THEM IN TERMS OF.
PREVENTION.
FOR OUR STUDENTS WE'RE REQUIRED
BY LAW.
BUT IT'S ALSO A GOOD IDEA TO
EDUCATE THEM ON BYSTANDER
INTERVENTION AND YOU MENTIONED.
BEING AN ACTIVE BYSTANDER AND I
THINK.
.
FOR ME WATCHING THIS ME TOO
MOVEMENT UNFOLDS.
SOME OF THE MORE RESIDENT.
DISCLOSURES HAVE BEEN FROM
THOSE BYSTANDERS THIS
PEOPLE WHO'VE SAID.
YOU KNOW I SAW THIS HAPPENING
AND I. AND I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT I MAY NOT HAVE KNOWN.
EXACTLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING BUT I
KNEW SOMETHING I DIDN'T STEP IN
AND I WISH I HAD. AND SO WE
REALLY TRY TO SPEAK TO OUR
STUDENTS.
ABOUT THAT WE REALLY HAVE TRIED
TO TRANSLATE THAT AND SPEAK TO
OUR OUR EMPLOYEES ABOUT THAT AS
WELL IN OUR FACULTY AND OUR
STAFF.
AND.
.
IT'S IMPORTANT IT'S BEEN
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO SORT OF.
HI THIS ISSUE TO UC'S MISSION
WHICH IS EDUCATION. AND RESEARCH
ON AND THINKING ABOUT TITLE NINE
AS A LAW ABOUT EQUAL ACCESS.
TO EDUCATION AND AND UP OF
SAFE AND FAIR WORKING
ENVIRONMENT AND I THINK.
FOR OUR FACULTY PARTICULARLY UP
IF THEY THINK ABOUT IT IN TERMS
OF. UNDERMINING THAT MISSION
THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT SEXUAL
VIOLENCE UNDERMINES THAT
EDUCATIONAL MISSION AND REALLY
CAN DERAIL.
STUDENT.
FROM.
PROGRESSING WITH THEIR ACADEMIC
CAREER ON I THINK THEY START TO
SEE OKAY THAT'S WHY I NEED TO
STEP IN. ON THOUGHTS Y. NEED TO
BE AN ACTIVE BYSTANDERS SO
THAT'S THE MESSAGE THAT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO SEND TOWARD
COMMUNITY AND. I THINK THE
MESSAGE REALLY DOES START AT THE
TOP SO WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO
HAVE PRESIDENT APOLLO TANO
REALLY. TAKE ON THIS ISSUE SPEAK
VERY PUBLICLY ABOUT IT SHE'S
NEVER.
PRETENDED THAT WE HAVE IT
FIGURED OUT SHE'S NEVER DENIED
THAT IT'S.
NOT BEEN A SERIOUS ISSUE BUT
SHE'S VERY PUBLICLY COMMITTED TO
TRYING TO FIT.
AND.
I THINK THAT THAT MESSAGE FROM
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN REALLY
IMPORTANT.
LISTENING TO UP MY CO PANELISTS
TALK ABOUT CULTURE CHANGE.
IT BROUGHT HOME TO ME AS WELL
THAT I THINK SOMETHING ELSE.
THAT HAS BEEN IMPORTANT IF.
PAINFUL.
HAS BEEN THE VERY PUBLIC
AND ONGOING RECKONING THAT YOU
SEE HAS HAD.
I DO WITH THIS ISSUE SO I THINK
I'M HAVING OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
.
NOT STRUGGLING WITH THIS HAS NOT
BEEN AN OPTION FOR US.
AND I THINK.
AS AS AS ONE OF YOU SAID THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS A MOMENT THIS IS THIS IS
THE TIME TO START THAT
CONVERSATION AND IN SOME WAYS.
.
YOU KNOW I I REMEMBER WHEN
SECRETARY DEVICE
SPOKE ABOUT.
.
ROLLING BACK THE TOTAL I
PROTECTIONS SHE KIND OF SAID I
WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THIS AT ALL.
.
AND.
THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER RIGHT.
WEEK IF.
WE DO HAVE TO TALK ABOUT IT AND
WE DO HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
REALITY AND I'M AS PAINFUL AS IT
IS. I THINK IT'S.
I THINK IT'S PROGRESS
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
AND BRING SOMEBODY AND THROUGH
THE INTERNET.
THE INTERNET'S A SO.
.
SKYPE I KNOW THAT WAS A BRANDED
COPYRIGHTED NAME I COULDN'T SAY.
I MISGUIDED DEMAND.
SO WE'RE GONNA GET THAT GOING
AND AND.
WHERE DOES THIS PANELIST WILL
STAY WITH US AFTERWARDS AS WELL
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
?
HELLO
.
WELCOME IF YOU WANT TO JUST
BRIEFLY INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
THEN.
JUST TELL US WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY AND THEN AFTERWARDS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER PANELIST
SPEAK AND THEN HOLD IT OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS.
IF YOU CAN STAND BY AFTER.
YOUR TESTIMONY.
AT I THINK MEANS I CAN'T THINK
VERY WELL I'M SO SORRY YES I AM
SPEAKING TO YOU HAVE BETTER
THINGS. OKAY HOT. THAT I THINK
YOU THANK YOU.
I AM I'M JOE WELL AMHERST AND
I'M THE FOUNDER AND CEO OF
PARADIGM WHERE ITS STRATEGY FIRM
THAT WORKS WITH ORGANIZATIONS TO
HELP THEM DESIGN. ONES EVER WERE
INCLUDES SEVEN ULTIMATELY
HEALTHIER CULTURES.
SO I CAN GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
ARE.
BACKGROUND ON ON HOW WE THINK
ABOUT THIS WORKING JUST A FEW
KEY THINGS ARE GONNA BE PRETTY
BRIEF RELATED TO YOU. ON THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I KNOW YOU'RE
HAVING TODAY.
FEEL FREE TO INTERRUPT ME IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS AND.
DO BEFORE FOUNDING PARADIGM I
WAS THAT WOMEN'S RIGHTS LAWYER
ON AND MY WORK INCLUDED IT'S
DOING COMPANIES FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
I THINK LITIGATION IS
UNDOUBTEDLY A REALLY POWERFUL IN
CRUCIAL TOOL FOR JUST S. BUT IN
MY WORK I FOUND THAT BY THE TIME
HARASSMENT CURZON'S CERTAINLY. I
TIME ACCOMPANIED BEING SUED FOR
IT ON A NUMBER OF THINGS HAVE
BROKEN DOWN AN ORGANIZATIONAL
LEVEL AND THAT'S WHAT LED ME TO
FOUND PARADIGM AND IT'S A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT. WHAT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY?
THEY'RE IN OUR WORK WITH
PARADIGM WE PARTNER WITH
ORGANIZATIONS TO DESIGN STRONGER
MORE INCLUSIVE CULTURES WHERE
EMPLOYEES FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS
CAN REALLY DRIVE.
AND KNOWING THAT YOU CAN GO TO
WORK EVERY DAY WITHOUT FEAR OF
BEING HARASSED AS A CORE PART
AND A HEALTHY INCLUSIVE CULTURE.
SO IN OUR WORK REALLY THINK
ABOUT HELPING ORGANIZATIONS
DESIGN CULTURES WHERE HARASSMENT
IS LESS LIKELY TO OCCUR.
AND WHERE IT'S TAKEN SERIOUSLY
AND ADDRESSED SWIFTLY WHEN IT
DOES.
SO I WANT TO TALK JUST BRIEFLY
ABOUT HOW TO BUILD DIVERSE
ORGANIZATIONS HOW TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. AND JUST A COUPLE
OF FACTORS TO CONSIDER WITH
RESPECT TO TRAINING BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT TRAINING OFTEN ONE
THAT'S WILL. USE ANSWERED IN A
PREVENTATIVE WAY FOR
ORGANIZATIONS THINKING ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SO AN ESSENTIAL PIECE OF ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT HARASSMENT IT
REALLY DOES NEED TO BE DESIGNING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE DIVERSE.
WHERE WOMEN ARE BETTER
REPRESENTED IN PARTICULARLY
IRWIN ARE BETTER REPRESENTED IN
CORE FUNCTIONS AND IN LEADERSHIP
ROLES WE KNOW THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS LESS LIKELY TO
OCCUR?
SO ONE QUESTION TO CONSIDER IN
ORGANIZATIONS WHERE WOMEN ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED. OR
PARTICULARLY WHERE THERE ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED IN POSITIONS OF
POWER IS WHY IS THAT HAPPENING
WATER THE FACTORS INFLUENCING
REPRESENTATION.
I MEAN ARE WORKING PARADIGM WE
CONSIDER THIS BY LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE EMPLOYEE LIFE CYCLE WHICH
WE BREAK DOWN INTO FOUR KEY
PIECE AS WE CALL THEM ATTRACT
THE LACK DEVELOPER TEAM.
AND WE CONSIDER WHERE IN THAT
LIFE CYCLE ARE WOMEN FACING
UNIQUE BARRIERS.
THE DATA IS REALLY KEY HERE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE TOP OF THE FINAL WHO IS
ME YOU CAN'T BEING CONSIDERED
FOR WHICH JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
HOW HIRING DECISIONS ARE MADE?
WHO IS DEVELOPING AN ADVANCING
GETTING OPPORTUNITY?
BECAUSE STAYING AND WHO'S
LEAVING.
IN TERMS OF MORE SUBJECTIVE
OUTCOMES IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND HOW PEOPLE FEEL IN
THEIR DAY TO DAY WORK.
YOU PEOPLE FEEL SAFE.
IN A FEEL EMPOWERED TO SPEAK UP
THE PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE A
VOICE.
YOU PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
BELONG.
ALL OF THESE DATA I AM OFFER A
REALLY POWERFUL INSIGHT INTO
WHERE ORGANIZATIONAL AND
CULTURAL BARRIERS ARE MERGING.
I PROACTIVELY ADDRESSING THESE
TYPES OF BARRIERS ORGANIZATIONS
CAN BUILD MORE DIVERSE INCLUSIVE
CULTURE IS OUR CRAFTSMAN IS LESS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN.
IN ADDITION THE BUILDING HEALTHY
CULTURES ORGANIZATION ALSO NEED
TO PRIORITIZE ACCOUNTABILITY. I
KNOW THERE'LL BE OTHER NO
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT ARE
ALREADY HAD BEEN AND IT'S
SOMETHING YOU'VE ALREADY THOUGHT
ABOUT. BUT I THINK WHAT I WOULD
JUST SAY HERE IS THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT GOING
BEYOND THE BARE MINIMUM REQUIRED
BY LOT. AND CONSIDER
ESTABLISHING MORE PROGRESS THAT
POLICY IS THAT OUTLINED A TAPE
OF CULTURE YOU ACTUALLY WANT TO
WORK IN.
AND I KNOW THAT THE PUBLIC
SECTOR IS DIFFERENT FROM PRIVATE
CORPORATIONS AND HAS UNIQUE
CHALLENGES AROUND. ON ABILITY.
BUT ULTIMATELY IN LATIN
ORGANIZATION CREATES A CULTURE
IN WHICH HARASSMENT ISN'T
TOLERATED. ARM NONE OF US SHOULD
BE SURPRISED TO FIND THAT
HARASSMENT CONTINUES IN THAT
CULTURE.
WELL THE LAST TACTICAL PIECE I
WANT TO MENTION BRIEFLY AT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PLAYING AWFUL
WILL ANTI HARASSMENT TRAINING.
ON ANTI HARASSMENT TRAINING IS
REALLY COMIN AYE IF LEGALLY
REQUIRED IN MANY TYPES OF
ORGANIZATIONS ACTUALLY NATION
WIDE A LOT OF STATES HAVE
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS.
I AM BUT I THINK WE'LL BE OFTEN
IN THIS TYPE OF TRAINING IS THAT
IT'S NOT WELL DESIGNED TO
ACHIEVE THE OUTCOMES WE ACTUALLY
WANT. TRAINING AS OFTEN AND
REALLY COMPLIANCE FOCUSED I
FAILED TO PROVIDE BYSTANDERS
WERE ALLIES WITH SKILLS FOR
INTERVENING FOR SPEAKING OUT.
IT TURNS OUT WE KNOW FROM
RESEARCH THAT TRAINING IS
ACTUALLY LESS LIKELY TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON PEOPLE WHO ARE MORE
PRONE TOWARDS COMMITTING
HARASSMENT.
SO I THINK WE SOMETIMES THINK
ABOUT TRAINING AS SOMETHING TO
STOP HARASSERS.
THAT'S NOT LIKELY TO WORK VERY
WELL.
WHICH TRAINING CAN HAVE AN
IMPACT ON EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT IT MATTERS HOW TRAINING ITS
FRAMES FOR EXAMPLE IT'S
IMPORTANT THE HIGHLY ETHICAL NOT
JUST LEGAL. ISSUES WITH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HELPER DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF
HARASSMENT ON VICTIMS.
TRAINING DELIVERY MATTER AS AS
WELL FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT IN
PERSON TRAINING IS MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN ONLINE TRAINING
WE ALSO KNOW THAT. TRAINING
THAT'S TARGETED TOWARDS ON JUST
MEN AT WHAT THE FACT AND THEN
TRAINING THAT BRINGS TOGETHER
PEOPLE OF ALL GENDERS HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
AND FINALLY I THINK IT'S JUST
CRITICAL TO MENTION FROM FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE THINKING ABOUT
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE IS. THAT
HARASSMENT DOESN'T HAPPEN IN A
VACUUM.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PRETTY GOOD
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN A VACUUM
CULTURES THAT ALLOW FOR
HARASSMENT.
ARE USUALLY PLAYING BY OTHER
ISSUES AS WELL.
DOING ORGANIZATION AND VERY
WOMEN ARE DEVALUED I'M AND
HARASSED WOMEN ARE ALSO LIKELY
TO FAITH OTHER BARRIERS LIKE
BIAS OR DISCRIMINATION IN HIRING
OUTCOMES AND ACCESS TO. CLEAN
YOUR HIGH VISIBILITY ASSIGNMENTS
PROMOTION AND COMPENSATION.
I IN ORGANIZATIONS THAT ALLOW
FOR SEXUAL HER ASK MEANT. WE
ALSO EXPECTED FIND OTHER FORMS
OF HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
FOR EXAMPLE DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON RACE. NEWS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ALREADY TREATING PEOPLE
DIFFERENTLY BASED ON THEIR
IDENTITIES.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER HERE THE UNIQUE
EXPERIENCE FOR THE WOMEN OF
COLOR AND THE INTERSECTION OF
RACIAL AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THAT WOMEN OF COLOR SO OFTEN
EXPERIENCE.
IN ORGANIZATIONS WHERE WE SEE
SATCHEL HARASSMENT OR
PARTICULARLY LIKELY IF HE
PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS
HARASSMENT AGAINST WOMEN OF
COLOR.
SO AND I WANTED TO JUST GET SOME
OF THOSE KEY INSIGHTS FROM OUR
WORK WITH ORGANIZATIONS AND AND.
YOU ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I MIGHT
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE INSIGHT BASED
BASED ON THE WORK THAT WE DO
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WILL
COME BACK TO YOU FOR QUESTIONS
A BEFORE WE DO THAT I'M GOING TO
GO TO OUR LAST.
PANELIST.
ARAB BUT HURT. OF NOT IN THE
ROOM I IN THE ROOM WON THIS
BATTLE.
I'VE THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
JOHNNY TAYLOR CHAIRMAN.
CHAIRWOMAN FRIEDMAN CHAIRWOMAN
MITCHELL AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I AM THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE SOCIETY
FOR HUMAN.
SURE.
AND JUST BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
HAVE AN INTERESTING EXPERIENCE
OF SET OF EXPERIENCES FIRST AS A
LABOR EMPLOYMENT LAWYER DEFENSE
LAWYER.
I THEN WENT ON TO RUN HR FOR A
NUMBER OF FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES WHICH HAD OPERATIONS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TICKETMASTER
INS. LA AND ASK DOT COM AT
OAKLAND SO WE WE HAD BUSINESSES
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
AND.
AND THERE WAS PORTION OF THE OP
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVICE
CEO OF ONE OF THOSE BUSINESS
SO THAT WAS MY PRIVATE SECTOR
SIDE.
OF THE LAST SEVEN AND A HALF
YEARS I WAS THE A CEO BUT
THURGOOD MARSHALL COLLEGE FUND.
WHICH IS ORGANIZATION SERVICE
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
AND THEN LITERALLY AND THREE
WEEKS ON THE JOB HERE AS THE CEO
OF THE SOCIETY FOR HUMAN
RESOURCE.
MET SO A VERY INTERESTING SET OF
EXPERIENCES WHICH WILL INFORM.
MY COMMENTS OF FOR THE NEXT TEN
OR SO MINUTES BUT THANK YOU.
I THE PURITY IT TODAY ON BEHALF
OF SHARM WITH THE WORLD'S
LARGEST HR PROFESSIONAL SOCIETY
WE HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE COUNTRIES.
WE'VE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS RIGHT HERE IN THIS GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE KEY THOUGH IS OUR MEMBERS
ACTUALLY IN TURN AFFECTED IMPACT
THE LIVES OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION WORKERS.
THAT'S THE REAL DEAL SO THE
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
IS NICE BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT
EVERYDAY I ABILITY TO INFLUENCE
THE LIVES OF A HUNDRED MILLION
PEOPLE NEARLY A THIRD OF OUR. US
POPULATION. THAT'S THE THE WORK
THAT WE DO AT THE SOCIETY FOR
HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT FOR
NEARLY SEVENTY YEARS.
SHARMA'S BEEN THE LEADING
ORGANIZATION IN PEOPLE
MANAGEMENT AND WE HELP
ORGANIZATIONS LEARN HOW TO
MANAGE THEIR PEOPLE BETTER THEIR
HUMAN ASSETS.
INCLUDING CREATING WORKPLACES
THAT FOSTER A CULTURE OF
RESPECT.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO ELIMINATING
ALL FORMS OF HARASSMENT I THINK
IS REALLY KEY THAT WHILE TODAY I
APPRECIATE THEIR FOCUS ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THERE ARE ALL SORTS OF FORMS OF
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT THAT OUR
ORGANIZATION FOCUSES ON AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS OBVIOUSLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE OF THE
DAY. RIGHT NOW BUT WE EDUCATE
OUR MEMBERS NOT ONLY ON THAT AND
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW BUT AND
BUILDING A POSITIVE AND
PRODUCTIVE WORKPLACE CULTURE.
WE BELIEVE THAT CREATING AND
MAINTAINING HARASSMENT FREE
WORKPLACE IS NOT JUST A LEGAL
PRIORITY.
BUT A BUSINESS ONE.
I'M PLEASE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO DISCUSS HOW THESE
CONCEPTS APPLY TO HIGH PROFILE
AND DYNAMIC WORKPLACES SUCH AS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AND
ASSEMBLY. PUBLIC CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY. A
MOST IMPORTANTLY I'M GOING TO
ADDRESS THE ROLE OF WORKPLACE
CULTURE IN PREVENTING AND
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
ALL WORKPLACES.
SO HERE'S THE IRONY.
EXACTLY TWENTY YEARS AGO THIS
WEEK.
WE WATCHED THIS COUNTRY DIVIDE
ITSELF
OVER AN ETHICAL CRISIS INVOLVING
A U. S. PRESIDENT
AND AN INTERN.
FAST FORWARD TO TODAY.
AND WE FIND OURSELVES STILL
STRUGGLING.
SAME ISSUES AROUND SIX.
POWER AND CONSENT.
ALL OF WHICH INTERSECT
IN THE WORKPLACE.
LET'S ALSO REMEMBER THAT EVEN
AFTER MP
AND AND THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
THAT SAME PRESIDENT VENICE HIS
FINAL TERM WITH THE HIGHEST IN
THE OFFICE APPROVAL. OF ANY
PRESIDENT SINCE WORLD WAR TWO.
AND HE CONTINUES TO RANK IN THE
MOST POPULAR AMERICANS IN THAT
ON THE GLOBE.
CLEARLY
AS MUCH AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS
TODAY WE HAVE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
BROADER CONCEPT OF THE AMERICAN
CULTURE.
OKAY THAT'S I MEAN WE HAVE TO
PUT THAT IN THE CONTEXT THE IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW.
THIS ORGANIZATION THE STATE CAN
OPERATE IN THE VACUUM IN THIS
UNITED STATES AND NOT APPRECIATE
WHAT WE ACCEPT US TOLERATE
BEHAVIOR THAT'S ACCEPTABLE IN
BABY THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE WE
GOTTA START LOOKING AT THE MAN
AND THE WOMEN IN THE MIRROR AND
ASKING OURSELVES HOW DO WE
REALLY FEEL ABOUT. THIS.
FAIR.
LIKE HOLLYWOOD AND WALL STREET
THE LEGISLATIVE ENVIRONMENT IS
UNIQUELY SUSCEPTIBLE TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SITUATION.
WHAT THEY ALL HAVE IN COMMON
THOUGH
IS THAT THESE WERE PLACES ARE
DRIVEN BY COMPLEX POWER DYNAMIC?
A FEW PEOPLE HOLD THE CAREERS
AND FUTURES OF MANY OTHERS IN
THEIR HANDS.
AND SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
DEEMED FRANKLY TOO BIG TO FAIL.
THEY'RE TOO IMPORTANT TO PALE
AND WE HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT
THAT.
ALSO THE USE THESE WERE. TEND TO
BE MALE DOMINATED.
AND I WANNA BE CLEAR THAT WHILE
SIX HARASSMENT IS ISRAEL IT'S
NOT JUST A WOMAN'S ISSUE ALONE.
NOT BY A LONG SHOT
MEN ARE ALSO PICKED.
AND WOMEN ARE ALSO PERPETRATORS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS ABOUT
POWER.
AND AND IT'S ABOUT IT'S
COMMITTEE IT'S IT'S ABOUT WHO'S
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT WHOEVER
IS IN CONTROL.
IT JUST SO HAPPENS FRANKLY THAT
IN MANY OF THESE WORKPLACES MEN
ARE IN CONTROL AT LEAST FOR NOW.
ANOTHER COMMONALITY AMONG SOARED
HIGH POWER WORKPLACES IS THAT
YOU HAVE A WEALTH OF YOUNGER.
SPIRALING COMPETITIVE EMPLOYEES.
WHO WERE ENTHRALLED BY POWERFUL
OFTEN OLDER PEOPLE?
THIS CULTURE CREATES PERFECT
CONDITIONS FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
IT'S ALSO ONE THAT IS RIGHT FOR
POSITIVE TRANSFORMATION.
AND IT'S TIME FOR A CULTURAL
TRANSFORMATION IN YOUR
LEGISLATIVE WORKPLACES.
AND AS A LEADER IN WORKPLACE
CHANGE CALIFORNIA MUST STARTED
IN NAME A START IT RIGHT HERE
RIGHT NOW SO I I. PRAISE YOU AYE
LOGIC FOR DOING THIS WORK.
SOMETHING THAT ONE OF MY CO
PANELISTS IS MENTIONED CULTURE
ALWAYS TRUMP'S COMPLIANT.
PERIOD.
CHARMS PERSPECTIVE IS UNIQUE
BECAUSE WE REPRESENT NOT JUST
ONE SEGMENT OF THE EMPLOYMENT
SECTOR.
BUT A PROFESSION THAT SPANS ALL
INDUSTRY
INCLUDING COMPANIES
FOR PROFIT NONPROFIT A
GOVERNMENT
AND WORK HARD WORK FORCES THAT A
LARGE AND SMALL.
I MEMBERS HAVE SEEN IT ALL AND
THEY LET US KNOW WHAT WORKS AND
WHAT DOESN'T.
HERE'S WHAT DOESN'T WORK.
RELYING ON COMPLIANCE.
RULES EDUCATION AND TRAINING
TO PREVENT OR ADDRESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
IT'S TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SELECT
TASK FORCE REPORT ON HARASSMENT
THE EOC RECOGNIZE THAT EVEN
EFFECTIVE TRAINING CANNOT OCCUR
IN A VACUUM.
IT MUST BE PART OF A HOLISTIC
CULTURE OF NON HARASSMENT
THAT STARTS AT THE TOP.
COMPLIANCE IS A KEY COMPONENT OF
HER HER OF A HARASSMENT FREE
WORKPLACE BUT IN REALITY WE
COULD DEMAND THAT EVERY EMPLOYEE
EACH OF THE IN YOUR OFFICES
TAKE TEN HOURS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING EVERY WEEK.
AND IT'S STILL GOING TO HAPPEN.
BY THE SAME TOKEN WE CAN ENFORCE
THE SPEED
THIS POLICIES FOR BEATING
WORKPLACE RELATIONSHIPS.
AS THE EASY ANSWER.
BUT OFFICE ROMANCE IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
YOU SIMPLY CAN'T IGNORE OR
LEGISLATE HUMAN EXPERIENCE AND
HUMAN BEHAVIOR SO IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO DEAL IN REALITY.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN CASE AFTER
CASE WERE PROBLEMATIC BEHAVIORS
AND SITUATIONS NEVER RISE TO THE
LEGAL DEBATE DEFINITION OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
BUT ARE PROBLEMATIC NONE THE
LESS
PROFESSOR KIM COB GEORGE
INSTITUTE OF TECHNOLOGY PUT IT
BEST WHEN SHE SAYS THERE'S A BIG
GRAY ZONE.
BETWEEN LEGAL SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ANY CULTURE OF INCLUSION.
AND SHE SAID IN BACK GRADIENT
REAL DAMAGE IS BEING DONE ON A
DAILY BASIS THAT'S CHANGING
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND CHANGING THE
TRAJECTORY OF THEIR CAREERS.
THAT'S REAL. THIS IS WHY I URGE
YOU NOT TO BE IN THE WORD BY THE
COTTAGE INDUSTRY.
SPRINGING UP ALL AROUND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS
THEY WANT TO COME AND CONSIDER
THE FACT THAT NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT OF US WORKPLACES HAVE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICIES.
AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
TOO A LOT OF EXPENSIVE TRAINING.
AND YET HERE WE ARE.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
RULES EDUCATION TRAINING ARE
NECESSARY IN FACT SHARMA'S
WORKING WITH THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE LEGISLATURES
NCSL YOU HEAR FROM THEM LATER
TODAY TO CO HOST A FREE.
TRAINING FOR NCSL MEMBERS ON
HARASSMENT AND ESTABLISHING A
CULTURE OF RESPECT IN THEIR
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES LAST WEEK WE
CONDUCTED A SIMILAR WEAPON I
WITH EEOC ACTING CHAIR VICKI
LIPNIK.
CHARM ALSO PROVIDES NUMEROUS
PROGRAMS AT CONFERENCES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY ON
CREATING AND MAINTAINING
HARASSMENT FREE WORKPLACE
INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH
OUR STATE COUNCIL. CAL SHERM AND
ARE SEVENTEEN CHAPTERS.
BUT RULES EDUCATION TRAINING
FRANKLY WILL NEVER BE ENOUGH
EVEN ZERO TOLERANCE POLICIES
HAVE NO AFFECT WHEN PEOPLE DON'T
FEEL SAFE TO REPORT HARASSMENT.
WHEN THERE'S NO MECHANISM TO
TO REPORT TO REPORT THE PEOPLE.
WHO WHO ENGAGE IN THIS BEHAVIOR?
WE DON'T SEE SUCCESS AND MISS
HERE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE TO
MARGINALIZE
DISTRUST
BULLIED AND EVEN FORCED OUT TO
HELP US CULTURE MAKE REAL
CULTURAL CHANGE.
MANUALS AND TRAINING SO USELESS
AND WORK PLACES WHERE BAD
BEHAVIOR IS SILENTLY TOLERATED.
IT IS CULTURE NOT COMPLIANCE
THAT GUIDES WORKPLACE CONDUCT.
AGAIN.
LET'S BRING THIS DISCUSSION HERE
TO THIS STATE AND LEGISLATIVE
BODY.
BUT THE STATE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY HERE HAVE AN ETHICS
COMMITTEE UNDERSTAND AND
STANDARDS FOR REPORTING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
HOWEVER THE STANDARDS ARE NOT
ALIVE.
INSIDE OF USED TO IT ONE WAY OUT
OF THE SIDES TO ANOTHER WAY.
AND CLEARLY IT'S NOT WORKING.
EMPLOYERS THINK UNLOADS HER
EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
MORE THAN FIFTY EMPLOYEES MUST
FOR ABOUT TWO HOURS ANTI SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING EVERY TWO
YEARS TO SUPERVISOR EMPLOYEES I
MUST DISTRIBUTE INFORMATION TO
ALL EMPLOYEES.
NEW SUPERVISORS MUST ENGAGE IN
TRAINING WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF
TAKING THEIR POSITION.
YET ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
YOU'LL HAVE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIMS FOUND IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
IN ANY CASE NONE OF THIS WOULD
HAVE MATTERED IF THE CULTURE HAD
BEEN THE RIGHT ONE.
SITUATIONS COULD HAVE BEEN
AVERTED OR RESOLVED LONG BEFORE
GETTING TO LEVEL OF COMMITTEES
AND CLAIMS BEING FILED AND
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR JOBS.
THE ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE WE
LIKE TO THINK OF THIS LIKE THE
HUMAN BODY WHEN IT WORKS
PROPERLY.
VIRUSES AND TOXINS ARE NATURALLY
EX.
RIGHT IN A HEALTHY WORKPLACE.
AND UP WITH A HEALTHY WORKPLACE
CULTURE WHEN SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IS OBSERVED OR EXPERIENCE THE
COMMUNITY TAKES OVER.
AND SHUTS IT DOWN COLLECTIVELY
AS YOU.
WITH THE MESSAGE THAT THIS
BEHAVIOR WILL NOT BE TOLERATED
HE.
BY ANYONE AT ANY LEVEL.
IDEALLY SEXUAL HARASSMENT
DOESN'T OCCUR AT ALL BECAUSE THE
BODY SIMPLY INOCULATE SELF.
WITH HEALTHY NORMS EXPECTATIONS
AND STANDARDS.
THAT'S REALLY THE TASK FOR YOU
WE CAN GO AND ENGAGE IN ALL
SORTS OF SEX HARASSMENT TRAINING
MANDATORY TRAINING MICHAEL
PANELIST JUST SUGGESTED BRINGING
IN PEOPLE WHO ARE INCLINED TO
ENGAGE IN THIS BEHAVIOR TRAINING
THEM DOESN'T SOLVE ANYTHING.
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE.
AND IN A VERY PRACTICAL WAY.
ONE WAY TO GET A HEALTHY
CULTURE.
THAT WILL NOT TOLERATE SEX
HARASSMENT IS BY CHOOSING TO BE
PRACTICAL ABOUT PEOPLE AND I'M
GONNA FINISH ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE ASK YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR POLICY A WORKPLACE
RELATIONSHIP?
HERE THE CAPITAL YOU EMPLOY A
LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
MENTIONED THAT BEFORE MANY OF
THEM SINGLE MOST OF THEM QUITE
AMBITIOUS.
THEY WILL PROCEED PURSUE EACH
OTHER WITH THEIR MENTORS AND
THEIR ROLE MODELS.
THAT'S JUST HUMAN NATURE.
AND RELATIONS.
BUT THEM OUT LOS JUST GO
UNDERGROUND.
CONTRIBUTING TO A CULTURE OF
DISHONESTY AND SECRECY
SO THE VERY THING THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE FOR IN THE WAY
SHE CREATING.
AND IF THEY ARE DISCOVERED
YOU ARE NOW FACED WITH THE
CHOICE OF FIRING ONE OR THE
OTHER OR BOTH AND ORGANIZATION
LUCIS TALENT CRITICAL TALENT.
INSTEAD YOU COULD FOLLOW A
POLICY OF DISCLOSURE.
NOT UNLIKE WHAT WE DO WITH
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST POLICIES
ONE A REAL ACTUAL EXAMPLE OF
WHAT COMPANIES ARE DOING IN
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DOING. THEY'RE
SAYING IF YOU REALLY WANT TO GET
TO TRANSPARENCY IN THE TRUEST
SENSE ALLOW PEOPLE TO COME
FORWARD WITHOUT FEAR OF
REPRISALS.
BOTH OF THEM AND GIVE THEM A
NOTHER PATHWAY.
CONTINUE THEIR WORK RELATIONSHIP
AND THEIR PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP.
AND SO WE HAVE TO GET REALLY
PRACTICAL ABOUT THIS.
TWO OTHER ELEMENTS IN
ESTABLISHING HEALTHY CUT TO IN A
CAR HEALTHY CULTURE ARE SWIFT
ACTION AND TRANSPARENCY.
CLAIMS OF HARASSMENT OBVIOUSLY
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED
IMMEDIATELY QUICKLY. AND IDEALLY
BY AN INDEPENDENT PANEL.
AND IF BEHAVIOR IS FOUND TO
VIOLATE THE CULTURE OF THE
ORGANIZATION THAT INDIVIDUAL SHE
BE
OBJECTED TO PROGRESSIVE
DISCIPLINARY PROCEDURES UP TO
AND INCLUDING BARRY.
BUT THIS BRINGS US TO A CRITICAL
POINT.
IN THE ZEAL.
TO ROUTE OUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND OTHER FORMS OF HARASSMENT
ORGANIZATIONS MOVE MUST BE
CAREFUL NOT TO SWING TOO FAR IN
THE OTHER DIRECTION.
CREATING A GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN
INNOCENT STANDARD.
I KNOW THAT'S NOT PARTICULARLY
POPULAR BUT THAT'S THAT'S THE
REALITY WE ALL HAVE MADE IN OUR
LIVES WHO. COULD BE REALLY
IMPACTED BY THIS AS WELL.
BIDDY SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ALLEGATIONS ARE FOUND TO BE
UNSUBSTANTIATED.
MANY ARE FOUND BE
UNSUBSTANTIATED EEL CELLS EEOC
TELLS US THAT AND IN SOME CASES
THEY'RE OUT RIGHT ON TROOPS
WOULD NOT THE LEGAL STANDARD
PRODIGIOUS OUTRIGHT UNTRUE.
A TRUST WORTHY DUE PROCESS
SHOULD
TECH BE ACCUSED UNTIL HERE SHE
IS POUND EITHER RESPONSIBLE OR
INNOCENT OF THE WRONGDOING.
I RECOMMEND THAT YOU TAKE EVERY
ALLEGATION SERIOUSLY OF COURSE.
INVESTIGATE IT PROPERLY AND
ADJUDICATED FAIRLY QUICKLY AND
APPROPRIATELY
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A WORKPLACE
WHERE EVERYONE FEELS SAFE.
AND THIS CAN'T GO ONE WAY.
CHEN HAS DEVELOPED MANY MANY
BEST PRACTICES AND PROCEDURES
FOR SUSTAINING A HEALTHY
WORKPLACE AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK AT OUR MEMBER TOOL KIT
BECAUSE WE HAVE REAL LIFE
EXAMPLES FROM WHERE REAL LIFE
EMPLOYEES. WHO CAN TELL YOU HOW
TO HELP GET THIS RIGHT?
THIS TAKES COURAGE.
BUT IS NOT A CHOICE ANYMORE.
HOW DO YOU KNOW YOUR CULTURE IS
WORKING WHEN IT MOSTLY RUNS ON
ITSELF?
HEALTHY CARD HEALTHY CULTURES
SELF POLICE BAD BEHAVIORS THAT
SAID THE SELF SELECT GOOD PEOPLE
BE SELF REGULATE AFFECTED
POLICIES AND SELF PERPETUATE.
THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
GOOD CULTURE.
IN THE END A HEALTHY CULTURE IS
A COMPETITIVE GAME CHANGER
ALLOWING YOU TO GET AND KEEP
THE BEST PEOPLE TO MEET YOUR
MISSION.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE WREAKS HAVOC ON THE
PAD BACK ON YOUR ABILITY. TO DO
YOUR JOBS AS LEGISLATORS.
EVEN IF THE SITUATION NEVER
REACHES THE LEVEL OF A
COMPLAINT.
BUT IT PUSHES GOOD PEOPLE OUT OF
THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'VE LOST THE TALENT GAY.
WITH CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE DOWN FOUR POINT NINE
PERCENT AND FOLLOWING THIS IS A
RISK YOU SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD WE
CAN'T LOSE STRONG PEOPLE.
THIS BODY NOW HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSFORM ITS
CULTURE.
AND AS THE BELLWETHER STATE FOR
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO DO
THIS WORK.
AS YOU GO ABOUT THIS CRITICAL
WORK THOUGH I URGE YOU TO
REMEMBER THAT COMPLIANCE
MATTERS.
BUT IT IS HEALTHY CULTURE
STAVES OFF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
CULTURE CHANGES THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING YOU CAN DO THAT
ALL OF US CAN DO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL PEOPLE IN
THE WORKPLACE ARE RESPECTED
VALUED AND EMPOWERED TO SIX
SHARM CAL SHARM AND OUR MEMBERS
STAND WITH YOU EACH OF YOU. AND
PUTTING AN END TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AT WORK AND IN
BUILDING BETTER WORKPLACES.
FOR PEOPLE TO WORK AND CREATE
ULTIMATELY A BETTER WORLD.
SHARMA'S PLANS TO DO THIS WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AS IT
ADDRESSES THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
BUT I JUST WANT TO COMMENT
SENATOR MORE LACKS. A COMMENT IN
RESPONSE THAT.
BUT THIS IS A VERY VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE.
IT'S COMPLEX.
WHY IN THE IF YOU IF WE RUSH TO
A DECISION WE WILL HAVE SOME
REALLY POOR AND AND SUMS VERY
NEGATIVE UNINTENDED?
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU AND I
THANK BOTH OF THE CO CHAIRS FOR
BEING THOUGHTFUL TAKING YOUR
TIME AND DOING THIS RIGHT THE
WORST THING YOU CAN DO IS ROLL
OUT SOMETHING BECAUSE IT'S THE
TOPIC OF THE DAY IN A TALL OF
THE NEWS.
AND RESPOND WITH EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT. EIGHT PROCESS OR A
PROCEDURE WAY GIVEN A RESPONSE
THAT IS NOT WELL THOUGHT OUT.
YOU CAN REALLY DO DAMAGE TO THE
ORGANIZATION AND CREATE THE
CULTURE THAT YOU DON'T WANT.
THANK YOU.
IT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
QUESTIONS NOW.
I'M GONNA TAKE THE PROG HAVE TO
ASK THE FIRST QUESTION I WAS
VERY INTERESTED IN YOUR
TESTIMONY MISTER TAYLOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE ROLE OF HR
PERSON NOW.
BECAUSE.
.
WE'VE SEEN YOU KNOW IN A LOT OF
THESE CORPORATIONS WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW IN HOLLYWOOD.
YOU KNOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
SAY THE SAME THING ABOUT OUR
ORGANIZATION.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WITHIN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT KNEW. THE
RESULTS OF INVESTIGATIONS I MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN IN POWER TO MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON THAT BUT WHAT
IS GIVEN THAT WHAT IS THE ROLE
OF HR PEOPLE ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY FEEL THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
REALLY WRONG GOING ON WITH THE
C. E. O..
A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE I'M
YOU KNOW GIVEN THAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHAT SHOULD THEIR RULE
BE.
WE ARE THE UNITS INTERESTING
WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT MEMBERS AND IT'S ABOUT
COURAGEOUS HR.
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THE
COURAGE TO DO THAT MAKE THOSE
TOUGH BECAUSE THEY NEED TO BE
MADE AND WHAT WE HAVE REMINDED
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS IS YOU
ULTIMATELY WORK FOR THE
ORGANIZATION.
YOU DON'T WORK FOR C. E. O. CEOS
COMING UP LEGISLATORS COME AND
GO ULTIMATELY YOU WORK FOR THE
ORGANIZATION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS AND.
AND YOUR JOB AND YOUR DUTY OF
LOYALTY IS TO THE ORGANIZATION
AND SO WHEN YOU SEE SOMETHING
THAT IS AN APPROPRIATE YOU HAVE
AN OBLIGATION.
THIS ISN'T IT NICE TO DO THIS IS
WHAT YOU MUST DO AND WHAT WE
GOTTA DO IS ENCOURAGE ARE
MEMBERS TO HAVE THE COURAGE
TO LITERALLY STEPPED UP AND CALL
THESE THINGS WHAT THEY ARE. AND
I WILL ADMIT IS THE PERSON WHO
REPRESENTS THIS ORGANIZATION
SOME THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS THAT IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US AS A PROFESSION.
I UNDERSTAND THERE CONSEQUENCES
AND ANYTIME YOU YOU TAKE ON THIS
THESE POSITIONS THERE'D NOT
WITHOUT PERSONAL CONSEQUENCE TO
YOU BUT IF YOU SIT IN THAT SEAT
AND YOU DECIDE THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE AN HR PROFESSIONAL. IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON YOU AND THAT'S
OUR MESSAGE WE'RE GOING BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS THINK I GET IT IT'S
DIFFICULT YOU GOTTA MAKE SOME
CHOICES.
BUT THE REAL TEST IS CAN YOU
WAKE UP EVERY DAY IN THE CAN THE
MIRROR AND SAY.
I DID MY JOB AND I FEEL GOOD
THIS ORGANIZATION AND THIS WORLD
IS IMPACT IS A BETTER PLACE. HR
CAN BE A SOCIAL FORCE
FOR GOOD.
AND SO THIS IS ALL ABOUT COURAGE
AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT A
PARTICULARLY PRACTICAL ANSWER
FOR YOU PRACTICALLY ARE SHARED
WITH SOMEONE THE OTHER DAY I
WAS.
TALKING TO A YOUNG LADY IN A.
CONFERENCE AND SHE SAID AND IT'S
EASY FOR YOU TO TALK ABOUT
COURAGE MUST STATE WHAT YOU KNOW
SHE TALKED ABOUT HER BOSS WHO
WAS A SERIAL SEXUAL HARASSER.
ISSUES THAT BUT YOU KNOW I I'M A
SINGLE MOM I GOT A CARD NOTE OF
MORTGAGE I HAVE DECISIONS TO
MAKE CONSCIOUS IT'S EASY IF YOU
TALK ABOUT COURAGE AND. I WAS
STUNNED BECAUSE LIKE WHAT WAS I
SUPPOSED TO SAY THAT'S A
PRACTICAL DILEMMA THAT YOU FACE.
AND ANOTHER WOMAN IN THE ROOM
STOOD UP AND SAID AND SHE WAS
BEING CUTE ABOUT IT BUT I THINK
IT WAS WHERE IT WAS WORTH
PUBLISHES THAT DONE. HER
SOUTHERN TWANG SHE'S MA'AM UP TO
A WHICH DO.
SAVE UP SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS USE
ALLEN CREATE A GOLD HAIL FOR.
LESS THAN A WHAT AGO TO HELP
MONDAY SHE'S THAT THAT POINT
WHERE YOU HAVE TO SHOW UP TO
WORK EVERYDAY AND DO SOMETHING
YOU DON'T BELIEVE VAN AND WORK
AND REPRESENT THE INTEREST OF
SOMEONE WHO IS A BAD PERSON. YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO STEP AWAY AND
OR A VERY PRACTICAL LEVEL SHE
WAS ENCOURAGING HER COLLEAGUES.
TO PUT ASIDE SOME MONEY BE ABLE
TO WALK AWAY FROM A VERY BAD
ENVIRONMENT AND WE HAVE TO SET
THAT EXAMPLE AS AN HR
PROFESSION.
JUST A FOLLOW UP TO HER DO YOU
SUGGEST THAT ARE THERE ARE THERE
ON THE.
BUT DO YOU HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR WAYS THAT.
COMPANIES ARE AGENCIES CAN
PROTECT THEIR HR PEOPLE. OUR
SILO THEM SOMEHOW EMPOWER THEM
AND GIVE THEM CHEN ALSO SPEAK UP
IF THEY FEEL THAT THEY'RE BEING
COULD THAT THAT THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE. NOT BEING
TAKEN SERIOUSLY WITHOUT THERE
BEING SILENCED.
YES SO SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON A WHITE PAPER OUR
KNOWLEDGE DEVELOPED PART
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT HIS IT
WANTS TO WORK ON THAT AND AND
WHO YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE IT WE
ARE A PROFESSION.
AND SO AS I'VE DESCRIBED TO TO
FOLKS BEFORE IN MY LAWYER DAYS I
WORKED TECHNICALLY FOR C. E. O.
OR IF I WERE A LAWYER ON THE
STAFF OF ONE OF YOUR STAFF I
WORK FOR YOU.
BUT THAT DOES NOT RELIEVE ME OF
MY RESPONSIBILITY MY
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
DO RIGHT.
EVEN IF IT COMES AT THE RISK OF
ME LOSING MY JOB THERE'S AN
ETHICAL OBLIGATION
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO SPEAK TO
AND ARE WORKING ON A STANDARD
THAT SAYS I'D LOVE TO CREATE A
DIFFERENT PLACE FOR HR PEOPLE TO
GO IN. WITH GOING TO BE
PROTECTED AND ALL OF THAT BUT
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE'RE
NOT SURE HOW PRACTICAL THAT IS
IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING YOU COULD
DO IN THE STATE CONTEXT YOU CAN
SET UP YET ANOTHER OFFICE. FOR
SOME FOR THE HR PEOPLE TO GO TO
AFTER THEY ARE DEALING WITH
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN DEALT WITH
BY NUMBER AGGRIEVED EMPLOYEE.
BUT WE YEAR AT WITH THINKING
THAT WE'RE THAT CAN HAPPEN YES
THERE ARE SOME BEST PRACTICES
AROUND ORGANIZATIONS SETTING UP
UP PLACES SAFE PLACES FOR HR
PEOPLE TO GO THE OTHER
DISCUSSION NOW IS FOR US TO
AGAIN. COMMIT TO A PROFESSIONAL.
.
AT THE GOAL OBLIGATION TO REPORT
NO MATTER WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND.
THINKS CULTURE LIKE DIDN'T
SPOKE SPEAK ENOUGH.
WHEN WE DID OUR DOCTORS BUT I'M
HAPPY ON THIS COMMITTEE SO I.
WHEN I SPEAK AS SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEEN ELECTED FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS AND HAVE WENT THROUGH MORE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAININGS THAT
I CARE TO TALK ABOUT.
THE BUT I WANT TO SAY IN THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL THREE ALL
FOUR SPEAKERS TODAY ABOUT
CULTURE.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE AN
ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE?
THE CULTURE HAS BEEN VERY
POWERFUL THE PEOPLEWHO ARE AND
HOW THE ABILITY TO USE THAT
POWER.
AND THEN ARE GUARDED BY THERE IS
NO PLACE PLACE PLACE FOR THE
VICTIM TO GO.
THERE HASN'T BEEN IN THE PAST
AND UNTIL WE SAW THE NEED TO DO
TO WE SAW COURAGE BY.
SOME VERY POWERFUL WOMEN IN IN
IN FILM COME OUT AND AND STAND
UP FOR WHAT.
WAS WRONG
WE SAW THEN.
THIS CULTURE'S CHANGING NOW SO
NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE OR WHO FEEL. EMPOWERED WHICH
IS GREAT TO THE ARM.
TALK ABOUT THE PERPETRATORS THAT
HAVE HAVE HAVE DONE WRONG. SO WE
HAVE A CULTURE HERE THAT IS A
THAT THE PERPETRATORS HAVE NOT
BEEN HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AND THE VICTIMS HAVE BEEN
SHOPPED AROUND OR IN SOME CASES.
NOT KNOW DUE DUE PROCESS SO
WE'RE GONNA KILL YOU DID THIS
COMMITTEE'S JOB.
IS TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CHANGE
THAT CULTURE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT SO I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING.
WORD TO WE WERE TO WE START AND
HOW DO WE TRY TO MAKE THIS
CULTURE MOVE IN A DIRECTION
WHERE. THE VICTIM.
DOES THAT THERE IS A SAFE PLACE
TO GO.
AND THAT WE HOLD ACCOUNTABLE THE
PERPETRATORS.
AND WE TAKE THE POWER AWAY FROM
POLITICIANS.
OKAY BECAUSE THIS IS A POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT.
TO WEAR THAT'S NOT THAT THE FOX
A.
GUARDING THE HENHOUSE FOR LACK
OF A BETTER TERM MAYBE.
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT NEW TO
PUT ANOTHER LITTLE TWIST ON IT.
IS.
YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE TWENTY
TWO YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN
ELECTED OFFICE IS THE PEOPLE WHO
AYE AYE AND WE SAW THIS AT THE
LOCAL RAZA COUNTY SUPERVISOR WE
HAD TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THESE.
JEWISH AND.
AND. I WOULD SAY THE MAJORITY
THE PEOPLE THAT NEEDED TO GO GET
IN TROUBLE NEVER GOT IN TROUBLE
AND THE ONES THAT JUST
POLITICALLY GOT ACCUSED THAT
WERE INNOCENT. LOST THEIR JOB.
AND SO WE HAVE A FINE LINE HERE
WHERE.
BECAUSE OF THE POLITICAL
SITUATION.
SO MANY CAN ACCUSE SOMEBODY AND
IT CAN CHANGE THEIR CAREER EVEN
THOUGH THERE WAS MAYBE NO.
.
A. REALITY TO IT SO I'M I WOULD
BE ANY OF YOU COULD ANSWER A WE
WE WE ARE GOING TO BE STRUGGLING
WITH THIS THIS IS THE MAIN
QUESTION FOR THIS THIS BODY.
IS TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE.
PROTECT THE VICTIM.
BY ALL MEANS IF SOMEBODY'S.
BEEN GUILTY THROW THEM HECK OUT
THIS PLACE.
AND AND NOT TOLERATE BUT THEN
DRIVE THAT FINE LINE OF WHERE WE
CHANGE THIS CULTURE HOW DO WE
START WHERE DO WE START THAT'S
WHAT I'M AFTER SO.
ANY TAKERS.
I WOULD SAY.
THERE ISN'T ANY ONE THING YOU
CAN DO THERE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS YOU CAN DO.
I'M AND THE IMPORTANT THING IS
TO BEGIN DOING THEM.
I AM I THINK THAT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO CHANGE.
AND ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE IS TO
HAVE ONGOING INCLUSIVE
CONVERSATIONS.
I AM ABOUT WHAT CULTURAL NORMS
DO YOU WANT TO FOSTER.
NOT HOW'RE WE GONNA CATCH THE
PERPETRATORS AND PUNISH THEM BUT
WHAT KIND OF ORGANIZATIONAL
CLIMATE DO WE WANT.
TO FOSTER.
I AM ALSO A BIG ADVOCATE OF OF
TYING THIS TO PUBLIC SERVICE
VALUES.
WE ALL HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROVIDE THE VERY BEST WORK.
I AM I CONSIDER MYSELF A PART OF
OF THE GOVERNMENT'S PROCESS
ALTHOUGH I'M JUST A TEACHER.
TO DO THE VERY BEST WORK TO
BRING IN THE VERY BEST PEOPLE
AND GIVE THEM A WORKPLACE WHERE
THEY CAN.
USE THEIR TALENTS WHERE THEY
CAN BE INNOVATIVE AND RESPONSIVE
AND RESILIENT.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
.
THE THE CULTURAL NORMS OF SAFETY
OF CIVILITY. OF TRUST OF
COOPERATION OF COLLABORATION.
TARGET IS GONNA MAKE YOUR
ORGANIZATION MORE INNOVATIVE IS
GONNA MAKE MORE PRODUCTIVE AND
IT'S GONNA MAKE IT.
.
BUT MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE TRYING TO SIR.
SO IT'S IT'S A PART OF A LARGER
CONVERSATION AND I WOULD SAY.
THIS ISN'T AN HR ISSUE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF OF WHAT KIND
OF INSTITUTION DOES
DO YOU WANT THIS TO BE.
AND IT HAS TO BE TOP LEADERSHIP
HAS TO BE EVERYONE SPEAKING TO
THESE QUESTIONS.
.
AND YOU WANT THESE TO BEAT THE
TRAINING IS GREAT EXCEPT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING. THE
DASTARDLY DEEDS.
.
CONVERSATIONS SHOULD BE TAKE
PLACE ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT MEN
FOR EXAMPLE TO BECOME FRIGHTENED
TO WORK WITH WOMEN.
YOU DON'T WANT THIS HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT DONE WELL I'M
NOT GOING TO HIRE A WOMAN I KNOW
I'M GONNA WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THIS PERSON.
I DON'T I'M NOT GONNA TAKE THAT
RISK.
SO YOU HAVE TO GET MEN TALKING
AND WOMEN TALKING AND YOUNG
PEOPLE TALKING AND PEOPLE IN. IN
HIGH UP AT HIGH LEVELS OF POWER
SPEAKING TO EACH OTHER ABOUT.
THEIR EXPERIENCE ABOUT WHAT THEY
WORRY ABOUT AND WHAT KIND OF
WORKPLACE THEY WANT TO BE IN.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT AND JUST MAKE
IT BETTER FOR WOMEN.
IT'S GOING TO MAKE IT BETTER FOR
THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO
MAKE IT BETTER FOR THE PEOPLE
AND THE CITIZENS THAT YOU CARE
SO MUCH ABOUT.
IN TERMS OF BEING
INNOVATIVE-POLICYMAKERS IN TERMS
A
CALIFORNIA CONTINUING TO BE THE
TREND SETTER.
IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW AS
FAR AS AS GOVERNANCE.
YEAH LET ME. ALSO ADD THAT THAT
THEY'RE PRACTICALLY PEOPLE JUDGE
YOU BY WHAT YOU DO NOT A WHICH
IS.
AND THAT'S THE REALITY.
YOU HATE TO CALL IT YOU CAN HAVE
TO MAKE EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE BUT
THE WAY THAT SHE BEGAN TO CHANGE
THAT CULTURE IS PEOPLE HAVE TO
KNOW THAT YOU REALLY BELIEVE
WHAT YOU SAY AND THAT NO ONE IS
TOO IMPORTANT TO FAIL I CAME
FROM THE INDUSTRY HOLLYWOOD.
NONE OF THIS SURPRISED ME AND I
WORKED AT BUY COM COMPANIES
PARAMOUNT PICTURES SPELLING
ENTERTAINMENT. AND I'VE AND A
NUMBER OF THEM AS A LAWYER I
CONSULTED WITH.
IN MANY OF THESE INSTANCES WE
KNEW WHO THE PERPETRATORS WHERE
WE KNEW WHO THE DIRTY OLD MAN
WHERE.
BUT IT WAS MONEY IT WAS WE CAN
WE CAN PAY FOR THIS AND MAKE
THIS GO AWAY HERE SHE IS TO HE
AND THIS AND THAT ALL OF THESE
INSTANCES HEATH WAS TOO
POWERFUL.
TO A BIG GENERATED TOO MUCH
CASTRO BOTTOM LINE AND SO YOU
CAN'T TELL PEOPLE WE HAVE THE
SAREK SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICY.
AND FRANKLY TAKE IT YOUR HR
PERSON THE HR PERSON TAKE
TO THE NEXT LEVEL AND THAT
PERSON SAYS. YEAH BUT WHAT WE
GONNA DO YOU KNOW HIM.
YOU KNOW HOW HE DOESN'T EVERYONE
KNOWS HIM.
UNTIL YOU START TAKING REAL
ACTION WHEN PEOPLE SEE IT THEN
THEY WILL TRUST YOU AND THAT'S
THE BEGINNING OF THE CULTURAL
TRANSFORMATION IF THEY CAN'T
TRUST YOU.
THEY WILL NEVER BE SAFE ENOUGH
TO REPORT IT TO YOU SURELY
ASSIST THAT DOUBLE TROUBLE SEX
HARASSMENT TRAINING COURSES THAT
YOU WANT AND SOME WELL INTENDED
PEOPLE JUST WON'T FEEL SAFE
ENOUGH TO BRING IT TO LIGHT.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T BELIEVE IT
WILL MATTER ANYWAY THAT'S WHAT
YOU ALL CAN DO A NIGHT AND I
DON'T MEAN TO SUGGEST THAT YOU
NEED TO GO OUT AND. AND YOU KNOW
MAKE A PUBLIC EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE
BUT IT MIGHT NOT BE SUCH A BAD
IDEA BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE SAW
IN THE INDUSTRY AS A SAID I CAME
FROM THAT INDUSTRY.
EVERYONE KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON
IN ALL OF THOSE INSTANCES MATT
LAUER THAT WASN'T A SURPRISE TO
SO MANY PEOPLE AND THAT'S A YOU
KNOW WE KNEW WHAT TO WHAT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING AND WEINSTEIN SHOT
EVERYONE KNEW.
AND THOSE ARE REAL NAMES AND IT
WAS ONLY UNTIL PEOPLE REALIZED
ALL MY GOSH THEY WOULD TAKE DOWN
SOME ONE THAT BIG. THAT THIS
MOVEMENT HAS BEEN BORN I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT IF YOU WANT
TO DO THAT IN A BALL OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURES.
AROUND THE COUNTRY WANT TO DO
THAT MAKE A FEW EXAMPLES I LIVE
IN WASHINGTON DC RIGHT NOW LET
ME TELL YOUAFTER THAT SPATE OF
A FEW OF THEM EVEN THE. MOST
PROTECTED.
STEPPED DOWN PEOPLE NOW BELIEVE
IT THIS IS CHANGE THAT THEY CAN
BELIEVE IT.
CAN I JUST ADD DATA CAN HELP.
.
A LOT OF OF CORPORATIONS AND AND
ORGANIZATIONS USE CLIMATE
SURVEYS.
I THINK.
MOST OF THEM ARE REALLY BAD.
.
OF AT AND I THE AND DEFENSIVE.
BUT WHAT YOU CAN DO IS YOU CAN
HAVE.
A CONFIDENTIAL SURVEY. THAT
ASKS PEOPLE ABOUT.
.
HOW DO HOW SAFE DO THEY FEEL?
I'M HOW SURE ARE ARE THEY OF THE
KIND OF BEHAVIOR THAT'S EXPECTED
OF THEM.
HOW SURE ARE THEY?
WHERE TO GO IF IF THEY HAVE AN
ISSUE WHERE THEY WANT SOME HELP?
SO YOU HAVE SOME INFORMATION AS
TO THE EXTENT THE PROBLEM BEFORE
YOU START START TO FIX.
DO WELL TO YOUR COMMENT.
I WASN'T SURE WHEN YOU WOULD IF
YOU WERE TRYING TO SPEAK.
OUR NOW THINK YOU IT'S ALWAYS
HARD NOT BEING IN THE ROOMS I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THE THOUGHTFUL
BEHAVIOR IT'S INCREASED FEELINGS
OF SAFETY AND GIVE PEOPLE A
VOICE IS GREAT MODELING.
I THINK OUT WE DO A LOT OF THE
SURVEYS AND I THINK WHAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING ALSO IS TO
TIE. ON ITS HIGH NEED DIFFERENT
CONSEQUENCES TOGETHER IN THE
REPORT THAT BACK OUT YOUR
WORKFORCE SO FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T GET EIGHT. WE ALSO
SEE THAT FOR THEIR PERFORMANCE
STARTS TO DECLINE WE THEATER
LESS LIKELY TO STAY IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION WITH THE PEOPLE NOT
CONTRIBUTING AS MUCH IN THEIR
WORK NOT SPEAKING UP IN MEETINGS
ALSO HELPING. HELPING
ORGANIZATION THROUGH DATA
UNDERSTAND THE BROADER
IMPLICATIONS OF CREATING
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE PEOPLE DON'T
FEEL SAFE AND SECURE BECAUSE. I
IT'S NOT JUST SINGING IMPACT
PEOPLE'S WELLBEING THING THAT
IMPACTS YOUR ENTIRE
ORGANIZATIONS ABILITY I THINK
YOU IT'S PAST WORK.
THANK YOU FOR ENCOURAGING THE
GOOD BEHAVIOR OF ASKING YOU.
COMMENT.
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS CAN
ALL WORK
A SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ON AS WE DEVELOP TODAY'S AGENDA
WAS VERY PORTANTINO THE CHAIR
AND I THAT WE SPEND QUALITY TIME
TALK ABOUT CULTURE BECAUSE AND
SO I WANNA.
KIND OF FOLLOW UP ON THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS QUESTION.
DID WAS A LITTLE DIFFERENT WITH.
WHAT I ALSO REALIZE?
THAT THAT THERE'S A DANGER IN
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE I'M SURE
THERE'S A BIG COLLECTIVE AYE
ROLL GOING ON RIGHT NOW ON THE
CAPITAL.
BEING PERPETRATED BY MANY OF
OUR SITTING COLLEAGUES
ON AND SOME OF THE EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS AND YOU KNOW
THEY'RE WASTING TIME TO TALK
ABOUT CULTURE WHAT IS CULTURE
WHAT IS THAT REALLY ME ECCENTRIC
CETERA. AND SOLD IT IN ORDER TO
NOT MISS OUT ON THIS WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THE HAVE A MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATION ABOUT CULTURE.
I'M SITTING HERE LISTENING TO
YOU AND REALLY TRYING TO COME UP
WITH TANGIBLE EXAMPLES OF WHAT
WE CAN DO. I THINK THERE IS THIS
X. THIS EXPECTATION WHICH IS
TYPICAL IN OUR ENVIRONMENT THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
FIGURE IT OUT
AND WE'RE GONNA ROLL OUT THE
ANSWER THAT EVERYONE WILL SIMPLY
COMPLY.
WELL AS YOU ALL.
BRILLIANTLY ARTICULATE IF THAT'S
NOT HOW CULTURE WORKS.
SO THAT I'M I'M SITTING HERE
THINKING ABOUT MY OWN
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE COMING
FROM AT EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT IN
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR WHERE.
CULTURE WAS INGRAINED WE'RE
MISSION DRIVEN ORGANIZATION SO
CULTURE WAS FIRST.
ON OUR AGENDA.
WHEN I CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE I
BROUGHT THAT EXPERIENCE WITH ME
SO ON THE WALLS IN MY OFFICE ON
THE FRONT DOOR LEADING TO MY
OFFICE IN MY OPEN AREA. IS MY
TEAMS.
VALUE STATEMENT.
OF OF WHAT WE.
COMMIT TO TO BE A MEMBER OF TEAM
MITCHELL.
AND WHAT WE BRING TO OUR WORK
EVERY DAY.
SO IT HIT ME.
SITTING HERE LISTENING TO YOU
CAN YOU GIVE US.
I KNOW MATTHEW TO SPOON FEED US
AND I'M ASKING YOU TO DO THAT.
TANGIBLE EXAMPLES LIKE THAT.
THAT THE COLLECTIVE AYE ROLLERS
CAN CHEW ON DIED YES TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT INDIVIDUALLY WE CAN
DO WHETHER YOU'RE IN LEADERSHIP
OR YOU'RE A FRESHMAN MEMBER OF
EITHER HOUSE.
CAN DO TO BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT
CULTURE AND INCORPORATE. A
HEALTHY WORKPLACE CULTURE.
IN YOUR TEAM.
INDIVIDUALLY.
WE'RE HUNDRED TWENTY LEGISLATORS
OF IT EACH OF US DID THAT.
THAT WOULD BEGIN TO CREATE THE
CULTURE HERE THAT WE TEND TO
SPEAK ABOUT IN MORE ABSTRACT
TERMS.
I NEED.
HOMEWORK PLEASE SAGA PROJECT FOR
YOU WE DID IN ONE OF MY LAST
SIGH
SO. THE SENIOR MANAGEMENT TEAM.
A GROUP AUGUST GROUP LIKE YOU
CAME TOGETHER AND SAID WHAT'S
THE CULTURE HERE.
AND WE ALL SAT AROUND IN THIS
BUBBLE AND CAME UP WITH WORDS
AND REALLY FANCY LITTLE
DESCRIPTIONS OF WHAT IT MEANT TO
WORK HERE.
WE DECIDED BRILLIANT IT'S WHERE
BEAUTIFULLY WERE NOT A ROLL IT
OUT TO THE ORGANISATION THE
ORGANISATION BICU.
AND SAID THAT'S NOT WHERE WE
WORK.
THE SWITCH YOU ALL DREAMING
ABOUT AS RACIAL DOESN'T SHE FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THAT THAT'S NOT WHERE
WE WORK.
SO WE ROLLED IT ALL BACK AND WE
DID FARE SIMPLY WILL S.
SIMPLICISSIMUS WE WENT OUT ALL
OF THE EMPLOYEES AND NOT A
CIRCLE OR CHECKBOX HE SAID.
TELL US THE TEN WORDS THAT COME
TO MIND BURST.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO WORK HERE
NOT WHAT WE ASPIRE TO BE?
WHAT IS IT MEAN TO WORK HERE
IT'S A VERY SIMPLE ACCESS?
AND WHEN YOU GATHER ALL OF THAT
DATA IT'LL BECOME PRETTY CLEAR
TO YOU WHAT YOUR CULTURE IS AT
THAT POINT YOU THEN DECIDE WHAT
YOU WANT IT TO BE AND THAT'S THE
GAP AND YOU FIGURE OUT THAT WHAT
ARE THE SPECIFIC INTERVIEW.
YOU PUT IN PLACE BUT SOMETHING
AS PRACTICAL AS SPEAKING TO THE
EMPLOYEES NOT YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES AND WE AN HR GOT
PAST YOU SIMPLY SATISFACTION.
WHAT DOES NOT A FEW NEED
EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT I DON'T JUST
WANT YOU SATISFIED IMAGINE TALK
WITH YOUR SPOUSE OR SIGNIFICANT
OTHER PRINTS ARE YOU SATISFIED?
BY WHAT YOU ENGAGED AND THERE'S
A BIG DIFFERENCE
BUT THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT
EXERCISE THIS IS ABOUT DESCRIBE
WHAT IT MEANS TO WORK HERE AS.
MY GOV TELE PANELISTS ASK
QUESTION WHAT'S IT REALLY LIKE
TO WORK HERE.
AND THEY WILL TELL YOU VERY
QUICKLY AND SOME OF THE SEX
HARASSMENT ISSUES COME OUT SOME
RACE DISCRIMINATION SOME SAYS
THAT YOU CAN'T BE PROMOTED. THE
GOOD AND THE BAD WILL COME OUT
ITS A VERY PRACTICAL WAY BUT ONE
OF THE DANGERS.
IS THAT WE TELL PEOPLE WHAT WE
ASPIRE WHAT WE WANT OUR VALUES
TO BE OR WHAT WE PERSONALITY I
MIGHT ACTUALLY BELIEVE YOU WANT
THIS TO BE. IT THE QUESTION IS
TO THE PEOPLE IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION AGREED THAT THAT'S
WHERE THEY WORK.
I AM I RIGHT.
PLEASE LEAVE AGREE WITH THAT.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT ONCE
YOU'VE ONCE YOU GO TO EMPLOYEES
AND ASK THEM ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT AT THAT BUT WHAT DESCRIBES
YOUR WORKPLACE. TO THEN GO BACK
TO THEM AFTER YOU COLLECT THAT
DATA AND SAY YOU.
WHAT DO YOU WANT YOUR WORKPLACE
TO BE LIKE?
AND SO. IF YOU DON'T THEN TAKE
ALL THE STATE AND SAY WELL NO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE IT AND
THESE ARE GONNA BE THE VALUES IF
YOU GO BACK TO THOSE SAME
EMPLOYEES AND SAY. OKAY WHAT
WHAT DO YOU WANT THIS TO BE.
AND IT TAKES I AM IN THE.
WE DO NEXT.
EXTENSIVE STUDY IN THE CITY OF
PHOENIX AND THAT'S EXACTLY THE
PROCESS THEY FOLLOWED.
THEY WENT BACK AND THEY CAME UP
WITH SEVEN STATEMENTS OF VALUE.
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU HAVE ON YOUR
DOOR.
BUT IT WAS IT WAS.
IT WAS A PROCESS WHERE EVERY
SINGLE EMPLOYEE PARTICIPATED IN
SOME.
UP SOME FASHION.
AND THEN ONCE THOSE VALUES WERE
ARTICULATED THAT WERE PUT
EVERYWHERE.
AND THEN YOU AND THEN THEY USED.
.
THEY USED EXAMPLES AND STORIES
TO ILLUSTRATE HOW THOSE VALUES
WERE PUTTING BEING PUT INTO
PLACE.
SO I WOULD SAY IF YOU IF YOU
WANT A LIST OF THINGS TO DO.
I WOULD SAY COLLECT DATA I LIKE
YOUR IDEA OF OF SPEAKING
DIRECTLY TO EMPLOYEES.
YOU KNOW SURVEYS ARE OKAY BUT I
BUT I AM I THINK CONVERSATION
ENGAGEMENT IS BETTER.
I DO THINK THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
STRUCTURALLY ARE EXCELLENT.
COMING UP WITH A JOINT PROCESS
FOR REPORTING PROVIDING THE
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR ON
PEOPLE WHO COME FORWARD ALSO
PROVIDING A SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT COUNSELING FOR
PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO.
BETTER.
OF.
I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT.
.
TRAINING.
IS IS GOOD.
BUT IT'S IT'S.
A LOT OF PPL DON'T DO ANYTHING
WHEN THEY SEE SOMETHING BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
RIGHT.
THEY JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND
HOW TO BE PROACTIVE HOW TO BE
POSITIVE IN THIS AREA AND THAT
CAN BE VERY VERY HELPFUL.
AND AND YOU WANNA ENCOURAGE.
EVERYWHERE AND AND AND AND YOU
KNOW IT THIS ISN'T JUST A
WOMEN'S ISSUE MAN ARCTIC JUST
THE ONLY PERPETRATORS BUT MATTER
CONFUSED.
INTO MY SONS ARE CONFUSED.
UP TO THIS IS NOT. THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
OVERNIGHT AND WE ALL NEED HELP
IN HOW TO IN EIGHTEEN HOW TO BE
SUPPORTIVE HOW TO LISTEN AND HOW
TO BEHAVE. AND AGAIN THIS ISN'T
ABOUT.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY IS ABOUT MAKING THE
ORGANIZATION BETTER.
BUT THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY
TO AFFECTS OUR STATE IS NOT
ABOUT SEX EITHER. OUR POWER
GRIDS WITH THAT YEAH THE OTHER
THING AB SEES IN THE MISSING
ELEMENT THOUGH IS ONCE YOU COME
UP WITH THESE VALUES AND WE PUT
THEM UP SO COMING UP THE RIGHT
SAID IS IMPORTANT AS WE'VE JUST
DESCRIBED. BUT THEN YOU GOT IT
ACTUALLY HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND SO THAT IF THEIR BEHAVIORS
IF YOU SAY FOR EXAMPLE WE VALUE
OPENNESS AND TRANSPARENCY
WHEN THEY ARE EXAMPLES BEFORE
YOU GET TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
WORKED OF RACE DISCRIMINATION
ANY. WHEN THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T LIVE BY THOSE VALUES
YOU'VE GOT TO EXPEL THEM.
THERE'S JUST NO OTHER WAY TO DO
IT AND YOU CAN'T DO IT SUBTLY
BECAUSE IT IS SO SUBTLE AND
THAT'S THE DIFFICULTY OF
PERSONNEL MATTERS NEEDING TO.
HELD CONFIDENTIAL IF PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW WHY THE PERSON IS
HELD THEY MAY HAVE BUT PERSON
JUST GOT ANOTHER JOB. WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE NOT MAKING
THE CONNECTION BECAUSE WE GO TO
SUCH LENGTHS TO HIDE IT.
SO PART OF IT IS IF YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE THIS IS WHAT IT MEANS TO
WORK HERE AND IF YOU DON'T LIVE
WITH THEM THIS NO MORE. YOU ARE
VOTED OFF THE ISLAND PEOPLE HAVE
TO KNOW THAT THE PERSON IS VOTED
OFF THE ISLAND FOR THAT AGAIN
WITHOUT DISCLOSING HIGHLY HIGHLY
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION BUT
THAT'S THE DISCONNECTED WE HEAR
THAT FROM EMPLOYEES ALL THE TIME
WE KIND OF QUIETLYLET SOMEONE
GO AWAY. AND SO THE PEOPLE WHO
WAITING TO BELIEVE IN YOU.
DON'T UNDERSTAND ATTRACT DID
YOUR JOB THEY JUST DIDN'T KNOW
THAT THE JOB WAS DONE AND SO YOU
DON'T GET. PEOPLE TO COME FOR TO
THINK THAT'S CRITICAL IN THE
LAST.
POINT THAT I WOULD ASK YOU TO
THINK ABOUT THIS TOO OFTEN WE
SAY THINGS THAT I DON'T THINK
YOU LITERALLY MADE IT WELL THIS
ISN'T AN HR PROBLEM. YES IT IS.
THIS AYE OUR PROFESSION IS HERE
TO HELP YOU
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE JUSTICE THE
FINANCIAL THE CFO'S. WHERE THE
BUDGET DIRECTOR RESPONSIBLE FOR
HELPING YOU SORT OF CHANNEL AND
DIRECT AND MANAGE YOUR FINANCIAL
RESOURCES OUR JOB IS TO DO THE
SAME THING WITH YOUR HUMAN
RESOURCES?
AND SO IF YOU SIMPLY TAKE YOUR
HR FUNCTION AS A PERSONNEL
COMMISSION AN ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTION PEOPLE WHO YOU GOT OUT
OF THE OUT THIS PAPERWORK TO GET
YOUR BENEFITS. YOU'RE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF A WORLD CLASS HR
FUNCTION WE ARE THE NURTURERS
AND KEEPERS OF CULTURE.
I JUST WANTED DAY AND ONE BRIEF
POINT WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOW TO
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE WITH A
SWIFT ACTION WHEN THEY DON'T
LIVE OUR VALUES. I JUST WANNA
KIND OF HIGHLY THAT IT'S ALSO
EQUALLY IMPORTANT SAID RECOGNIZE
AND REWARD PEOPLE COULD DO. AND
I THINK SOMETIMES THAT GETS
MISSED IN THIS DISCUSSION BUT.
Y. TO REALLY LIVE YOUR VALUES
YOU HAVE TO BOTH HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY ACT
OUTSIDE OF THEM. AND ELEVATE
PEOPLE WHO ACT INSIDE OF THEM
MAKE SURE EVERYONE SEES YOU
RECOGNIZING AND REWARDING PEOPLE
THAT ARE INCLUSIVE PEOPLE THAT
ARE THREE. PEOPLE THAT GIVE
OTHERS THE FLOOR PEOPLE THAT
INVITE OTHERS IN.
CREATING INCLUSIVE CULTURE
REQUIRES BOTH THAT CARROT AND
STICK APPROACH ON.
ALCOHOL I WENT BACK AT THE NORTH
FOR THIRTY BUT I THINK THAT
THAT'S REALLY REALLY KEEPS YOU.
I JUST I JUST WANTED TO ADD.
.
FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR POINT ABOUT
THE SWIFT ACTION.
.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL OR A OR A FACULTY
MEMBER WITH.
LIFETIME TENURE THAT SWIFT
ACTION IS NOT QUITE AS EASY AS.
FOR OTHER EMPLOYEES SO I THINK
THAT'S WHERE.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TERMS OF
TRANSPARENCY ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT I'M GIVING COMPLIANCE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE
DONE WHAT YOU CAN DO. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WILL WILL.
OFTEN FOLLOW THE CULTURE RIGHT
SO IN THE IN THE YOU SEE YOU'VE
HAD THE PIERCED THE FACULTY
MEMBERS THEMSELVES STARTING TO
HOLD THEIR COLLEAGUES
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE HAVE TO DO
THAT BECAUSE IT'S THE FACULTY
WHO.
A PLAN THEMSELVES ON SOME LEVEL
IN THE UC.
SO THEY HAVE TO BUY INTO THIS
BEFORE THEY'RE GOING TO HOLD
THEIR COLLEAGUES
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHAT QUESTIONS SHOULD BE I MEAN
IT'S EASY TO SAY THAT'S THE WAY
IT IS BUT THAT'S NOT OKAY TO SAY
WHAT WE TREAT THESE PEOPLE
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TENURE THAT'S RIDICULOUS IF YOU
ARE A? CREDIT OR YOU ARE A
PREDATOR AND WE SHOULD NOT
ACCEPT EFFECT YOU SHOULD BE HELD
TO A HIGHER STANDARD.
CHILDREN PEOPLE'S LIVES WHO
YOU'RE INFECTED A THE IMPACT AND
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S OKAY TO
SAY THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
STANDARD JUMEAU SWIFT BECAUSE
YOU NEED TO MOVE SWIFTLY.
IF SOMEONE IS RUINING SOMEONE'S
LIKE THE PROFESSOR BUT I'M
MENTION THE GEORGE JUST THROUGH
TECHNOLOGY
SHE SET BACK. IN THIS PROCESS OF
GOING THROUGH ALL OF THIS YOU
ARE DESTROYING SOMEONE'S LIFE
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE SO I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT YOUR JOB
LEGISLATORS IS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH THAT. THE IDEA THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE SPECIAL AND
CAN'T BE DEALT WITH BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A PEACE DE ARROBA TO BOOKS
AND HAVE TENURE IS SUBSCRIBER.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR WE GET OUT
WE CAN ALL ARRANGE FOR THE
SECURITY TO HELP THEM GET UP
THAT HILL.
I JUST WANTED TO HAVE ONE REALLY
PRACTICAL
POINT.
.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY DID
IN AND.
CITY OF PHOENIX
WAS THAT ONCE THEY CAME UP WITH
THESE VALUES THAT BECAME THE
STRUCTURE FOR EMPLOYEE
EVALUATIONS.
HOW HAVE YOU CONTRIBUTED TO THIS
VALUE?
IT'S A WAY TO STRUCTURALLY
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
AND TO MAKE IT LIVING TO MAKE A
LIVING AND I KNOW THAT YOU DON'T
DO PERFORMANCE EVALUATIONS OF
LEGISLATORS.
A BUT IF YOU ASK THEM TO.
NDA BUT NOT STAFF BUT BUT IT
KEEPS WOULD HAVE STAFF IF IF
THAT'S THE WAY STAFFERS
EVALUATED AT LEAST THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUES RIGHT.
I WAS GONNA GOING TO MISS.
IMMERSE AND.
.
SHE'S GONE I'M GONNA STATE MY
QUESTION FOR THE RECORD AND SO
WE CAN JUST GET BACK TO HER JUST
SO SHE KNOWS AND THEN MADAM
CHAIR I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION
ON TO MY QUESTION THIS IMMERSE
AND.
I'VE READ HER ARTICLE IN THE
HARVARD BUSINESS REVIEW WITH
REGARD TO ON IMPLICIT BIAS.
AND MY QUESTION WAS IF THERE WAS
AN INTERSECTION BETWEEN IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
INSIDE JUST CURIOUS ABOUT THAT
SHOULDN'T TOUCH ON THAT. UP.
MR.
.
TAYLOR I CAN GO BACK TO YOU I I
HAD A VICE PRESIDENT HR WHO
REQUIRE THAT I SINCE SHE IN MY
ENTIRE HR DEPARTMENT TO THE
SHARM CONFERENCES IN LAS VEGAS
EVERY YEAR SESSION WAS A
BELIEVER.
AND.
UP AND AND CONVINCE ME THAT HR
MUST ACT AS THE CONSCIOUS OF THE
COMPANY SO I SEE THAT IN YOUR
STATEMENT AS WELL SO. YOU YOU
YOU BRAINWASHED PEOPLE YEAH BUT
THEY CAME BACK AND THEY.
BEADED OVER MY HEAD I I GOT IT.
AND YOU KNOW AS WE YOU KNOW MY
FATHER TO ME IS A GO YOU PUT ONE
FINGER OUT THERE THREE POINTING
BACK AT YOU. AND SO.
I WONDER WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS
THE LEGISLATURE TO OUR BUDGETING
PROCESS.
.
IN MAKING SURE S. COLLINS WOULD
SAY WE HAVE THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN
THE RIGHT SEATS ON THE BUS IN
OUR OWN HR FUNCTIONS.
IF WE.
HAVE BOTH EMPOWER THEM FASHION
THEIR JOB STATEMENTS DEVELOP
REIMBURSEMENT. THAT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR WHAT WE NEED
GIVEN THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANTIAL
SOMETIMES WE GET LOCKED INTO.
ON THE STATE HR WE BUY INTO
THEIR JOB DESCRIPTIONS
AND I'M WONDERING IF WE NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB OF BUILDING AN
HR FUNCTION FUNCTION. AND PAYING
FOR AN INCREASE IN THE SLOTS IN
THE POSITIONS.
THAT TRULY MEET THE NEEDS.
THE UNIQUE AND RATHER CUSTOMARY
NEEDS OF AN ORGANIZATION THE
SIZE THAT WE ARE SENATE HAS NINE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES THE ASSEMBLY
HAVE PROBABLY ALMOST DOUBLE
THAT.
AND SO YOU KNOW I I SOMETIMES
GOVERNMENT YOU KNOW WE WE
BELIEVE THE LOWEST BID GETS
THERE. AND SO.
WE PROBABLY NEED TO LOOK DEEPLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
STRUCTURE AND THE JOB
DESCRIPTIONS AND THEREFORE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE RIGHT. AND SO
HAVING HAVE THAT AHA MOMENT.
I'M WONDERING IF IF YOU CAN
TELL US
HOW YOU ASSESS IT AN HR
DEPARTMENT IS FUNCTIONING WELL.
SO THAT SAU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
SO WE HAVE A CERTIFICATION.
A YOU KNOW JUST AS THE.
CPA FOR FOR FOUR FINANCE
PROFESSIONALS AND NOT LICENSURE
LIKE LAWYERS AND MEDICAL DOCTORS
BUT BUT BUT CERTIFICATION.
THAT WE CALL THE SHARM BODY OF
COMPETENCY AND KNOWLEDGE.
AND WE CALL IT BLOCK AND AND THE
FOCUS THERE IS IT WILL ALLOW YOU
TO KNOW IF THE PERSON HAS THE
NECESSARY SKILLS TO OPERATE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
HR. WHO FRANKLY OFTENTIMES MY
EXPERIENCE IN DEALING WITH
PEOPLE IN STATE LEGISLATURES UP
LATE STEP STATE ENVIRONMENT HR
FUNCTIONS IS THAT THEY'RE STILL
A LITTLE BIT OF A PERSONNEL
NATURE TO WHAT THEY DO IT'S VERY
ADMINISTRATIVE IMMENSE NOT IN
KEEPING WITH A SORT OF HUMAN
CAPITAL? TYPE APPROACH TO HR AND
SAID YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE BEST
PEOPLE BECAUSE THE BEST PEOPLE
WHAT REALLY. HARD DIFFICULT
THORNY COMPLEX JOBS AND IF THEY
ARE RELEGATED TO JUST DOING
STUFF PUSHING PAPER THEN THEY
WON'T COME THEY ARE AND THE
RESULT IS IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
BEST PEOPLE IN HR. YOU CAN
EXPECT TO DROP THIS CULTURE
DISCUSSIONS I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
AS A PROFESSION THEY NEED
TRAINING. AND THEY NEED
CONSISTENT TRAINING BECAUSE THIS
THING IS CHANGING TWO YEARS AGO
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT MEET.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
WERE TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE SO IT'S NOT LIKE YOU CAN
SEND SOMEONE TO TRAINING.
ONE YEAR ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS
AND THINK THEY'VE GOT IT AYE I
THANK YOU FOR SENDING AND
COMMITTING TO SENDING YOUR VP OF
HR IN TEEN THERE BECAUSE THEY
ARE CONSTANTLY. EVOLVING AS WELL
BUT THE KEY IS TO.
FIND THE RIGHT HRP.
AND THAT DOES TAKE A YOU KNOW
BUT I OFTENTIMES MY TEST FOR
THEM AS I ASKED HIM ABOUT
COURAGE.
IN THE PROCESS I CLEARLY WANNA
KNOW IF YOU'D EXPERT IF YOU'RE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT AND YOU
UNDERSTAND.
THE COMPETENCIES AND AND THE
BODY OF KNOWLEDGE OF HR BUT THEN
I WON UNDERSTAND BECAUSE YOU CAN
KNOW IT BUT BE AFRAID TO.
TO USE IT AND TO PRACTICE
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF OUR
QUESTIONS IS.
ARE YOU READY TO DO IT WHEN
YOU'RE FACED WITH ONE OF THOSE
DILEMMAS WHEN YOU HAVE TO COME
AND MEET WITH A PERSON
POWER AND HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT THEY'RE
CREATING IN THEIR WORKPLACE AND
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT PERSON NO
MATTER HOW TALENTED THEY ARE.
YOU HAVE A PROBLEM SO
CERTIFICATIONS NUMBER ONE AND
THEN LOOKING FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THAT COURAGE.
IF I COULD IF I COULD TRY MEN I
I'M I'M NOT HR.
BUT I THINK THE UNIVERSITY
HAVING THAT REQUIREMENTS HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT OFFICE
WHICH OVERSEES THE POLICY
REPORTS A VERY HIGH LEVEL.
YOU KNOW AT.
THE ONLY PERSON WHO I MEAN MY
CLIENT I ALWAYS SAY IS NOT THE
UNIVERSITY IT'S GENDER EQUITY.
AND AND THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
LEGAL MANDATES UNDER THE FEDERAL
SCHEME BUT THERE'S NO REASON
WHY.
YOU COULDN'T REPLICATE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WHERE YOU
REALLY HAVE. A FULLY INDEPENDENT
OFFICE THAT YES GETS ITS
PAYCHECK FROM THE LEGISLATURE
BUT OTHERWISE.
REPORTS INDEPENDENTLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
.
SCOOP UP.
SHORTER QUESTIONS IN UP INSIDE
TO SEE MISS EMERSON GO BECAUSE I
THINK SHE PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
BEEN GOOD FOR THIS ONE.
AS WELL AS MISS SOMEBODY.
.
YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE ALLOTS IN
OUR CULTURE REGARDING BULLYING.
YOU KNOW AND IN THE SCHOOL
SETTING AS A MOM YOU NO. THAT'S
KIND OF BEEN AN ONGOING THING
SINCE NOW MY SON IS SIXTEEN
MINUTES YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN DEVELOPING. AND
USING NEW TECHNOLOGIES YOU KNOW
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
IS NOT REALLY THE FORTE OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE I CAN TELL YOU
THAT BECAUSE WE ARE STILL WAY
BACK AS FAR AS THAT GOES.
BUT YOU KNOW LOOKING AT WHAT HAS
BEEN DONE WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
TRYING TWO GET THAT HERE I MEAN
PEERS ARE SO IMPORTANT TO YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND HOW THEY ARE ABLE TO
USE NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
TO.
EMPOWER EACH OTHER.
ATTACKED
TO MAYBE REPORT AND THERE'S APPS
YOU KNOW OUT THERE THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE CAN USE.
THERE'S DIFFERENT NAMES I'VE
SEEN ONE OF LIKE AYE. AN AYE
ICON LOOKING AYE ABLE THING. AND
THAT SOMEONE POSTS SOMETHING
THAT IS.
YOU KNOW.
IT SHOWS AND TOLERANCE YOU KNOW
IT COULD BE ANY NOT JUST SEXUAL
IT COULD BE RACIAL INTOLERANCE
YOU KNOW. AGAINST THE
TRANSGENDER PERSON.
OR AGE OR YOU KNOW WHATEVER IT
IS.
A RACIALLY MOTIVATED OR
CULTURAL.
THEY CAN PUT THAT.
ICON.
AND THAT'S SAYS SOMEONE'S
WATCHING YOUR PEERS OR WATCHING
AND THEN OTHER PEOPLE JOIN IN
WITH THAT. AND THEN THAT PERSON
IS ISOLATED IN THE ONE WHO DID
IT IN THAT MAYBE THEY'LL SAY
WELL YOU KNOW I.
OFTEN DO THAT ANYMORE THIS THING
GET THE RESPONSE THAT I WANTED.
.
I THINK AND AND.
WHEN ONE OF OUR OTHER HEARINGS
THE ONE OF THE ATTORNEY GROUPS
HAD TALKED ABOUT. THAT PEER
CULTURE IN A WORKPLACE.
AND.
I THINK THAT'S SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE DO A LOT OF
THINGS IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
OUR STAFF SO WITH US. WE GO TO
RECEPTIONS OFF SITE WHERE IT
MEETINGS WERE ACT SOCIAL
GATHERINGS IN OUR DISTRICTS
WHERE THERE'S LOTS OF PEOPLE
FROM THE PUBLIC AS WELL AS. YOU
KNOW STAFF AT ALL LEVELS.
AND.
PEOPLE SEE THINGS THEY MAY
QUESTION OR THEY THINK THAT'S
NOT APPROPRIATE YOU KNOW HOW DO
WE BE ABLE IS THERE. THE ABILITY
OR HAS THAT BEEN DEVELOPING IN
THIS TYPE OF ISSUE. IN THE
CORPORATE SETTING TAKING IT FROM
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN EDUCATION.
TO ALLOW PEERS TO START TO SAY.
.
YOU KNOW THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE.
OR REMINDING SOMEONE YOU KNOW WE
SAW WHAT YOU DID OR.
USING TECHNOLOGY EVEN
HOW DO WE.
YEAH BIT WILL NOT ALLOWING IT TO
PROGRESS
LIKE IT HAPPENS.
AN I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S EVEN
ANYTHING THAT IS BEING USED IN
MODERN.
YOU KNOW.
BUT I THINK THAT'S REALLY PART
OF HOW WE DEVELOPED CULTURE.
MISS EVERYONE WE HAVE LIKE WE
SAID YOUNG STAFF YOUNG INTERN
SERVED.
ROLL UP I MEAN.
YOU KNOW I I HAVE TO ASK MY SON
HOW TO FIX
MY OPINION THINGS HE CAN DO IT.
TO INVEST TWO SECONDS. SO.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A WAY TO
STOP OUR.
IN ON.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S EVEN.
ON THE TABLE.
.
FOR I MEAN I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
I THINK THAT THE STUDENTS HAVE
COME UP WITH A LOT OF INNOVATIVE
PURER.
SELF GOVERNING IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT.
.
REPORTING OPTIONS FOR YOUNGER
PEOPLE WHO DON'T FEEL EMPOWERED.
THERE'S A LOT OF TECH THERE'S
WIDE ABSENT TECHNOLOGY FOR SORT
OF ANONYMOUS REPORTING. ON THE
COLLEGES ARE STARTING TO USE
WHICH MAKE A LOT OF SENSE.
SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE A VERY
GOOD IDEA. BUT ALSO TO YOUR
POINT.
.
IT'S ABOUT YOUR PEERS AND IF
YOU'RE NOT USING TECHNOLOGY.
WHAT ARE OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN
HOLD?
PIERRE IS ACCOUNTABLE ABOUT SORT
OF WHAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT WITH
THE FACULTY NOT THAT WE WERE
PLAYING A DIFFERENT STANDARD.
FOR DISCIPLINING THEM AS MUCH
AS IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE.
OUR OWN PEERS HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE. MY YEAH WHAT WAS
ONE OF THE ANTINAUSEA SINCE
IT'S SOMEWHAT LIKE AN APP CALLED
SPEAK UP YOU CAN DO ANONYMOUS
REPORTING.
FOR BULLYING
OPPRESSION YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
NOTICES THEIR SAFETY THREAT.
IT COULD BE A LOT OF THINGS BUT
I THINK SEXUAL HARASSMENT COULD
BE PART OF THAT THERE ARE AND
THERE THERE ARE ALSO
APPLICATIONS THAT.
WOULD COLLECT
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIME SOMEONE
DOESN'T ONE REPORT. ON BECAUSE
THEY THINK A WELL IT'S JUST I
PROBABLY IMAGINED IT OR MAYBE
I'M MAKING TOO BIG A DEAL OUT OF
THIS BUT IF THEY KNOW THAT THE
PERSON HAS DONE IT TO SOMEONE
ELSE. THEY'RE MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO COME FORWARD AND REPORT SO
THERE'S NOW TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
COLLECTING. REPORTS.
ON THE CONDITION OF HE LET ME
KNOW IF SOMEONE ELSE REPORTS
THIS PERSON AS WELL AND NOT
WOULD CHANGE.
YOU KNOW THEIR DECISION MAKING.
S. WATCHIN IT'S INTERESTING HOW
WAS THAT AND IN ONE OF MY LAST
LIVES NOT PROTECT THE NAME OF
THE COMPANY BUT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY THESE OF OUR TECHNOLOGY
TO ACTUALLY MONITOR WHAT OUR
YOUNG. ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON THE YOUNG
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA
ACTIVITY FOR SECURITY REASONS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'VE GOT THAT WE THINK OF
USING THESE TOOLS FOR PURPOSES
OF SORT OF HOW DO YOU REPORT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT RACE
DISCRIMINATION ETCETERA. WHAT WE
FOUND THAT WAS A SHOCK TO WISH
YOU WANNA TALK ABOUT CULTURE
SOME OF THE WAYS THEY SPOKE TO
EACH OTHER?
OKAY SO WE HAD AND WE LITERALLY
WOULD CALL IN AND SEE IT. IF
YOU'RE MALE EMPLOYEE HAD SET
THIS TO YOU IN THE WORKPLACE
YOU'D BE AN HR.
HAVE A DISCUSSION YOU REFERRED
TO ANOTHER WOMAN FELLOW EMPLOYEE
USE THAT THE WORD THIS WORD THAT
WORD.
AND SO WE SAID YOU ARE
DESENSITIZING THE ORGANIZATION
TO AND IT'S IT'S NOT THAT YOU DO
THIS AFTER HOURS BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT A DIFFERENCE EVERYONE WORKS
TWENTY FOUR HOURS NOW. YOU KNOW
YOU ONLINE BUT THINK ABOUT THAT
THIS IS YOUR MIND SAID THIS IS
WHAT WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE AND SO YOUR POINT'S WELL
TAKEN BUT I JUST DON'T WANT IT
TO BE I DON'T THINK FROM HR
PERSPECTIVE. THAT WE CAN
COMPARTMENTALIZE PEOPLE'S LIVES
LIKE THAT THE IDEA THAT YOU
ALLOW. MANY OF OUR EMPLOYEES
REALLY ENGAGED IN SOME TERRIBLY
INAPPROPRIATE AND DIVISIVE
CONVERSATION ONLINE AND THEY
THINK I'M DOING THIS ON MY UP TO
MY OWN TIME ON MY HOME COMPUTER
DATA DOT. WILL. FAST FORWARD
THEY BRING THOSE MIND SETS ENACT
CULTURAL THINKING TO WORK AND
THERE'S NO WAY TO
COMPARTMENTALIZE IT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THEY THINK THEY CAN.
AND BY THE WAY IF YOUR COLLEAGUE
SAW IT
AND YOUR COLLEAGUE YOU KNOW.
THEY MAY TREAT YOU DIFFERENTLY
AT WORK AS A RESULT OF IT SO
PART OF THIS IS AND I WISH YOU
KNOW WAS HERE IT IS A BROADER
CONVERSATION.
ABOUT WHO IS IT THAT WE BRING
INTO OUR ORGANIZATION NOT JUST
THEIR BEHAVIOR YOU KNOW AT WORK
DURING THE FOR WHAT YOU KNOW THE
FOUR WALLS OF THE BUILDING. BUT
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE AND HOW CAN
WE INFLUENCE HOW THE GROW UP.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE HIGHER IT
SPACE IS THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT
GOING REPORT. UP BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT HAS OCCURRED TO YOU BUT
LOOK AT THE MAN OR THE WOMAN IN
THE MIRROR AND SAY WHO AM I HAS
SWELLED TO I SEE SOME REALLY BAD
THINGS ABOUT PEOPLE. TRANSGENDER
ODD COMMENTS ABOUT ELDERLY THE
ELDERLY PART AMAZING ON.
SHE'S ALL SHE IS THAT SHE'S
THAT AND I'D SO
CALLED SOME OF THE EMPLOYEES AND
TO SAY WE WATCH YOUR TWITTER
FEED.
AND AND YOU KNOW AS MUCH AS YOU
TALK ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE LET ME
TELL YOU YOU HAVE SOME PRETTY
BAD BEHAVIOR CHRIS THE HEALTH.
AND THAT HELPED PEOPLE BEGIN TO
UNDERSTAND AND EMPATHIZE AND AND
CHANGED OUR CULTURE
ROOM AND THAT'S WHAT'S SO
INTERESTING ABOUT THE PURE YOU
KNOW USING THESE APPS BECAUSE.
WHEN THEY SEE SOMETHING.
THEY CAN PUT THAT ICON EVERYONE
KNOWS WHAT THAT MEANS AND OTHERS
CAN JUMP ON. AND IT'S YOU KNOW
IT IS A CULTURE COMING AROUND
I'M JUST REALLY QUICK ALSO FROM
YOU KNOW WITH TITLE NINE I JUST
WANNA SAY.
HIM.
WHEN I WAS YOUNG. BEING SOMEONE
WHO NEVER REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT
YOU KNOW THAT.
I COULDN'T DO SOMETHING BECAUSE
I WAS BROUGHT UP IN ON THE
DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANTS AND. IN
THE SOUTH BRONX AND WENT ON TO.
WIN THE CITY CHAMPIONSHIP THAT
CA JUST A A CITY CHAMPIONSHIP
ACROSS COUNTRY IN NEW YORK
BECAUSE OF TITLE NINE. AND I
KNOW THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE IN OF
DAWN ON THEM IN THE SENATOR HAVE
A NEGATIVE CONNOTATION ABOUT IT.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST IT'S
IT ALLOWS YOU TO BELIEVE YOU CAN
BE ANYTHING. THAT YOU WANT TO BE
AND YOU KNOW THEN YOU COME IN
THE WORKPLACE AND YOU TRY AND
THINGS HAPPEN THAT.
YOU KNOW IT KIND OF HITS YOU
LIKE WOW YOU KNOW. IT IS A.
THAT A NEW AWAKENING.
.
BUT I ONE I WAS GONNA ASK IF YOU
COULD JUST TALK A LITTLE MORE
ABOUT THE CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE.
AND HOW THAT WORKS.
YES.
SO EVERY CAMPUS HAS A
CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE THEIR
THEIR LEGALLY PRIVILEGED THEY'RE
TRAINED AS SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COUNSELORS AND
IN FACT SENATOR JACKSON'S
SPONSORED A BILL LAST YEAR THAT.
INSURE THAT THEY WOULD HAVE.
A LEGAL PRIVILEGE WHEN THEY'RE
COUNTING ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AS
WELL AND LAW.
THANK YOU HUNT BUT I SO SO
THEY'RE ALSO INDEPENDENT.
THEY BASICALLY SERVE AS A
RESOURCE SO IF SOMEONE GOES TO
THEM THEY CAN COME IN A
CONFIDENTIAL SPACE EXPLAINS THEM
HERE YOUR OPTIONS THIS IS WHAT
IT WOULD LOOK LIKE IF YOU
REPORTED. ON THIS IS WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE IF YOU DON'T WANNA
REPORT RIGHT NOW BUT MAYBE WE
CAN DO SOMETHING ELSE FOR YOU.
I THINK
PEOPLE HAVE A FEAR OF COMING
FORWARD BECAUSE THEY THINK IT'S
GONNA START.
I TRAIN LEAVING THE STATION THAT
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO CONTROL
AND SO THE MORE YOU CAN MAKE
SOMEONE FEEL THAT THEY'RE IN
CONTROL. OF THAT PROCESS THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE TO COME
FORWARD.
SO WE FOUND THOSE CONFIDENTIAL
ADVOCATES I THINK OUR STUDENTS
WOULD CERTAINLY SAY THAT'S BEEN
THE MOST IMPORTANT AN OVATION
WE'VE. WE'VE PUT ON THE CAMPUS.
ALICE COMMENT THAT WE'VE.
HOTLINE THAT WE ARE CONTRACTING
WITH I'M WILL PROVIDE A LOT OF
THE SERVICES TO.
PEOPLE WHO COME IN CONTACT WITH
US SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ACTUALLY PERFECT TIMING.
MISSILE ALL DAY I HAD A
FOLLOWUP QUESTION ONE WAS ABOUT
THE CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE AND
THEN YOU ALSO MENTIONED THAT YOU
HAD A NON BOATS PERSON ONE WHAT
IS THE DIFFERENCE IN. THE THE
ROLE OF THE ON BUT PERSON VERSUS
THE CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING SO THE
CONFERENCE ADVOCATE AS I
MENTIONED IS IS LEGALLY
PRIVILEGED AND.
TYPICALLY I THINK HAS BEEN
THOUGHT OF MORE IN THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
SPACE ON AND PROBABLY MORE
STUDENT FOCUSED ALTHOUGH THEY DO
AT THIS POINT SERVE OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY THE ARM BUDS.
WOULD BE NOT CERTAINLY THEY
WOULD HAVE ANY KIND OF LEGAL
PRIVILEGE
BUT THEY ARE CONFIDENTIAL THE
SENSE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
REPORT. ON MANY OF OUR EMPLOYEES
ARE WHAT WE CALL RESPONSIBLE
EMPLOYEES WHICH MEANS THAT IF
THEY BECOME AWARE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THEY NEED TO REPORT
IT. TO TITLE NINE
I'M ENTITLED LINE DECIDES
WORKING WITH THAT YOU KNOW
VICTIMS WHAT TO DO FROM THERE.
ON SO BUT THE ON WHAT'S DO NOT
HAVE THAT REPORTING OBLIGATION
SO THERE'S STILL A CONFIDENTIAL
SPACE THAT CAN TRY TO WORK WITH
THE PERSON TO COME UP WITH
ALTERNATIVES AND RESOLUTIONS ON.
EXPLAIN OPTIONS SORT OF HELP
THEM MAKE DECISIONS
AND DID YOU SEE THAT THE
CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE YOU
THOUGHT IT WAS ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS THAT YOU HAD INSTITUTED.
HOW LONG AGO DID THAT START ON
THE CAMPUSES?
I THINK SOME CAMPUSES HAD THESE
ADVOCATES FOR YEARS BUT IT WAS
IN EARLY TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT THE
PRESIDENT ENSURE THAT EVERY
CAMPUS HAD THAT SORT OF
INDEPENDENT FULLY CONFIDENTIAL
ADVOCATE.
THAT'S GREAT THAT'S THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL BECAUSE WERE STRUGGLING
WITH HOW DO WE MAKE AND CREATE A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR EMPLOYEES
TO COME FORWARD. AND REPORT WHAT
HAS HAPPENED TO THEM RIGHT.
SO I THINK COUNTY NOT
CONFIDENTIAL FIRST STOP IS
CRITICAL I WOULD AGREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND MISTER TAYLOR
YOUR COMMENT ABOUT WE NEED
COURAGEOUS HR I WOULD SAY WE
NEED COURAGEOUS PEOPLE IN THIS
THING THAT WE CALL LIFE. AND IT
GOES BACK TO THE COMMENT THAT
SOMEONE MADE ABOUT HOW TO BE A
COULD BYSTANDER. IT'S KINDA LIKE
BEING A BULLY YOU TELL YOUR
CHILDREN NOT TO BE A BULLY BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS WE TOLD OUR
CHILDREN AS IT'S EVEN WORSE IF
YOU SEE SOMEONE BEING BULLIED
AND YOU DON'T STEP IN. AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ALL EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
US BE JUST ALWAYS THINK ABOUT
HOW CAN I HELP MAKE THE
SITUATION BETTER. AND I THINK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS VERY HELPFUL VERY
ENLIGHTENING THINK THEY COMMAND
CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
PROFESSOR DAN HARD I'M
BEGINNING TO FEEL THAT CULTURE
IS MULTI LAYERED.
INTERPERSONAL CULTURE
CORPORATE CULTURE INNOVATION
CULTURE BUSINESS CULTURE.
I EN UN VOTE.
THE GOLD STANDARD THAT PETER.
DRUCKER
I DOES YOU HAVE A.
A BOOK ON OR DIZZY HAVE A
CHAPTER ON. CULTURE.
.
I COULD FIND ONE FOR YOU HE.
IN HIS MOST INFLUENTIAL BOOK
WAS WRITTEN IN NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR.
I DON'T.
THINK HE'S STILL ALIVE THAT.
.
OF A BUT I'M FORGETTING THE NAME
OF THE BOOK RIGHT NOW BUT ALL
GET FREE. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
BOOKS INTO.
COME TO MIND THAT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL LINE.
GAIN.
I HAVE ATTENDED THE NORFOLK
COUNTY.
.
HARVARD BUSINESS SCHOOL ALUMNI.
CONFERENCE A FEW YEARS AGO AND I
GET TO LISTEN TO.
THE FOUNDER AND CEO ZAPPOS
YEAH.
COMPANY MY WIFE HAS A
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
PROBABLY PUMP SORRY AND AND AND
HE WROTE A BOOK.
ABOUT CORPORATE CULTURE AND I
LISTEN TO HIM SPEAK AND I YOU
KNOW YOU WOULD YOU TALK ABOUT
DUES USING UP POSITIVE.
APPROACH.
I TOLD YOU SEE. ROAD DELIVERING
HAPPINESS.
A PATH TO PROFITS PASSION AND
PURPOSE.
AND IT'S DYNAMIC. ON.
HOWEVER BUDDY IN THE COMPANY
TREATS CUSTOMERS AND.
INDIVIDUALS AND IMPACT.
THEY HAVE A POLICY IF YOU DON'T
LIKE THE CULTURE AT ZAPPOS AFTER
YOU BEEN THERE FOR SIX MONTHS
THEY GIVE YOU A BIG BONUS TO
LEAVE.
THAT'S AND SO I'M JUST WONDERING
IF.
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD BOOK TO
SHARE IT WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
OR OF WERE BE SHOULD COME IN
SPEAKER IF THERE'S A VIDEO NOW
IF YOU COULD GET HIM TO COME AND
SPEAK AT THE MARVELOUS THE OTHER
ARM. FOUND GREAT EXAMPLE OF
POSITIVE ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES.
.
THE.
PERSON IS PROBABLY BEST KNOWN IN
THIS FIELD IS A PROFESSOR
PRESIDENT ACKER SHINE.
IT'S S. C. H. E. AYE AND.
HAS WRITTEN A LOT ABOUT.
CULTURE AND LAYERS OF CULTURE.
.
IT ALSO.
IT SOME OF THIS CONVERSATION
YOU'RE CORRECT.
POLITICAL CULTURE AND
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE.
INTERSECT.
.
WE WE ALL BRING LAYERS OF
CULTURE TO WORK.
AND SO.
OUR NATIONAL CULTURE
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE A
POLITICAL CULTURE.
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE
SUBCULTURES.
ALL OVERLAP IN AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS IT'S SO COMPLEX TO
CHANGE.
IS THAT WE'RE ALL BRINGING IN
DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES AND HISTORIES AND.
AND AND NORMS ABOUT BEHAVIOR.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS I WOULD LOOK
AT ECHO SHINE. I WOULD LOOK AT
ZAPPOS I WOULD LOOK AT SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES.
BUT THERE'S A LOT RIGHT NOW.
.
A LOT OF THE WRITING ON
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE IS ABOUT
CREATING A CULTURE OF INNOVATION
AND RESILIENCE.
AND WHAT YOU WANT IS IS.
ITS ONE THING TO HAVE A STRONG
CULTURE IT'S VERY GOOD TO HAVE A
STRONG CULTURE IN LESS.
ONE OF THE TENETS OF THAT
CULTURE IS TO NOT CHANGE.
AND SO WHAT YOU WANT IT WHAT
YOU WANT IS YOU WANT A RESILIENT
FLEXIBLE CULTURE.
AND THE WAY THAT YOU GET A
RESILIENT FLEXIBLE CULTURE THAT
ADAPTS TO THE ITS EXTERNAL
FORCES. IS BY HAVING A CULTURE
THAT VALUES TRUST AND STABILITY
AND SAFETY.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
CULTURE IS NOT JUST SOME.
YOU KNOW KUN BY ALLAH YOU KNOW.
TOUCHY FEELY THING IS THE THING
THAT DRIVES. ORGANIZATIONAL
SUCCESS AND PROFITABILITY IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND IT'S WHAT A
DRIVES ORGANIZATIONAL SUCCESS
AND PUBLIC SECTOR NONPROFIT.
I SAW BODY.
.
YOU HAVE COUNSELING ON CAMPUS.
WHAT YOU DO TO HELP OUT VICTIMS?
BUT IT MYSELF FOR US AS ONE OF
THE COUNSELORS DEREK YOU WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS WHAT IS YOUR
ORGANIZATION DOING TO HELP PICK.
DO YOU REFER THEM TO SOMEONE ARE
DO YOU HAVE SOME INTERNAL.
AT THE COUNTY IF WE HAD A.
A MAJOR A VET.
YOU BRING AND COUNSELORS MOVES.
RIGHT AND HELP ME PICK RECOUNTS
WRITER WHATEVER.
WHAT WOULD WE HAVE TO HELP
SOMEONE WHO SAYS HEY I I'VE BEEN
ARRESTED RIGHT? IT'S IMPACTING
IS. TAYLOR SAID SO HOW DO WE.
OR ARE WE REQUIRED.
TO HELP OUT. IN SOME WAY DO IT
WITH THERE SHOULD BE SOME.
MAYBE SOME.
BUDGET ITEM THAT IS WE HAVE
SOMEHOW RESTORED HIS MERCY IS SO
DRAMATIC RIGHT.
WE ARE REQUIRED TO DO THAT UNDER
TITLE NINE AND.
.
NOW WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IS IS
VERY CHALLENGING BUT I FEEL ON
SOME OF THE LUCKY HUNT THAT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE. ON THAT
WE DO HAVE TO DO AND I AND I
HAVE THOUGHT TO MYSELF THAT
STUDENTS ON IS.
HORRIBLE AS IT IS TO EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL
VIOLENCE I DO THINK ON. THE UC
HAS.
AS I'M SURE MANY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES YOU HAVE SO MANY
SUPPORT SYSTEMS IN PLACE FOR IT
FOR THOSE.
FOLKS WHO DO SO ON YOU KNOW WE
WE HAVE OUR COUNSELORS WE HAVE
STUDENT COUNSELING CENTERS WE
HAVE EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE AND
COUNSELING CENTERS.
WE HAVE A TITLE MIND OFFICE
WITH LEGAL MANDATES AND A STRONG
POLICY AND WE ARE REQUIRED TO IF
WE FIND THE PERSON AS EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. UP WERE
REQUIRED TO REMEDY THAT.
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IN A GIVEN
CASES IS COMPLICATED BUT WE DO
WORK WITH HR OR ACADEMIC
COUNSELING OR WHOEVER WE NEED TO
WORK WITH?
TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL OR ACADEMIC PROGRESS
IS.
RESUMED AND MAINTAINED.
IT'S.
VERY CHALLENGING.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO IT THANK YOU
TAYLOR ASKED LAST QUESTION.
SUMMING I USED TO DO I STILL DO.
.
WAS HAVE EXIT INTERVIEWS IT WAS
YOUR LAST WEEK I'D SAY
COMMANDED.
AND I SAID I'M NOT TAKEN NOTES
AT THIS IS FREE FOR ALL YOU DID
AND TELL ME.
WHAT I NEED TO KNOW WHAT DO I
NEED TO KNOW IS THE MANAGER OF
THIS DEPARTMENT WHAT WHAT SHOULD
I CHANGE?
AND IT WOULD USUALLY BE LIKE.
WATCHLIST DRESS CASUAL ONCE IN
AWHILE IT'S WERE.
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE A RADIO AT OUR
DESK YOU'RE YOU KNOW AS I NEVER
HAD SOMEONE SAY SO AND SO IS
DOING THIS I'M NEVER AND NEVER
HAD? YOU GOTTA YOU GOTTA TAKE
CARE OF SILENCE HOPE.
BUT TOM.
I'M JUST WONDERING ABOUT THE
EFFICACY OF AFFECTION ABUSES AT
SOMETHING YOU ADVOCATE. WHAT'S
INTERESTING NOT ONLY DO WE
ADVOCATE THE USE OF OF.
.
EXIT SURVEYS BUT AN EXIT
INTERVIEWS SO AND IN SOME OF THE
BEST PRACTICES ISSUE HAPPENED
WHEN THE PERSON IS EXITING THEIR
LAST DAY. YOU HAVE A ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATION WITH THEM TO SAY
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE
HERE ONE OF THE BEST PRACTICES
IS YOU ALSO READ OFF THE VALUES
THE ORGANIZATION AND SAY. HOW
DID WE RATE? WILL YOUR
EXPERIENCE WHILE HERE DID WE
LIVE THOSE VALUES IT HELPS YOU
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT REALLY MEANS.
BUT ONE OF THE THAT THE BEST
INVENTIONS INTERVENTIONS THAT
I'VE SEEN AS OF LATE. IS THEN
ABOUT A MONTH LATER.
YOU HAVE AN INDEPENDENT PARTY
CALLED THE EMPLOYEE TO SAY NOW
YOU'VE STEPPED AWAY FROM.
YOU'RE DONE.
LET ME ASK YOU ANOTHER SERIES
OF.
AND YOU DELVE A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER
BECAUSE THERE ARE LIMITATIONS
ULTIMATELY YOU DON'T WANNA SAY
ANYTHING TOO BADLY ABOUT YOUR
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE YOU MAY
NEED THAT SAME ORGANIZATION TO
GIVE YOU A REFERENCE IN THE
FUTURE RIGHT EVEN IF YOU LEAVE
THERE WITH THE JOB IT MIGHT BE
YOUR NEXT. JOB THAT YOU NEED AT
THE SECOND OR THIRD JOB SO WHAT
WE FOUND IS USING AN INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATION TO BAN CALL ABOUT A
MONTHLATER SO THEY'VE STEPPED
AWAY FROM IT. ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
LEFT UNDER SITUATIONS WITH
EXPERIENCED A CRISIS
THEY'RE TOO CLOSE TO IT TO
REALLY DEAL WITH IT. GIVEN A
MONTH LATER HAVE SOMEONE CALL
THEM INDEPENDENTLY AND IT'S BEEN
A GREAT PRACTICE FOR US TO
LEARN.
A EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
SHOP.
THANK YOU RICHARD TAYLOR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS.
THANK YOU.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT
TODAY'S HEARING WAS CENTERED ON
CULTURE AND THE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT.
IDEA THAT WE REALLY HAVE TO GET
A HANDLE ON. LIFE RECEIVED ALL
OF YOUR COMMENTS REGARDING
CULTURE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
BEGINNING.
OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE IN
THE FUTURE.
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT WAS
MADE HAD TO DO WITH. YOU WANT TO
BE SURE.
.
TO TAILOR THAT YOU HAVE
COURAGEOUS HR PEOPLE.
AND THE ONE THING THAT CAME TO
MIND IS.
THE NEED TO EMPOWER OUR AGE ARE
REPRESENTATIVES AS WELL.
IF.
THEY.
THE CULTURE HAS BEEN SUCH THAT
THEY ARE TOLD WHAT THEY HAVE TO
DO THEN WERE NOT EMPOWERING
THEM.
IS THAT ANOTHER PART OF THE
CULTURE THAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED
AND HOW DO WE CHANGE THAT.
WELL THERE'S A QUICK AND IT
STARTS FROM THE TOP IN THAT
RESPECT.
THE HR LEADERS HAVE TO BELIEVE
THAT WHEN I GO OUT THERE AND I'M
BEING OBJECTIVE AND HONEST AND I
KEEP YOU FEEDBACK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN OUR UP AN
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU WILL DO
SOMETHING WITH THAT AND IF YOU
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT.
THAT YOU WILL AT LEAST NOT HOLD
ME ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE I'M
JUST THE MESSENGER IF YOU WILL.
AND SO ON YOU'RE TO STEP VERSION
IN NATURE PERSON WHO'S
COMFORTABLE ENOUGH AND
COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO DO IT BUT
THEN THE ORGANIZATION AGAIN
CANNOT IMMEDIATELY GIVE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO HIM OR HER.
GOES BACK TO THE STUDIO ADDRESS
OF THE ORGANIZATION THAT THIS
THEY TALK ABOUT IT BUT THEY
DON'T MEAN IT SO THAT SHORT
ANSWER IS IT REQUIRES NOT ONLY
FINDING THE RIGHT AGE A PERSON
BUT CREATING A CULTURE AND
DEPARTMENT OF PEOPLE. BUT ALSO A
CULTURE WITH THE HR FOLKS CAN
REALLY DO WHAT THEY DO BEST AND
THAT IS REALLY SIGNAL TO YOU
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN YOUR.
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT WAS
MADE HAS TO DO WITH HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
AND I KNOW THERE'S A COMMENT
ABOUT THE TENURE PROFESSOR
VERSUS SOMEONE.
TENURED.
WELL I THINK ALONG THE SAME
LINES WE HAVE LEGISLATORS WHO
ARE. ELECTED VERSES IT COULD BE
A SUPERVISOR EMPLOYEES.
CLEARLY THINGS ARE DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE LEGISLATORS
JUST AS OUR CHAIRWOMAN HAS OFTEN
SAID. THEY ARE NOT EMPLOYEES IN
THE THE SAME SENSE OF THAT.
.
ANY OTHER EMPLOYEE WOULD BE
CLASSIFIED.
SO HOW DO YOU FIGURE OUT HOW
YOU.
HOLD SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE.
WHO WAS A LEGISLATOR VERSUS HOW
YOU HOLD SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE
WHO IS A? YET EITHER SUPERVISOR
OR AN EMPLOYEE.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND I AND
I. WANT TO REMEMBER THAT IN BOTH
INSTANCES THERE ARE GOOD REASONS
WHY HEY.
A LEGISLATOR OR A TENURED
PROFESSOR CAN'T BE TERMINATED
LIKE THAT UP FOR TIP FOR
POLITICAL PROTECTION RIGHT IN
ACADEMIC FREEDOM SO IT SO THERE
ARE GOOD REASONS FOR IT.
I THINK IT'S BEEN REALLY
IMPORTANT.
AGAIN TO START TO TIE.
TIED TO THE MISSION.
RIGHT SO TO ENSURE THAT WE THAT
WOULD TO START TALKING TO OUR
FACULTY ABOUT WHY WERE HERE WHY
THEY'RE WHAT THEIR PURPOSE AT
BEING YOU THAT YOU SEE IS. AND
IT'S TO EDUCATE AND WHEN.
WHEN THEY'VE SEEN THESE
PARTICULAR THESE HIGHER PROFILE
MATTERS REALLY DESTROYED
DEPARTMENTS.
DISTRACT THEM FROM THEIR
SMALLER SHIP WOULD BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
REALLY DAMAGE THE INSTITUTION
THAT THEY'VE LOVED AND THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT THEY'VE LOVED.
I THINK THEY'VE BEEN MUCH MORE
WILLING
TO.
HOLD EACH OTHER ACCOUNTABLE AND
THAT REPUTATION THAT
REPUTATIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY IS
QUITE.
QUITE POWERFUL IN IN CERTAINLY
IN IN YOUR HER.
PROFESSION BUT ALSO IN THE IN
THE ACADEMIC PROFESSION
ON AND ON SOME LEVEL.
FACULTY MEMBERS FOUND
RESPONSIBLE FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
.
PAYS A PRICE.
PROBABLY MUCH GREATER THAN A
CORPORATE EMPLOYEE BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S OUT THERE.
AND.
YOU KNOW.
IT'S PUBLIC INFORMATION AND AND
NO YOU KNOW A UNIVERSITY CAN BE
VERY HESITANT TO TAKE ON THAT
FACULTY MEMBER OR EVEN PUBLISH
THEIR WORK.
IF THEIR REPUTATIONS BEEN
DAMAGED IN THAT WAY.
ANOTHER COMMENT THAT WAS MADE
HOW TO DO WITH SWIFT ACTION.
WHEN A REPORT IS RECEIVED.
IN ORDER TO TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR
THEIR HOUSE TO BE SWIFT ACTION
SALUTE YOU KNOW THAT. THE THE.
THE DISCIPLINE OR THE REACTION
ISN'T HE IN RESPONSE TO WHAT WAS
REPORTED.
HOW DO WE BALANCE THAT WITH DUE
PROCESS?
THERE WAS A PAUSE HOME. THAT'S
THE CHALLENGE
A.
SWIFT BUT DELIBERATE. IS PERHAPS
THE WAY THAT WE TRY TO USE THOSE
TERMS
IN HASTE WILL MAKE WASTE AND OWN
WE ARE DEALING WITH PEOPLE'S
LIVES ON BOTH SIDES.
BUT THIS THE SITUATION AND SO
THERE'S A PROCESS THAT SAYS WE
WANT TO MOVE ACROSS BUT I GIVE
YOU A CLASSIC EXAMPLE ALL OF US
IN THE FUTURE WORLD.
FRANKLY AND I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE A NON A CHAU WORLD THAT
WITH THE MATT LAUER SITUATION.
APPARENTLY IF YOU BELIEVE WHAT
WAS SAID.
THE THE REPORT CAME TO THEM FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN TWENTY YEARS
ON A MONDAY AND THEN.
S. FIRED ON TUESDAY.
NO ONE THOUGHT THAT A THAT WAS
OVERLY SWIFT THAT'S THE POINT
EVEN IF THE END RESULT WAS WHAT
IT WAS AND WE BELIEVE THAT WAS
THE RIGHT RESULT. THE IDEA THAT
YOU COULD CONDUCT IN THE
SEMBLANCE OF A REAL
INVESTIGATION AS AN HR
PROFESSIONAL IN LESS INTO
A POOR OURS AND MAKE A DECISION.
YOU CAN MAKE A DECISION TO
SUSPEND WHICH IS A DIFFERENT
DECISION THAN A FULL OUT
TERMINATION DECISION BECAUSE
EVERYONE'S LOOKING THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT MY GOSH. AND I'M
GONNA GO SO FAR AS YOU YOU LIKE
IN A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT YOU SEE
IN THE.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WORLD EVEN WHEN
WE SEE SOMEONE COMMIT A CRIME
IT'S ON VIDEO BUBBA BLAH WE
STILL HAVE A PROCESS BY WHICH WE
DETERMINE WHETHER WHAT IF THAT
PERSON WAS WHAT WE REALLY SAW
WHAT WE SAW. AND WHAT ARE THE
MITIGATING FOR.
CIRCUMSTANCES IMPACTORS AND
THEN WE MAKE THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
OF OF BOB.
PUNISHMENT OR DISCIPLINE.
YOU HAVE I THINK THAT IS A
PERFECT WAY FOR SAID THINK ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND OTHER
FORMS WORKPLACE HARASSMENT BUT
THIS NOTION THAT WE NEED TO
LEARN ONE DAY AND WITHIN A DATA
TO OUR WEEK. SORT IT AND MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT SOMEONE'S LIFE TO
PUT IT TAKES TIME TO PROPERLY
FOR EXAMPLE INTERVIEW WITNESSES.
IT TAKES TIME TO PROPERLY VET
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER SEPARATE
FACT FROM FICTION.
AND YOU KNOW AS A PRACTICING
LAWYER WHO DID SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND OTHER FORMS OF HARASSMENT
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS FOR YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MAGIC
PERIOD AS ITS SHOULDN'T TAKE TWO
YEARS TO DO IT BUT I AM
ABSOLUTELY CONVINCED THAT IS NOT
A WEEK EITHER.
WOULD YOU SAY THAT PART OF THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THE RELATIONSHIP.
TWEEN A SUPERVISOR. ASSUMING
THAT IT'S AN EMPLOYEE.
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A
SUPERVISOR IN THE EMPLOYEE THE
EMPLOYEE HAS NOW WHEN THAT'S NOT
A GOOD EXAMPLE. LET'S GO TO
LEGISLATORS.
LET'S GO TO SECTOR WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YES IF IF YOU HAVE
A LEGISLATOR WHO HAS.
BEEN ACCUSED.
IF THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATOR AND THAT LEGISLATORS
SUPERVISOR.
IS A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH A
SUPERVISOR SAYS WE HEAR THE
SPEAKER.
THIS IS A SITUATION
I THINK THIS IS WHERE YOU SHOULD
GO WHETHER IT'S TOO TO RESIGN OR
WHATEVER IS THAT RELATIONSHIP.
IMPORTANT IN THIS SORT OF A.
YEAH SHE WAS SO IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY FOUNDED IN TRUST.
AND AND THE ORG AND WE TALKED
EARLIER ABOUT SOME OF THE
DISTINCTION I THINK YOU HAVE TWO
OPTIONS HERE ONE OF WHICH IS NOT
RELAPSE AND ONE IS EXPULSION AND
ONE A SUSPENSION.
I THINK AS A PRACTICAL MATTER
YOU ALL CAN BOAT TO SEE
SPEND DON'T ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES WHO YOU COLLECTIVELY
DETERMINE. HAS ENGAGED IN THE
QUESTIONABLE BEHAVIOR AND
POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR UP
TO AND INCLUDING SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SO YOU CAN SUSPEND THEM I DON'T
KNOW OVER TIME I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE HISTORY IS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
IF YOU'VE EVER USED THE
EXPULSION.
OPTION
AND THAT AGAIN IS WHEN YOU GO
BACK TWO PEOPLE JUDGING YOU BY
WHAT YOU DO AND NOT WHAT YOU
SAY.
I THINK SUSPENSION IS
INTERESTING TEMPORARILY AND I
KNOW THERE ARE TONS OF HURDLES
AND I DIDN'T MEAN TO MISS
CHARACTERIZE YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT.
IT'S JUST THAT. IF YOU HAVE
EXPOSURE AS AN OPTION.
AND YOU'VE NEVER USED IT.
THEN IS IT REALLY AN OPTION
AND OUR PEOPLE TO BELIEVE THAT
YOU'RE SERIOUS ABOUT IT IF
YOU'VE NEVER USED IT. IT'S THE
SAME IT'S A THAT'S THE POINT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT YES
YOU'RE DIFFERENT THAN IF I WERE
EVERY COMPANY HAVE GONE TO WORK
WITH THE MY LIFE IS SAYS WE'RE
UNIQUE.
EVERYTHING SHOOTING. YOU KNOW
THERE ARE NO TWO ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE THE SAME
BUT IF WE SAY ZERO TOLERANCE.
THEN WE CAN START PUTTING AND
DIFFERENTIATED SORT OF STANDARDS
IF SOMEONE ENGAGES IN BEHAVIOR
THAT BRINGS HARM TO PEOPLE THEN
YOUR HR FUNCTION U. S. LEADERS
HAVE TO TAKE ACTION.
APPROPRIATELY SWIFT.
MY LOOK COULD I JUST ADD TO THEM
IN IN TALKING ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
YOU DON'T WANNA JUST SHINE THE
LIGHT. ON.
COMPLAINTS INVESTIGATIONS
YOU ALSO WANT TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
AND SO YOU WANT THE CONVERSATION
NOT JUST TO BE ABOUT. WHAT HAS
GONE WRONG BUT HIGHLIGHTING
EXAMPLES WHERE PEOPLE CAN BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING THE
RIGHT THING?
AND.
THAT WAY IT ITS ITS THAT'S MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
CHANGING PEOPLE'S BEHAVIOR. THAN
TALKING ABOUT WELL THERE WAS
THIS INVESTIGATION THAT THE
RUMOR MILL STARTS YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED WAS ENOUGH DONE. I'M TO
ALSO TALK ABOUT WHAT WENT RIGHT.
IN MY LAST QUESTION MADAM CHAIR.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
REPORTING.
TALKING ABOUT THE LIFE OF A
VICTIM.
AT WHAT POINT DO WE ALLOW THE
TO DIRECT REPORTING.
FOR THAT VICTIM TO BE THE ONE
WHO DECIDES WHAT IS REPORTED
WHEN IT IS REPORTED AND THE
DETAILS OF THAT REPORT TO
PROTECT.
HER AND I RECOGNIZE THAT MEN
SOMETIMES OF THE VICTIMS BUT I
THINK STATISTICS ARE CLEAR THAT
WE HAVE OVER EIGHTY PERCENT.
SOME STATISTICS STATISTICS TAKE
US UP TO NINETY PERCENT.
OF THE VICTIMS ARE WOMEN AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE WOMEN
VICTIMS SO HOW IS IT THAT WE
PROTECT THE VICTIMS AND ALLOW
THAT VICTIM. TO BE THE ONE TO
DIRECT REPORTING OF THE CRIME OR
THE HARASSMENT AGAINST.
HER OR HIM.
WIPING THAT'S WHY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT HAVE SORT OF A
CONFIDENTIAL SPACE WHERE THEY
CAN GO TO GET INFORMATION AND
MAKE CHOICES ON AT A CERTAIN
POINT. YOU KNOW.
.
IT'S HARD BECAUSE THEY.
IF THE INSTITUTION KNOWS.
WE COULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR NOT DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT
RIGHT SO YOU YOU CAN'T HAVE A
VICTIM COME IN. YOU YOU YOU
CAN'T GATHER.
IN OVER TEN REPORTS AGAINST A
CERTAIN PERSON AND THEN SAY WELL
I'M STILL JUST GONNA LET EACH
VICTIM DECIDE.
HOW THIS GOES BECAUSE AT A
CERTAIN POINT THE INSTITUTION
HAS TO SAY NO? WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING BUT FOR THE MOST PART
I THINK YOU DO WANT TO TRY AND.
RESPECT THAT VICTIMS ON WISHES.
CERTAINLY WHILE BALANCING SAFETY
SO I THINK.
IF SOMEONE KNOWS THAT IF THEY
DID COME FORWARD IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO THE
NUCLEAR REACTION.
THAT THERE COULD BE SMALLER
THINGS IF IT'S IF VOTE IF
SOMEONE COME FORUMS LIKE THIS IS
MAKING ME UNCOMFORTABLE. I DON'T
WANT A FULL.
A FULL BLOWN INVESTIGATION
FINING I'D LIKE MY CUBICLE
MOVED.
WE TRY TO DO THAT.
AND THEN THINK ABOUT WHAT IF
ANYTHING ELSE WE CAN AND SHOULD
DO WHILE RESPECTING THAT
PERSON'S WISHES.
YOU
THANK YOU BEFORE I GO TO MISTER
DALLI I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT WHICH IS THAT OF
EXPULSION HASN'T BEEN USED.
THE OP THE OTHER OPTION IS NOT
THAT IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
SERIOUS IT'S ALSO MAYBE IT'S
JUST NOT THE RIGHT TOOL.
YOU KNOW SO AND WE NEED TO BE
OPEN TO THAT AS WELL.
IT MAY BE THAT IT MAY NEVER BE
USED BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT THE
RIGHT INSTRUMENT. A MISTER DALI.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIR.
SO YOU KNOW WE ARE.
.
A STATE OF LAWS AND WE HAVE LAWS
THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW
AND WE ARE LAWMAKERS.
AND AT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
FIND.
INTERESTING ABOUT NOT COMING TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
AFTER SERVING IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR A LONG TIME IT
HAPPENED TO DEAL WITH THE LAWS
THAT.
THAT THIS.
THESE BODIES PASS.
.
I CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
WHEN I CAME AS AS A LEGISLATOR.
I HIRED MY STAFF AND AND I HAVE.
MY DISTRICT OFFICES AND SO I HAD
AN EMPLOYEE.
WHO I WAS TRYING TO?
EDUCATE ON HOW I WANTED. THINGS
DONE AND I'M SO ANYWAY IT DIDN'T
WORK OUT OUR OUR RELATIONSHIP
DIDN'T WORK OUT I I'M A I'M A
GOOD PLAYER.
FOR MY BOOK HOME VISIT I'M A
FARMER I HAVE EMPLOYEES TO SO I
HAVE TO ABIDE BY. THE LABOR LAWS
THAT DID.
ARE THE LAWS OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THERE ARE YOUKNOW WORKERS HAVE
TONS OF RIGHTS AND THERE'S LOTS
OF REASONS FOR ALL THESE LAWS
AND AND I UNDERSTAND ALL THAT.
A BUT WHEN I CAME THE
LEGISLATURE.
AFTER COME A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AYE AYE AYE. DID ALL THE SAME
THINGS I DID AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHICH WAS.
I YOU KNOW. ENCOURAGE THE PERSON
GAVE HIM IN WRITING ALL THESE
THINGS THAT I NEEDED TO DO TO.
TRY TO IMPROVE THE THE ABILITY
FOR THEM TO WORK AND IT DIDN'T
WORK OUT SO LET HAD LET THAT
PERSON GO SIGHT I TURNED INTO.
THE PAPERWORK TO OUR.
.
THE RULES COMMITTEE AND SAID I'M
NOT LET THIS PERSON'S GOING TO
SETTLE MISTER AL YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T.
IT'S DIFFERENT HERE AT THE STATE
LEVEL YOU DON'T YOU DON'T HAVE.
TO BUILD A CASE YOU THEIR OUT
WILL EMPLOYEES.
AND SOMETHING I FOUND VERY
FRUSTRATING AS A. PERSON HAS TO
ABIDE BY THE LAWS LAS IN
EMPLOYMENT AND MY HOME BUSINESS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT LEGISLATURE
HAS EXEMPTED THEMSELVES FROM THE
LAWS THEY PASS.
SO LET ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE WE ARE
ABLE TO WORK. A TWENTY HOUR DAY
HERE WITHOUT GIVING R. PLAYS A
BREAK.
NOW I'M NOT ABLE TO DO THAT AT
HOME BECAUSE I'M IN VIOLATION OF
LABOR LAWS.
THAT WE PASS AND SO.
YOU KNOW I OFTEN SAY TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT IF YOU HAD TO
LIVE BY THE LAWS YOU PASS YOU
WOULDN'T PASS SOME OF THOSE LAWS
BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY DIFFICULT
TO LIVE BY.
BUT WE'VE EXEMPTED OURSELVES
AND SO WE'RE WE HAVE A CULTURE
HERE THAT SAYS WE ARE ABOVE THE
LAW BECAUSE WE DON'T EVEN ABIDE
BY THE OWN LAWS THAT WE PASS.
AND WE DON'T CHEAT OUR EMPLOYEES
THE SAME AS I HAVE TO TREAT MY
EMPLOYEES AT HOME.
.
AND I THINK GOT CULTURE AS WE
TALK ABOUT THIS CULTURE THERE'S
A CULTURE THAT WERE BETTER THAN
EVEN OUR OWN LAWS THAT WE HAVE
TO ABIDE BY OUR LAWS AND IN THAT
SETS IT.
THE PARADIGM AND IN PLACE SO YOU
KNOW FOR GOING FORWARD.
WE ARE EVERYTHING I'VE BEEN HER
THIS.
THE BODY IS GRAPPLING WITH WHAT
IS THE CULTURE OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY AGAIN IT LOOKS
LIKE IN THE FUTURE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
IN YOUR OPINION DO YOU THINK
THAT WE SHOULD ABIDE BY THE LAWS
THAT WE PASS.
SO THAT THERE'S A BASE.
FOR.
THE EMPLOYEE TO KNOW THAT HEY I
AT LEAST I HAVE THESE LAWS ON MY
SIDE TO START WITH.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IF YOU WORK
FOR THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
WE HAVE EXEMPT OURSELVES IN THE
LOS THE LABOR LAWS THAT WE'VE
PAST IS STATE.
YOU DON'T ALWAYS HAVE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS IF YOU DON'T.
BOB ABOUT THE STATE'S OPTIC
ASIDE AND. NO I I I I DO THINK
THAT AS I'VE SAID A COUPLE OF
TIMES I THINK.
.
PEOPLE JUDGE ABOUT WHAT YOU DO
AND NOT NECESSARILY WHAT YOU SAY
AND THAT IS THE STANDARD AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A DISCONNECT.
IT WITH IS THAT YOU HAVE THIS
LAW THAT APPLIES HERE NOT ENOUGH
THIS BUT TO BE FAIR THERE ARE
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
DIFFERENT. YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
RULES FOR DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES SO FRANKLY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WHAT I WOULD DO. IS
TO THE EXTENT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE IF THERE IS A
LEGITIMATE REASON FOR TREATING
FOR EXEMPTING YOU FROM A
PARTICULAR LAW THEN YOU SHOULD
GO TO GREAT LENGTHS.
EXPLAIN WHY BECAUSE IF THERE IS
IF IT'S PURELY BECAUSE WE DO
THINK
WE ARE ABOVE THE LAW THEN THAT'S
A PROBLEM YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT AND IT BLEEDS INTO
EVERYTHING ELSE AND THAT'S WHY.
YOU WILL HAVE SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT YOU HAVE IN
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT GENERALLY
BUT IF THERE IS A REALLY
COMPELLING REASON FOR WHY THERE
ARE REASONS WHY YOUR RULES THAT
AND THEN OTHER RULES. THAT YOU
JUST EXPLAINED IT AND THAT'S
PART OF THE CULTURE IS
EXPLAINING IT TO PEOPLE SO THEY
BUY INTO.
SO BEFORE I GO TO SENATOR BATES
SIDE.
IT MADE ME THINK OF A QUESTION
THIS IS A. DIFFICULT QUESTION
BECAUSE IS TO COME OUT OF LEFT
FIELD.
.
SO SOME PEOPLE HAVE SUGGESTED
THAT THE SOLUTION TO THIS IS TO
ALLOW THE EMPLOYEES. THAT WORK
OUT OF MORE OF OUR WORKFORCE TO
UNIONIZE AND I'M WONDERING IF
YOU'VE EXAMINED CULTURES THAT.
FUNCTION UNDER. AND ONCE I DON'T
AND IF YOU THINK THAT THAT AND
THIS IS REALLY AN UNFAIR
QUESTION YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER BUT IF YOU IF YOU'VE SEEN
THOSE KINDS OF OF DIFFERENCES.
BASED ON THOSE THOSE KINDS OF
STRUCTURES.
NOT NOT REALLY A ONE OF THE
LARGEST.
IF IF YOU RECALL.
CLASS ACTIONS AT THE TIME WAS
THE MITSUBISHI MITSUBISHI MOTOR
SALES OF AMERICA CASE THE BIG
CLASS ACTION WERE WOMEN.
WERE UNDERPAID.
DE SYSTEMATICALLY AND NOT
PROMOTED EXETER AND THEY HAVE A
UNIONIZED ENVIRONMENT
SO I THINK I'M I DON'T KNOW THAT
UNIONS WILL SOLVE THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES SPEAK TO
WHAT IS THE CULTURE. IN IN THIS
ORGANIZATION SO SOUNDS LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD BUT THAT THAT
DOESN'T SOLVE FOR IN PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE ME THEIR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT A UNIONIZED
ENVIRONMENT TYPE SCENIC QUITE A
BIT.
RIGHT.
OKAY THERE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE MOVE TO THE NEXT.
SPEAKER.
OKAY AND ACTUALLY MISTER TAYLOR
I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO STAY IF YOU
DON'T MIND BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT WORKING WITH
OUTSIDE GROUPS IN YOUR REPRESENT
AN OUTSIDE GROUP SO YOU MIGHT AS
WELL TO SET UP THEIR CASE IS
MORE QUESTIONS.
I AND AND THANK YOU OTHER
PANELISTS IS WAS REALLY
FASCINATING AND EXTREMELY
HELPFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I'LL ASK OUR MISTER GRIFFIN
FROM THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF
STATE LEGISLATORS TO COME UP AND
PRESENT.
THIS PANEL IS ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD WITH PARTNERS.
SO I'M GONNA JUST ASK.
MISTER TAYLOR TO STAY IN CASE
SINCE THEY ARE THE COULD BE
PARTNERS OF US IN CASE ANYBODY
HAS QUESTIONS BASED ON THE
TESTIMONY WE HEAR THANK YOU.
BERRYHILL AMOUNT THEIR WAY UP.
UP SO MY NAME IS JONATHAN
GRIFFIN I WORK FOR AND CECIL
CENTER FOR LEGISLATIVE
STRENGTHENING. I'M BENNETT NCSL
FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AND PRIOR
TO THAT I WORK IN THE FLORIDA
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES THAT
LIKE TO THINK.
CHAIRMAN FREEMAN SHARON
MITCHELL FOR HAVING ME AND ALL
THE REST THE MEMBERS OF A OF THE
COMMITTEES WELL.
ICED WHAT TO SAY BECOMING ON
LATE THOUGH SUCH A FASCINATING
DISCUSSION A SOMEONE WHO CARES
VERY MUCH ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
INSTITUTION THAT'S KIND OF OUR
GOAL WITHIN NCSL. UP IT'S GREAT
TO SEE SO MANY PEOPLE COMMITTED
TO IMPROVING THE LEGISLATIVE
INSTITUTION.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE'VE BEEN AT
THIS FOR AWHILE I WANT TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF ERRANDS TIME.
IT PROVIDES A BRIEF.
.
REVIEW OF WHAT WE'VE DONE AND
WHAT WE'RE PLANNING AND DOING
GOING FORTH AND OPEN UP THE. THE
GROUP TED OR OPEN UP A
CONVERSATION EVERYONE.
SO. NC SO BEGIN UPDATING OUR
RESEARCH IS OUR RESOURCES
REGARDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
POLICIES IN TRAINING AND AND
JUST WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE IN
EARLY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
REPRODUCED A TWO PAGE LARGEST
BRIEF THAT THINK YOU HAVE IN THE
BACK OF YOUR PACKET ON THE TOPIC
IN JULY. AND THEN IN OCTOBER OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
WE HELD A SEMINAR HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT WITH THE.
CRATE FULL PARTICIPATION OF OF
SHERMAN SPONSORSHIP.
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE OCTOBER
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING
POLICIES WERE HOT TOPICS
THROUGHOUT THE MEETING.
AS RESPONSES INTEREST WE SENT A
SURVEY ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
POLICIES AND TRAINING TO
LEGISLATIVE HR PROFESSIONALS IN
ALL FIFTY STATES.
WE RECEIVED RESPONSES FROM
TWENTY FIVE STATE LEGISLATURES
AND AN ADDITIONAL ELEVEN
LEGISLATIVE CHAMBERS INCLUDING
ROUGHLY THIRTY EXAMPLES OF
LEGISLATIVE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
POLICIES.
USING THOSE RESPONSES ALONG
WITH CONSTIPATION FOR EXPERTS IN
THE AREA WE WERE ABLE TO CREATE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT A
WHAT ABOUT WHAT A GOOD SEXUAL
HARASSMENT POLICY SHOULD HAVE A
WHAT GOOD TRAINING SHOULD
ENTAIL.
I'M NOT SURE I SEN IN.
ACCOUNT A MEMO LATE LAST NIGHT
NOT SURE IF IT MADE IT TO
EVERYBODY.
BUT I CAN KIND OF GO OVER THE
THE BROAD STROKES OF IT.
THAT'S WE TALKED ABOUT AT
LENGTH ARE TODAY THERE'S NO.
SILVER BULLET APPROACH TO TO
PICK TO SOLVING THIS PROBLEM IS
NO PANACEA.
POLICIES ARE JUST ONE PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION STRATEGY AS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY THE CULTURE OF THE
LEGISLATURE ALONG WITH HIGH
QUALITY AND THOUGHTFUL TRAINING
ARE EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT.
BUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICIES
TO PROVIDE TV HUGE BENEFITS TO
AN ORGANIZATION FIRST THEY SHOW
THE EMPLOYEES THAT THEIR
LEADERSHIP TAKES THE MATTER
SERIOUSLY AND A PUT THOUGHT INTO
CURBING THE BEHAVIOR. BY
CRAFTING A POLICY THAT SERVES
THEIR EMPLOYEES NEEDS OF THE
THIRTY POLICIES YOU RECEIVE EACH
ONE WAS UNIQUELY CRAFTED TO FIT
THEIR LEGISLATIVE ENVIRONMENT.
THERE'S NO COOKIE CUTTER OR
UNIFORM POLICY THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE THIRTY SECONDLY
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
WE'RE SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICIES
REALLY US SENATE TONE IS THEY
PROVIDE A CLEAR PATH FOR A
PERSON WHO BELIEVES THEY HAVE
SUFFERED HARASSMENT TO MAKE
THEIR CLAIM.
CLEARLY THE PROCESS IS
PARAMOUNT HERE GOOD POLICY
SHOULD IMPROVE SHOULD PROVIDE
EXAMPLES OF INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT.
IT SHOULD INCLUDE MULTIPLE
CONTACTS FOR HARASSMENT VICTIM
JUST REPORT ACCLAIM INCLUDING
MAKING SURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THE E. OC IN THE STATE'S
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION. CAN
ALSO RECEIVE THOSE CLAIMS THAT
THEY FEEL LIKE LEADERSHIP THEY
DON'T HAVE A VOICE.
IT SHOULD PROVIDE AN
EXPLANATION OF THE INVESTIGATION
PROCESS ARE GOING INTO IT THEY
HAVE EXPECTATIONS ABOUT THE
BREVITY IN THE CONFIDENTIALITY
AND AND HOW LONG THE PROCESS
SHOULD TAKE.
AND SHOULD OUTLINED POTENTIAL
DISCIPLINE FOR THE ACCUSED.
OFTEN WE HEAR THAT PEOPLE DON'T
MAKE COMPLAINTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
AFRAID OF SOMEONE LOSING THEIR
JOB IN THE ALTERNATIVE YOU WILL
HEAR PEOPLE WHO ARE UPSET BY
MAKING COMPLAINED THAT IT DIDN'T
RESULT IN THAT MAKING CLEAR THAT
THERE ARE NUMBER. OF POSSIBLE
OUTCOMES.
HELPS ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
REPORT MORE.
BOB IT ALSO NEEDS TO PROVIDE A
CLEAR STATEMENT PROHIBITING
RETALIATION.
AS FAR AS TRAINING GOES.
ONE THING AGAIN THEY DIFFERED
GREATLY IN IN QUALITY BUT ALMOST
ALL STATES RESPONDED THAT AT
MINIMUM TRAINING WITH AND YOU ON
MANDATORY.
BUT AFTER CONSULTING WITH NC
SALES TRAINERS AND EXPERTS ARE
REVIEWING OUR SURVEYS WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING RECOMMENDATIONS AS
WELL.
MOST IMPORTANT ALL AGAIN.
IS THAT MUCH LIKE CHANGING THE
CULTURE LEGISLATURE TRAINING IS
THAT'S MOST EFFECTIVE WHEN THE
LEADERSHIP IS FULLY ENGAGED AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TRAINING IT
SENDS A MESSAGE TO EVERYONE ELSE
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
DONE IN THAT THERE. ARE ON BOARD
NO A RECEPTIVE MEMBER OF OF THE
COMMUNITY.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TRAINERS IN
CORPORATE LEGISLATIVE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES AT AS ALL OF YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE NOT A LEGISLATOR FROM
EIGHT AM TO FIVE PM YOUR
LEGISLATOR MIDNIGHT YOUR
LEGISLATOR AT TEN PM YOU'RE
ALWAYS.
REPRESENTING YOURSELF AND SO
THAT THAT IMPROVE THAT
INTERACTION WITH THE PUBLIC THAT
INTERACTIONS IN THE EVENING.
DOES SHOW ALSO NEED BE ACCOUNTED
FOR PEOPLE NEED TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WORKS OUT TO
THAT NOTE IT'S ALSO SOMETIMES
IMPORTANT TO SEPARATE STAFF AND
LEGISLATORS FROM TRAINING
BECAUSE THE UNIQUE. POWER
DYNAMICS AND THE UNIQUENESS OF
THE JOBS.
SO THAT WAS WE CAME ACROSS IN
OCTOBER.
IT WON'T SHOCK YOU TO HEAR THE
MOST THESE POLICIES ALREADY
OUTDATED BY THE TIME TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CAME AROUND.
SO FAR WERE A REBEL LEVIN
STATES THAT IMPLEMENTED OR
INTRODUCE NEW POLICIES.
CHAMBER RULES ARE ETHICS RULES
AND I EXPECT. MOSTLY ALL IF NOT
ALL STATES TO BE REVIEWING THE
POLICIES AS SESSIONS KEEP ON
COMING IN.
MOST THE CHANGES OF THESE
ACTUALLY ARE MINOR SO FAR.
THEY USUALLY JUST CLARIFY
PROCEDURES ALREADY IN PLACE OF
FOR EXAMPLE THE MEXICO CHANGE TO
GENERAL REPORTING. OF LANGUAGE
TO HAVE SPECIFIC PAUL. REPORTING
FOR IF IT'S A STAFF MEMBER WHO'S
FEELING HARASSED THE LEGISLATOR
EVEN A THIRD PARTY LIKE A
LOBBYIST.
IN ADDITION TO THOSE POLICIES
WERE ACTUALLY SEEING
UNPRECEDENTED OUT OF LEGISLATION
AS WELL ABOUT TYPICALLY THERE
WOULD BE HARDLY ANY LEGISLATION
IS A SAMPLE TO POLICIES
INTERNAL.
UP PROCEDURES.
THIS YEAR WE'RE SEEING BILLS
THAT INTRODUCED TASK FORCES OR
COMMISSIONS ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
A BILL TO CREATE ANONYMOUS TIP
CLIENTS TO REPORT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. AND BILLS LIKE THE
WINDOWS INTRODUCED HERE THAT
REQUIRE LEGISLATORS TO REIMBURSE
THE STATE WHEN PUBLIC FUNDS ARE
USE TO SETTLE COMPLAINTS A NEW
YORK EVEN INTRODUCE LEGISLATION
TO CREATE A CRIME OF OFFICIAL
MISCONDUCT FOR STATE
LEGISLATORS.
SUCH REALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING.
RIGHT NOW AS IT WAS SAID BEFORE
AND ON FEBRUARY NINTH WE WILL BE
CONDUCTING A WEAPON ARE ON THE
TOPIC.
WE ARE ALSO CURRENTLY
COORDINATING TRAINING THAT WILL
TAKEN PART THE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAVE AND
TRY TO BETTER SERVE OUR
MEMBERSHIP THROUGH TRAINING.
.
I REALLY DISPLACEMENT OPENING UP
EVERYONE ELSE ABOUT GOING
FORWARD AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
BETTER SERVE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD IN
THIS. TOPIC.
Q. MISDEEDS I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
HAVE A CHANCE
TO ASK YOU IF YOU HAD A
QUESTION.
IN THE LAST.
YEAH.
YEAH WE WE WEEK ALONG LISTS FOR
RIGHT FROM THE GET GO PUBLIC
JEOPARDY WHERE PEOPLE ARE
PUSHING HER BY.
WELL MY AT MY WILL BE VERY CLEAR
BECAUSE IT'S A KIND OF AN
INTERESTING SITUATION THAT WE
WITH JOHN AND WE HAD A NUMBER OF
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS RUN. OUR
COMMUNITY REGARDING TREATMENT BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO RATHER THAN ELEVATE THOSE TO
A POLICE COMMISSION ALL ABOUT WE
WERE SEEKING OTHER WAYS TO BRING
RECONCILIATION.
TO THE SITUATION.
AND CREATED A POLICE COMMUNITY
RECONCILIATION PROGRAM.
AND WHICH THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
FELT THEY'D BEEN HARASSED IN
THESE
YOU KNOW APPROACH THINGS THAT
YOU KNOW WOULD BE DEBT VERY
DETRIMENTAL TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS CAREER.
THEY VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATED
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE DEAD.
SO THE QUESTION IS IS THERE A
PLACE IN IN THE.
TOOLS THAT WE WILL HAVE AS WE
GO FORWARD.
THAT A RECONCILIATION PROCESS
CAN WORK WHEN YOU HAVE THIS
POWER BASE
BECAUSE THE WOULD BE HARD FOR.
CA I AM A.
STAFFORD TO A LEGISLATOR AND I
FEEL I'VE BEEN HARASSED.
SEXUALLY OR ANY OTHER WAY.
DO YOU AYE AYE REPORT IT AND
THEN I HAVE TO ASK IF THAT
INDIVIDUAL SIT DOWN WITH ME AND
WE CAN WORK THROUGH OUR PROBLEMS
AND THAT REALLY. I JUST THE
POWER RELATIONSHIP
THAT IT WORKED.
WHICH LAW ENFORCEMENT SO CAN'T
WORK HERE AND HAVE YOU EVER USE
THAT.
UNOFFICIALLYAND AND IN SOME
CASES OFFICIALLY THAT'S BEEN THE
ROLE OF HR.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU ENVISION SO ONCE YOU GET TO
THE EEOC OR A THIRD PARTY YOU'RE
NOW IN FULL DISPUTE MODE BUT
IDEALLY WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN IF
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT HR FUNCTION
IS.
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN BATES ASSEMBLY
OR SENATOR
THEN SENATOR BATES ONE OFFICIAL
CAN ARE ITEMS ARE BUT SENATOR
BATES IS.
LIVES DIRECTOR COMES IN AND
SAYS I FEEL LIKE I'M BEING
HARASSED IN THE WORKPLACE.
AND BRINGS THAT TO AN HR
FUNCTION
THAT IS CAPABLE AND COMPETENT
AND ALL THAT GOOD STUFF IDEALLY
BECAUSE SOMETIMES.
THAT PERSON'S DEFINITION OF
HARASSMENT MAY BE YOU KNOW THE
LAY PERSON'S DEFINITION OF
HARASSMENT IS NOT ALWAYS LEGAL
HARASSED.
THAT I WAS WITH. THE SENATOR ON
A TRIP.
AND SHE NEEDED X. THAT MORNING
SHE ASKED ME TO GO OUT AND GET
IT.
AND I FELT HARASSED BY.
IN SO WE OFTENTIMES BY NATURE
FUNCTION PUTTING THE TWO PARTIES
IN THE ROOM WILL REALIZE THAT IS
EITHER MISC UNDERSEA IT'S
MISCOMMUNICATION
MISUNDERSTANDING MULTI
GENERATIONAL CONVERSATIONS
BECAUSE THE WAY THAT WE TALK IS
NOT THE WAY A TWENTY ONE YEAR
OLD OX. AND SO A LOT OF THAT IS
AT PLAY THERE SOME REAL POWER
DYNAMICS THERE WE HAVE FOUND
THAT HR CAN ACTUALLY SERVE IN
THAT OFFICIAL RECONCILIATION
ROLE AND IF WE WORK WELL THROUGH
THIS WE KEEP BOTH TALENT.
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T IT'S NOT AN
EITHER OR THAT'S THE PROBLEM
WHEN YOU GET INTO THE TREE IN
THE REAL ADVERSARIAL KIND OF
SOMEONE HAS TO WIN AND SOMEONE
HAS TO LOSE AND GOD FOR BID
YOU'VE GOT NO LAWYER INVOLVED.
AS WELL HAD BECAUSE THEY DON'T
MAKE MONEY IF YOU TO JUST
RECORD.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE ANGLE THE
ANGLE IS YOU NEED TO LOSE SO
THAT I CAN GET MY THIRD OR
WHATEVER I KNOW CALIFORNIA. HAS
DIFFERENT WHO YOU KNOW A
CONTINGENCY RULES BUT THEREIN
LIES THE PROBLEM IS ONCE IT'S
GONE EXTERNAL AN ADVERSARIAL
YOU'VE A REAL YOUR ABILITY TO
MANAGE IT NOT CONTROLLING
BECAUSE WE'RE CONTROL SUGGEST
THAT YOU TRY TO HIDE IT.
IT'S NOT IT'S JUST SOMETIMES THE
PARTIES HAVE MISSED EACH OTHER
IN PASSING AND THERE'S A PROBLEM
THERE AND WHEN YOU DEAL WITH
THAT YOU COULD SAY PUT TALENTS
ALONG ITS I'VE SEEN THAT WORK WE
DON'T CALL IT RECONCILIATION
PROGRAMS BECAUSE YOU. TITLE
SEVEN OF THE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
AND SOMETIMES THE SEA SAYS YOU
CAN'T WORK AROUND OUR PROCESS
BUT I THINK THE OPPORTUNITY AND
WE'VE SEEN IT WORK IS A STRONG
HR FUNCTION WILL GENERALLY GET
YOU TO THAT PRETTY QUICKLY.
AND I JUST LIKE TO ADD UP THE
STATE OR IN ACTUALLY IN THEIR
LEGISLATURE IS A VERY STRONG
INFORMAL COMPLAINT PROCESS. AND
AGAIN I THINK THIS THIS LEADS TO
THERE'S YOU KNOW KIND OF A
GENERAL IDEA THAT MOST THE TIME
WHEN YOU MAKE A COMPLAINT.
YOU'RE NOT ASKING FOR RESULT IS
WHAT BEHAVIORS STOP.
AND AS LONG AS YOU HAVE AN HR
FONG AT AGE OUR COMMUNITY THAT
FEELS EMPOWERED TO DO SO THAT
SHOULD ALWAYS BE AN OPTION.
AND THERE ARE SOME STATES THAT
ACTUALLY PUT THAT INTO THEIR
POLICY TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE AWARE AGAIN THAT.
THERE'S NOT IN THIS DOZEN
DICTATORS ALL THERE'S THERE'S A
LOT OF WAYS TO HANDLE COMPLY.
CAN I JUST RAISE IT BECAUSE LIKE
INCOME THE DUE PROCESS AND
ACCUSED.
SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
HA IF THEY THROW MY GOD I DIDN'T
MEAN TO DO THAT I DO NOT KNOW
HOW TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S
QUITE. YOU KNOW IN TERMS THE
CONSEQUENCES A LOT LESS THIS
COMPARED TO MOVING UP THE LADDER
DO SOMETHING THAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
KNOW THAT TOUGH CANNED GOODS
BECAUSE I I THINK I'D LIKE TO.
SO US TO EXPLORE THAT AS WE'RE
STARTING TO PUT TOGETHER OUR
STRUCTURE.
MISTER GRIFFIN HOW CAN NCSL HELP
US AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
PROCESS.
NUMBER REALLY IN ANY WAY YOU ASK
US TO.
WHERE YOUR ORGANIZATION AND WE
TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY ON AS
FAR AS THAT'S COMING TO PROVIDE
FURTHER TESTIMONY IS THAT'S FAR
AS?
GIVING IT DOING TRAINING.
REGARDING THE TOPIC.
.
RELIEF IF YOU ASK FOR IT WE WILL
PROBABLY FIND A WAY TO DO IT.
THAT'S DISCOUNTED GENERALLY OUR
MOTTO THROUGHOUT.
ANYTHING IN THIS IS A TOPIC
THAT WE TAKE EXTRAORDINARILY
SERIOUSLY AND AS AS WE GOTTA
TALK EARLIER THIS IS NOT A
CALIFORNIA ONLY PROBLEM I MEAN
WE ARE WE ARE COMING UP WITH
STUFF. THROUGHOUT THE BOARD
BECAUSE THIS IS AFFECTING SO
MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
Q. AND.
MISTER GRIFFIN MENTIONED
LEGISLATION SIMILAR THAT TO WHAT
WAS INTRODUCED HERE HAVING
LEGISLATORS HAVING TO PAY.
SETTLEMENT
I'M WONDERING MISTER TAYLOR
SOMEONE WITH A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
IN THIS.
IN THIS FIELD WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT COULD
BE.
WELL THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
IT IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR GOOD
BY COMPARISON WE WE ALL WORK AND
WE HAVE DO YOU KNOW POLICY
WRITER DIRECTORS AND OFFICES
LIABILITY POLICY AND SO. EVEN IF
YOU FOUND HAVE DONE IT
TYPICALLY.
IT'S IT'S NOT AT PERSONAL RISK
TO YOU.
I'VE I'VE WHILE I APPRECIATE AND
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY'RE GOING
WITH THAT THERE IS A TON OF RISK
THAT I THINK REALLY GOOD PEOPLE
MIGHT DECIDE NOT TO DO THIS
WORK.
IF THEY THINK THEY'RE GONNA
SUBJECT THE PERSONAL ASSETS
TO EXPOSURE.
AND MAYBE AYE FUNDAMENTALLY
STARTED BELIEVING IN PEOPLE I
BELIEVE THERE ARE FEW BAD ACTORS
BUT I WOULD HATE TO PROPOSE
POLICY OR. FOR POLICIES THAT
WOULD HARM OR HAVE THE IMPACT OF
MAKING THE NINETY FIVE PERCENT
OF US WHO WILL FOLLOW THE RULES
SAY YOU KNOW IT'S JUST NOT WORTH
IT I DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO.
MORTGAGE MY HOUSE WOULD GIVE UP
MY EXPORT THIS RISK. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I SAW IN
PRACTICE.
WHICH YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S REALLY
TOUGH TO A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SETTLED SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIMS.
AND I'M TALKING FROM BUSINESS
THE BUSINESS MAKES THE DECISION
TO DO IT.
NOT THE INDIVIDUAL IT'S NOT IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF PARAMOUNT
PICTURES TO BE ALL OVER THE NEW
SO WE SOLVE PER THAT PROBLEM.
AND WE RESOLVE IT EVEN IF ONE OF
OUR EXECUTIVES DECIDED THEY
WANTED TO FIGHT IT FIGHT IT TO
THE END AND THAT'S THE REALITY
AND I THINK YOU WILL BE
CONFRONTED WITH SOMETHING. VERY
SIMILAR TO THAT I THINK ABOUT
THE WOMAN WHO RAN FOR CONGRESS
WAS RUNNING FOR CONGRESS IN
KANSAS OUT OF A BEAUTY IF YOU
FOLLOW IT DEMOCRATIC. CANDIDATE
FOR OUR CONGRESS AND.
SHE HAD BEEN A HEAD OF HR
INTERESTINGLY
TWENTY OR SO YEARS IN THE PAST
AND HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BY A MALE EMPLOYEE.
I SHE NEVER OF AGREED THAT
OCCURRED SHE NEVER ADMITTED TO
IT. THE COMPANY WAS SUBSEQUENTLY
PURCHASED AND MARK SOME SORT OF
MNA THEY SETTLED THE CLAIM
WITHOUT HER.
NOW WOULD BE RIGHT TO THINK COME
BACK AND MAKE HER CHIP IN WITH
THEY MADE THE SETTLEMENT
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT DID HAPPEN
THE DNC PULLED AWAY AT SUPPORT
OF HER AND SHE PULLED OUT OF THE
RACE.
AND THAT WAS AN ALLEGATION THAT
WAS SETTLED BY HER EMPLOYER
SUITS A REALLY COMPLICATED ISSUE
FIRST YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
WILL THE BEST PEOPLE.
PRACTICALLY SUBJECT THAT YOU'RE
A BUSINESS OWNER YOU KNOW YOUR
WIFE WILL LET YOU RUN IF SHE
PICKS MY GOSH SOMEONE ACCUSES
YOU OF SOMETHING RIGHTLY OR
WRONGLY AND NOW YOU'VE EXPOSED
OUR FAMILIES.
BASE OF WEALTH NO JUST IT'S NOT
WORTH IT AND THEN THE OTHER SIDE
IS EVEN WHEN IT DOESHAPPEN IF
IT IF YOU ULTIMATELY CONCLUDE
THAT IT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE STATE THERE TIMES WHEN
YOU CAN TO SETTLE IT. EVEN IF
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN
THE UNDERLYING CLAIM.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE AS A
PRACTITIONER.
CONSTANTLY DEALING IN
REALITY YOU'D BE NICE TO FIGHT
UNTIL THE END BUT SOMETIMES JUST
DOESN'T MAKES.
DID THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
CHAIRMAN YEAH IT SHOWS US I
THINK THE COMPLEXITY OF THESE
ISSUES AND THE NEW WANTS AND
ALSO THE POTENTIAL FOR.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES EVEN
WITH THINGS THAT ON THEIR FACE
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE.
WHICH SEEMS TO HAPPEN A LOT
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING SORT OF WITH
THE LEGAL ROUND.
AND JUST YOU KNOW TRYING TO
ANTICIPATE WHERE THINGS MIGHT
GO.
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR FINAL PANEL
MYSTERIOUS.
MISTER GRIFFIN IN THE TWO PAGE
ARTICLE THAT YOU PROVIDED TO US.
IN BEYOND IT SAID.
TOWARDS THE END
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE FEW
STATES THAT MANDATES SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING BY STATUTE.
YET WE FIND OURSELVES IN A
SITUATION WHEREIN.
UP WOULD YOU AGREE THAT. I'M
SURE YOU HEARD MOST OF THE
PANELISTS BEFORE YOU.
TALKING ABOUT CULTURE.
AND TO THE FACT THAT IT REALLY
IS AN ISSUE OF CULTURE BEFORE IT
IS ANYTHING ELSE.
YES I THINK ABSOLUTELY I THINK
AS.
PROFESSOR DAN HARTZ SAID ABOUT
IN HER PRESENTATION CULTURE EATS
EVERYTHING ELSE UP.
THEIR CULTURES IS THE OVER
ARCHING THAT'S AGAIN WHY I THINK
THIS IS SUCH A POSITIVE FROM
FROM THE TO SONY CARES ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE INSTITUTIONS SUCH A
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE. BECAUSE
SEEING THAT CULTURE IS REALLY.
THE MOST IMPORTANT STEP AND YOU
DON'T LEADERSHIP BY AND THOSE
THINGS ARE REALLY WOULD HELP SET
THE TONE THE MOST MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE YOU CAN COME UP
WITH.
AND ALSO WHAT DISCIPLINE ESSAYS
CALIFORNIA BE ONE OF THE FEW
THAT MANDATES TRAINING IS AGAIN
WHY WE HAD NEVER SEEN
LEGISLATION REALLY ON THIS
BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST ALL TIME.
BOB BENNETT INTERNAL POLICIES.
THANK YOU.
SOMEONE NUMBER WALDRON I'M.
SINCE WE HAVE SOMEONE WHO HAS
DEALT WITH LEGISLATURE'S
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY I THOUGHT
IT WAS APPROPRIATE KIND OF
CIRCLE BACK WITH. WHAT WE
STARTED OFF THE HEARING ABOUT?
TALKING MORE ABOUT DESIGNING
DIVERSE ORGANIZATIONS.
AS OAK POTENTIAL GOAL TO.
STEM YOU KNOW THIS
CONTINUOUS.
.
ENCOURAGING MORE WOMEN TO SERVE
IN CAPACITIES.
.
I THINK IN THE MY I MIGHT BE
OFF.
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE JUST.
BURDEN WHEN THE ISN'T A NEW
LEGISLATIVE AND I THINK THIS
TWENTY SIX OR TWENTY SEVEN
WOMEN.
CURRENTLY SERVING OUT OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY.
LEGISLATIVE POSITIONS
SO IT'S.
AMONG SOLOISTS.
IF FOR A STATE SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT.
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN OR HAVE YOU
SEEN IN OTHER STATES?
ENCOURAGE MORE WOMEN TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
.
I THINK ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
CALIFORNIA IT'S IS SO BIG.
THAT A LOT OF WOMEN. YOU KNOW.
AND THE STRUCTURE IS SO OUT OF
DATE HOW WE DO OUR PROCEDURES
AND OPERATIONS THAT IT
DISCOURAGES WOMEN BECAUSE IT'S
NOT FAMILY FRIENDLY IT'S
INFLEXIBLE. TO A TEE TO SERVE.
THE YOU KNOW IF YOUR MOM IS VERY
DIFFICULT I HAD TOLD MISS MY
SON'S BIRTHDAY YOU KNOW A. YOU
BASICALLY HAVE TO TAKE.
TIME OFF TO THE EVEN STAY IN THE
DISTRICT.
THAT DISCOURAGES WOMEN WHAT HAVE
YOU SEEN IS THERE ANY.
EFFORTS IN OTHER STATES.
TO WORK ON THE MORE DIVERSE MORE
EQUITABLE MORE. FLEXIBLE.
COURSE IF YOU LIVE IN A SMALLER
STATUS EASY TO COME INVOLVEMENT
CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM VERY
DIFFICULT.
YEAH I'M I MEAN I WOULD SAY EVEN
UP BEYOND WOMEN I THINK THERE'S
THERE'S A GENERAL.
DEMAND THAT LEGISLATORS DON'T
MATCH THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
VIRTUALLY ANY STATE IN ANY IN
RELIGION AND IN THE RACE AND
GENDER. UP ACROSS THE BOARD BUT
ULTIMATELY BEYOND ENCOURAGEMENT
I MEAN THE VOTERS ARE ARE WHO
LACKS THE PEOPLE THE PEOPLE LIVE
OUTSIDE OF VERY FEW
CIRCUMSTANCES YOU DON'T GET
SELECTED TO BE A LEGISLATOR YOU
KNOW YOU RUN. AND SO WHILE
THERE'S ENCOURAGEMENT THERE'S
ONLY SO MUCH THAT CAN REALLY
HAPPEN ON THAT SIDE AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY A STATE SPECIFIC I
MEAN THROUGH THE STATE DECIDES
TO CUT BACK IN THE ELECTION.
IF THEY BACK MORE BUT YOU KNOW
IF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ASIDE SETBACK
THE CANDIDATES THAN. YOU SEE
SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY WAS LIKE
SO MUCH THAT THEY CAN REALLY BE
DONE.
OKAY IF THERE'S NO MORE
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW I DO WANT TO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE WHO WANTS TO.
TYPE YOU CAN PLEASE GO TO THE
MICROPHONE.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
INPUT.
THANK YOU FAT
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
WHO CLOSER?
CAN HEAR ME NOW.
MY NAME IS CARMEN FIELDS AND I
AM A SURVIVOR OF A HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT. WHICH INCLUDED A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT
ADVANCEMENT EMPLOYEE. WHILE I
WAS EMPLOYED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
ONE ATTACKER WAS A NEW HIRE.
AND.
WHILE THIS HAPPENED DURING HIS
PROBATIONARY PERIOD IF HE FREELY
ADMITTED TO DOING EVERYTHING. AS
DETAILED IN THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD. RULING.
HE WAS PASSED ON PROBATION.
AND HE STILL WORKS FOR THE
STATE.
I ON THE OTHER HAND WAS
ENCOURAGED AND.
MOVE TO A LESS DESIRABLE
POSITION OUTSIDE OF
HEADQUARTERS.
BECAUSE I MADE HIM
UNCOMFORTABLE.
THE CHP TOOK OVER ELEVEN MONTHS
TO DO THEIR INVESTIGATION.
WHICH I RECEIVE NO SUPPORT
AND WAS LEFT IN THE DARK.
JUST HAD A COMPLETE NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON MY LIFE.
AND MY CAREER.
AS I AM NO LONGER EMPLOYED AND
OF MY NAME SOUNDS FAMILIAR.
I WAS.
IN NOVEMBER THE CUT ON TO
SACRAMENTO BEE.
STORY.
I WAS THE HOST BUT THIS INCIDENT
DURING INTERVIEWS
FOR PROMOTION. OF WHICH I NEVER
GOT A PROMOTION.
YOU WANT TO CHANGE CULTURE.
VICTIMS SHOULD MAKE UP TO RELIVE
THE EXPERIENCE OVER AND OVER.
YOU SHOULD THE SANDMAN SPECIALLY
ONE LITTLE.
WORK UNDERCOVER TO COME TO YOUR
HOME TO INVESTIGATE YOUR WEALTHY
ATTACK.
ALL OF YOU SHOULD HE SHOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM REQUIRE VICTIMS
OF HARASSMENT. TO LEAVE IF.
THE REPLACEMENT.
AS PART OF A SETTLEMENT.
I WAS MAKING EXAMPLE OF HER
REPORTING.
MANY WOMEN NOW ARE AFRAID TO
REPORT BECAUSE THEY SAW WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME THEY SAW HER I
WAS TREATED.
I WANTED TO I WANT MY JOB BACK.
AND I WOULD REALLY LIKE YOU TO
ENCOURAGE HUGE BE TO GIVE ME MY
JOB BACK.
AND MAKE ME A STATE EMPLOYEE IT
GIVEN.
IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
WILL REACH OUT TO YOU.
IT SHOWS THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING HERE
BECAUSE WE'VE CERTAINLY HAD
EMPLOYEES IN THIS BUILDING.
WHO HAVE GOTTEN UP AND TOLD
SIMILAR STORIES?
IS ANYBODY HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
.
THIS REYES. THOUGH I'M SORRY.
ONE MORE ONE MORE SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OTIS
JACKSON.
.
I DON'T HAVE ANY PREPARED
COMMENTS FOR TODAY I'M I WISH
I'D BEEN ABLE TO GET ON THE
AGENDA THIS IS BEEN A VERY.
THOUGHTFUL AND OPEN MINDED.
FORUM WE'VE LEARNED A LOT OF
INFORMATION.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SAY IS THAT
TIME?
I WORK IN CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT FOR QUITE A FEW YEARS
I'VE BEEN TRAINED AS A.
INSTRUCTOR AND FACILITATOR AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION.
IT'S VERY TECHNICAL LIFE'S WORK
IS VERY SPECIFIC.
ON THERE ARE.
ROLES DUTIES RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT ARE LAID OUT FOR ALL LEVEL
OF THE HIERARCHY IN AN
ORGANIZATION TO BE FOLLOW.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE.
TO PROTECT THE.
CHOOSER.
ALEX THE PERSON AT.
PRESENTS THE ALLEGATION AND THEY
ARE TO.
PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO PROTECT
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS
HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT.
THE DUTY TO RESPOND.
IS A DUTY TO RESPOND AT THE
LOWEST RESPONSIBLE LEVEL.
KEEP VIS RELIABILITY.
AND THAT'S ABILITY OF THE WORK
ENVIRONMENT GOVERNMENT.
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BUSINESS
IN A CIVILIZED AND EIGHT LEGAL
MATTER.
.
I GOT INTERESTED IN THIS
PARTICULAR FORM BECAUSE
I WAS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ON
TWO TEN.
AND I HEARD AN INTERVIEW.
BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA.
SO I PULLED OVER AND CALLED HER
OFFICE.
BECAUSE I THINK I HAVE SOMETHING
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE SITUATION.
I THINK I HAVE SOMETHING TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE SITUATION I
CAME UP AND MET WITH HER BRIEFLY
ON MONDAY.
AND SHE RECOMMENDED STAYING OVER
FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD.
I WANT TO TALK TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE ABOUT
TRAINING LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
I THINK LEGISLATIVE STAFF CAN
BE TRAINED ON A REGIONAL BASIS.
THE QUALITY OF THE TRAINING IS
ESSENTIAL.
ONE OF THE.
INTRICATE ASPECTS AND ONE OF THE
COMPARATIVE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
TRAINING IS THAT IT'S NOT
EFFECTIVE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE IT BUT IT'S NOT
WELL ONE THING AND I'M GOING TO
BE BRIEF HERE BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS ABOUT IT THE A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE STANDARD
FOR TRAINING PUT TO OUR PERIOD.
BECAME A PROLIFERATION OF
VIDEOS.
SO THE POLITICAL RACE IN THE
VIDEOS ONLY GAVE YOUR TIME AWAY
FROM YOUR DESK.
WHERE YOU COULD GO AND YOU CAN
SEE SOMETHING YOU'RE PROBABLY ON
THE WAY INTO THAT?
TRAINING.
SEE THE VIDEO.%
ANYONE WHO WOULD HAVE TO SAY
BECAUSE THERE ARE PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT THESE THINGS IN A GIDDY
CONAWAY.
WE KNOW THAT.
BUT.
TALK ABOUT.
TRAINING IT HAS TO BE ON SITE IT
HAS TO BE IMMERSIVE HAS TO BE
ROLE PLAYING.
IT'S GOTTA BE VERY SPECIFIC TO
TALK ABOUT THE LIABILITY THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL AND ORGANIZATION
PASS.
BECAUSE THERE NEW LAWS AND
STANDARDS THAT.
GIVE COURTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY FIFTY OR SOME. LEVEL OF.
LIABILITY.
AND YOUR PERSONAL RESOURCES CAN
BECOME CHALLENGE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION.
IN THE NONPROFIT.
THEIR BUSINESS TAKES
VERY BAD HIT.
IN THE PUBLIC AND FINANCIALLY.
SO IN THE TRAINING WHAT I
PROPOSE TO DO. IS TO TRAIN
INDIVIDUALS ABOUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND OBLIGATE THEM.
FOR CHANGING THE CULTURE.
IS TO GET THEM TO DO A COUPLE
OF.
TRAINING TECHNIQUE.
ITEMS.
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT THE
LIABILITY OF THE EMPLOYER
DETERMINATE I GIVE YOU ONE MORE
MINUTE PLEASE YANKEE THAT
DETERMINE THAT THE. THAT THE
LIABILITY STANDARD THAT THE
EMPLOYEE.
HAS THEY BECOME VERY CLEAR ON.
AND WITH THAT.
LATER ABOUT BE HAPPY TO COME
BACK SACRAMENTO ME. TALK TO THE
GROUP PREPARE SOME.
DIRECT COMMENTS.
I HAVE A TENTATIVE.
.
TRAINING OUTLINED.
THAT WILL ACCOMPLISH ALL THOSE
THINGS IF YOU ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT EARLIER TODAY THAT YOU
HEARD THE NEGATIVES ASSOCIATED
WITH. THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING.
I HAVE THAT AND I'M A CERTIFIED
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR.
DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
FINAL COMMENTS.
THE DAY.
REYES.
LEAVE MY PLAN WITH YOU.
OKAY WE ONE MORE SPEAKER I'M
GONNA ASK ANYBODY ELSE WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK TO PLEASE GO GET UP AND
GET IN LINE NOW OTHERWISE THIS
WILL BE THE FINAL SPEAKER IN TWO
MINUTES PLEASE OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ON MY FEEL ARE MORE
OPTIMISTIC.
AFTER HEARING ALL THIS
DISCUSSED BUT I DID WHEN I CAME
IN.
I'M THE REASON I'M HERE IS WE'VE
BEEN VISITING WITH STAFF IN THE
CAPITAL HERE PER. FEW WEEKS.
MAYBE IN A COUPLE MONTHS
AND WE'VE HAD A SPECIFIC.
ALONG THE PER TRYING TO HAVE.
PUT ON THE BOOKS EXACTLY STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD PLEASE
HOMONYMS ROGER BENTLEY. AND UP
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
ADVOCATE FOR IS AN ADJUSTMENT IN
CLERGY.
MANDATED REPORTING.
AND IN OUR VISITING WE CAME THIS
COMMISSION CAME TO OUR
ATTENTION.
AND WE REALIZE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
SAY.
I REPRESENT A NETWORK PEOPLE
THEIR AUTHORS.
CHILD VIEW SURVIVORS.
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND WE REALIZE
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE CAN SHARE WITH YOU.
THAT IF NOTHING ELSE YOU COULD
LEARN FROM THE MISTAKES OF THE
CULTURE THAT I CAME FROM.
AND ONE THING THAT I WANT TO
MENTION THAT I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THIS DISCUSSION.
IS THE CONCEPT OF UNDUE
INFLUENCE.
NOW.
I'VE SEEN UNDUE INFLUENCE IN
JUST BRIEFAMOUNT OF TIME THAT
I'VE BEEN HERE VISITING.
.
IT'S THE OUR WORD IS RELIGION.
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID.
TO TAKE THAT ON.
I WANT I WANT TO TELL YOU ENOUGH
WASN'T GOING TO BRING THAT UP
BUT WHAT I WANT TO TELL YOU.
IS THAT.
CULTURE IS AFFECTED.
BY THE WAY THAT RELIGIOUS
LEADERS
ARE BEING TREATED.
IF YOU MAKE AN EXCEPTION.
FOR CLERGYMAN OR PRIEST
WHO IS ABUSING CHILDREN.
THAT'S GONNA AFFECT YOUR
CULTURE.
SO I'D LIKE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO.
GOING TO DETAIL WITH YOU ON THIS
AT A FUTURE TIME.
I'M MY GIVEN OUT PRINT MIKE.
CONTACT INFORMATION.
I'M JUST GOING CONCLUDED I'M
AWARE PERSONALLY OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE SUFFERING.
A GREAT DEAL BECAUSE OF THE
EXCEPTIONS THAT ARE MADE TO.
CLERGY
AND PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF
POWER.
SO IN THIS OUT HIS FEAR OF.
I'M ASKING YOU WOULD HAVE THE
COURAGE.
TO TAKE THIS ISSUE ON.
AND I CAN POINT OUT TO THE
CALIFORNIA LAW.
FORMERLY.
.
IT'S ON THE BOOKS.
FOR CLERGY MANDATED REPORTING.
CALIFORNIA COURTS
HAVE BEEN RULING.
AGAINST THE FIRST AMENDMENT
DEFENSE.
AND ALL OVER TRYING TO PROPOSE
SPECIFICALLY IS TO TAKE THOSE
RULINGS.
CODIFY THEM IN THE CALIFORNIA
LAW.
SEE ENOUGH OF THIS LEGISLATION
ENOUGH OF THIS LITIGATION.
AND THIS IS GET TO THE POINT.
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE IS A CRIME
AND NEEDS TO BE REPORTED TO THE
AUTHORITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
SOME APPARATUS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN I JUST
I AM VERY PLEASED WITH THE
DIRECTION OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE.
BEGINNING
WITH THE ISSUE OF CULTURE.
AS ARE SENATOR INDICATED THERE
IT'S A COLLECTIVE EYE ROLLING.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS.
BUT IT IS CLEAR FROM THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE'VE RECEIVE
TODAY. THAT THAT IS WHERE WE
MUST BEGIN.
AND I APPRECIATE NOW THAT WE
WILL BE DIGGING DEEP.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
JUST AS WE'RE LOOKING FOR WHAT
WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE AND I
APPRECIATE THE DIRECTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR EVERYBODY'S
NAM FOCUS AND EVERYBODY BEING
PRESENT OF FOR THE MEETING AND I
HOPE THAT WE CONTINUE THAT THAT.
ENTHUSIASM BECAUSE THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
AND IT'S GREAT TO HAVE EVERYBODY
ON HERE AND.
GIVING THE ATTENTION TO THE
PANELISTS AND I OF COURSE WANT
TO THANK THE PANELISTS FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS IT WAS REALLY.
TREMENDOUS AND VERY VERY
ELIMINATING
I WAS GONNA BE A WONDERFUL
FOUNDATION FOR US TO NOW BEGIN.
TO THEM LOOK AT OUR POLICY
SPECIFICALLY.
MITCHELL.
DURING THE MEAL OKAY WE ARE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU